Hallo Wolfgang, hallo Stefan.
Sag mal, bist du schon angekommen im Metaverse?
Gute Frage, denn du siehst ja auch gerade meine Beine nicht.
Stimmt, es ist tatsächlich diese Frage mit den Beinen. War jetzt gar nicht Thema im Buch, aber war große Marketing Aktion von Facebook. Ja, die Beine sind jetzt aufgetaucht. Ich musste daran denken, die Tagesschau hat doch irgendwann mal umgestellt auf neue Kamerabewegungen oder wie auch immer, dass man auch in der Tagesschau die Sprecher mal mit Beinen sieht, weil die Kamera von rechts geflogen kommt oder so. Und um das anzuteasern hatte man in den Tagesthemen nur Beine als so ins Studio gestellt, wo sich die Leute wundern sollten, hä, wieso stehen da so Beine rum? Und ich habe das damals für eine wahnsinnig dumme Aktion gefunden, weil es eine wahnsinnig bescheuerte Aktion war. Gleichzeitig dachte ich so, naja gut, hat zumindest einen kleinen Gag, weil man hat dann diese Fotos auf Twitter und so weiter gesehen. Also die digitale Sphäre hat sich dann wieder über diese eine Sekunde sichtbaren Beine da aufgeregt. Man war also schon irgendwie in so einer virtuellen Welt und so. Und ja, tatsächlich hat Facebook dieses Niveau an. Wir machen Werbung zum Thema Beine, die sichtbar sind in Medien. Wirklich nochmal grandios unterboten, in der sie das zur zentralen Marketing Aussage ihres letzten großen Aufschlags da die Woche gemacht haben. Nämlich zu sagen, und jetzt haben die Avatare auch Beine.
Und wer verdammt mal ist überhaupt für dieses Design des Facebook Metaverse verantwortlich? Es sieht ja grauenhaft aus. Es ist ja nichts, was in irgendeiner Weise in einem Lust erweckt, dort Mitglied zu werden, Bürger zu werden in diesem neuen Universum. Es ist so furchtbar, dass ich mich so wundere, dass man doch viel Geld ausgibt, auch für die Entwicklung des Metaverse, aber dass man offenbar nicht mal ein paar gute Innenarchitekten engagiert hat, die mal darüber nachdenken, wie würde denn, wenn man tatsächlich so futuristisch sein will, ein neues Wohnen, Leben und all das aussehen? Weil das sind ja einfach nur solche aseptischen, komischen Konferenzhölln, die da sich auftun und nichts weiter.
Ja, und das ist wirklich schräg, weil wenn man sich die Facebook-Technik-Abteilung, und sie haben ja ein riesiges Research and Development, anschaut, dann arbeiten die ja an fotorealistischen Holographien und so weiter. Nur wenn man sich dann das anguckt, was tatsächlich auf dem Markt präsent ist gerade, sieht man, ja, das dauert noch zehn Jahre, weil es sieht scheiße aus. Zumindest diese 2D-Abbildung, die man dann so sieht, klar, wenn man es dann selber erlebt, ist noch mal ein anderes Gefühl und so, aber ja, es sieht nach Hölle aus und wird auch so erfunden von sehr vielen Menschen.
Es kann ja ohnehin noch dauern, das wissen wir aus dem Buch von Matthew Ball, noch eine kurze Anmerkung zur Tagesschau, das muss sein, stilistischer Natur, du hast mitbekommen, dass ist jetzt keinen Krawattenzwang mehr bei den Nachtsendungen der Tagesschau.
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Ein Moderator hat jetzt auch schon auf die Krawatte verzichtet. Ich befinde mich jetzt quasi im Widerstand, indem ich noch Krawatte trage, oder?
Hast du heute auch keine?
Heute habe ich auch keine.
Was ist das, der Lotterleben zieht ein?
Nee, das ist ein Stehkrankenhemd, da kann man keine Krawatte zu Hause.
Man kann es nicht ausreden. Das habe ich tatsächlich nicht mitbekommen. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, wie viele Knöpfe lassen sie offen? Das ist die Reaktion, die ich am meisten bekommen habe, nachdem ich bei 3SAT ohne Krawatte im Anzug zu sehen war. Wie auch die Frau hier in Frankfurt, ich habe ihren Namen leider nicht präsent. Frau Nikitin. Die dann schon meinte, sie wollen Manschettenknöpfe und keine Krawatte. Und wir sagten, wir wollen den Trend jetzt setzen. Also ich, du natürlich nicht. Ich bin jetzt werde ich nach googeln nachher, wie die Tagesschausprecher 0 uhr 30 aussehen, wenn sie da ohne Krawatte die Nachrichten vortragen.
Normalerweise müssen zwei Knöpfe auf sein und nicht nur der oberste.
Habe ich dann auch gehört, aber ich dachte mir, sonst sieht es zu Olaf Scholz mäßig aus.
Aber kommen wir zu Matthew Ball, das Metaverse und wie es alles revolutionieren wird im Wahlen Verlag erschienen. Das sind 300 eng beschriebene Seiten über Gegenwart Zukunft und vor allem auch über die Vergangenheit, also was sich in den vergangenen 20 Jahren getan hat. Und ein Hauptaugenmerk von Matthew Ball liegt auf der Computerspieleindustrie. Man kann fast sagen, die Computerspieleindustrie wird als entscheidender Gameplayer eingeführt für das, was im Metaverse uns blühen könnte. Und was immer wir jetzt gleich zu dem Buch sagen, ich würde schon mal jetzt festhalten wollen, Stefan, wir müssen, glaube ich, um Zeitgenossen zu bleiben, um einen solchen Podcast wie Die Neuen Zwanziger zu machen, unbedingt im nächsten Jahr gemeinsam auf die gamescom nach Köln fahren und dann sehen wir uns mal an, wie weit es da schon ist. Denn wir haben diesen Konsens zwischen uns, dass wir die unmittelbare Begegnung schätzen, dass wir uns freuen, mit Freunden Cocktail trinken zu gehen oder du dann auch noch Sport machst und all das. Aber ich habe so meine Zweifel daran, dass das wirklich viele so sehen. Denn die Zahlen, die hier präsentiert werden, die Trends, die hier gesetzt werden bzw. rezipiert werden, die zeugen doch auch von etwas ganz anderem. Nämlich, dass das Metaverse vielleicht nicht so sein wird, wie Mark Zuckerberg sich das vorstellt. Dass es aber offenbar eine ganz große Lust bei Menschen gibt, ins Digitale abzuwandern und die physische Welt zu verlassen.
Genau. Das ist vielleicht auch eine der ganz großen Lehren aus dem Buch, wenn wir Metaverse hören, nicht immer gleich an die Brille auf dem Kopf denken, die alles verdeckt und einen so rausnimmt. Sondern es kann in viele Richtungen gehen. Man weiß es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so genau. Dass du die GamesCon ansprichst, ist ja witzig, weil das ist ja auch eine Vorortveranstaltung. In der dann alle vor Ort in der Schlange stehen und physisch darauf warten müssen, dass der Platz frei wird, körperlich, um dann mal kurz schon mal drei Monate vorher einzutauchen, was sie danach stundenlang zu Hause machen. Ich habe den ganzen Sinn nie verstanden, wie mir auch das Gaming weiterhin fremd bleibt, allerdings. So wie es ist, dass ich immer noch der Einzige bin, ohne Führerschein und alle anderen Führerschein haben, spielen auch alle um mich herum irgendwelche Spiele. Also wenn ich irgendwelche Leute zum Mittagessen treffe, beginnen die plötzlich Gespräche und referieren auf gemeinsame Erlebnisse, die sie stundenlang am Tag zuvor hatten, wo ich dann, ah ja, stimmt, ihr wart wieder in eurer komischen Welt da, und habt irgendwie Gemüse gesät und sowas. Also in der Sicht, man kommt ja nicht ganz drum rum. Ich halte mich weiter davon fern, auch damit Leute mir was zu erzählen haben, wenn sie mich sehen, mir dann egal, ob das aus virtuellen Welten Geschichten sind.
Diese Zahlen sind ja erstaunlich. Also wir sprechen bei jungen Menschen von 75 bis 100 Prozent, je nach Alterskohorte, die einfach Computerspiele spielen. Es ist jetzt nicht mehr so, wie man das früher vielleicht in der Klasse hatte, als wir zur Schule gegangen sind, dass da so fünf, sechs, sieben, acht gespielt haben, und dann wurden das vielleicht irgendwann mal mehr, sondern es spielen jetzt einfach alle Computer. Das ist jetzt keine neue Erkenntnis, aber die sollte man doch ganz klar sich vor Augen halten, wenn wir jetzt über das sprechen, was das Metaverse dann eigentlich ist. Du hast es ja schon gesagt, man kann es so schwer definieren. Was ist es denn eigentlich? Vielleicht können wir, bevor wir mal so chronologisch durchgehen, erst mal so eine Definition vorlesen, die Matthew Ball vorschlägt. Also Matthew Ball ist jemand, der sowohl für Tech-Unternehmen gearbeitet hat, sie berät, der auch journalistisch tätig ist und der jetzt eigentlich der Denker des Metaverse ist und von allen konsultiert wird. Und er schreibt dann, hier ist also, was ich meine, wenn ich über das Metaverse schreibe und spreche. Ein massiv skaliertes und interoperables Netzwerk von in Echtzeit gerenderten virtuellen 3D-Welten, die synchron und dauerhaft von einer praktisch unbegrenzten Anzahl von Nutzern mit einem individuellen Gefühl der Präsenz und mit einer Kontinuität der Daten von Identität, Geschichte, Berechtigungen, Objekte, Kommunikation und Zahlungen erlebt werden können. Was jetzt sehr, sehr schwierig erst einmal und sehr abstrakt klingt. Bedeutet mal etwas leicht übersetzt. Massiv skaliert und interoperables Netzwerk heißt, dass wir verschiedene Netzwerke haben, Welten, durch die wir gemeinsam gehen, durch die wir gehen können, durch die wir das eine zum anderen mitnehmen können. Also wie wir das in der realen Welt auch können. Es gibt in diesem Buch das Bild von einem Kind, das kann mit Barbie und Marvel-Helden zusammen aus Figürchen in die Badewanne steigen. Und diese Interoperabilität muss man erst mal online herstellen. In Echtzeit, also es ist eine Live-Nes, die ganz wichtig ist. Also es ist etwas anderes als jetzt der Podcast, den wir im Nachhinein hören. Da hatte ich auch viele Fragen zum Thema Live-Nes. 3D ist entscheidend, synchron, dauerhaft. Also es bleibt auch da. Es ist nicht einfach nur für den Moment, sondern man kann es wieder begehen wie einen wirklichen Raum. Und dann die Anzahl von Nutzern ist unbegrenzt und die muss aber uns auch präsent sein. Also wir könnten auch unbegrenzt von vielen Hörern und Hörer gehört werden als Podcast. Aber denjenigen, die den Podcast hören, denen ist nicht bewusst, nicht irgendwie spürbar, dass den 40.000 andere auch gerade hören. Das ist im Metaverse anders. Und es geht dann um so eine Kontinuität und um Zahlung, die Kommunikation zu diesen Punkten kommen wir dann noch.
Genau, all das dröseln wir jetzt nach und nach auf. Und er macht es uns sehr einfach, indem er auch einen historischen Einstieg findet ins Buch. Er kommt auf Vannevar Bush zu sprechen. Wir kennen ihn alle nicht, aber er war der Präsident der Carnegie. Das heißt ja nicht Carnegie, sondern Carnegie, habe ich gehört. Institution of Washington war. Dort Mimics irgendwie postulierte, also Memory Extender, was auch immer man sich in den 1930er Jahren darunter vorstellte. Und er gründete damals mit das Office of Scientific Research and Development mit nahezu unbegrenzten Mitteln. Unter anderem daraus hervorgegangen ist das Manhattan Project, also die Atombombe. Und ganz entscheidend nach 45 hat man sich entschieden, Vannevar Bushs Empfehlung zu folgen und zwar die Investitionshöhen zu belassen, auch wenn man gerade keine Kriegswirtschaft hat, also gar kein echtes Problem bewältigen muss. Zuerst hat man Hitler besiegt und dann hat man sich mit der Zukunft beschäftigt. Also so wird das hier gemacht. Und klar, das ist dann Grundlegung für später Internet und silicon Valley und so weiter. Und dann großer Sprung nach vorne. Diese Kulturgeschichte dröselt er auch später auf, aber wir wissen, das Internet, der Tablet-Computer und das Metaverse, das hat alles kulturelle Vorboten. Legendär ist ja, wie sie bei Google immer noch vom Star Trek Computer und so weiter da einfach nacheifern. Und das Metaverse selbst ist also heute grundlegend irgendwie zu finden, bei Mark Zuckerberg natürlich seinen formulierten Zielen und Facebook als Meta umzubenennen. Aber auf Augenhöhe irgendwie ja auch Nadella, also Microsoft, der natürlich mit HoloLens und dann Minecraft kaufen und lauter solche Sachen sich da auch schon mal die Landschaft zurechtlegt. Der Nvidia-Chef, Jensen Huang. Die Wirtschaft im Metaverse wird größer sein als die Wirtschaft der physischen Welt. Und er selber wird die ganzen Chips dafür grundlegend legen, egal welches Unternehmen das wie macht. Man wird dafür Rechenbauer brauchen.
Matthew Ball geht von einer zweistelligen Billionenhöhe aus.
Ja, also groß, groß, groß wird gedacht. Unity Technologies und die Roblox Corporation spielen ja am Anfang schon eine Rolle. Tencent mit der Hyper Digital Reality und sehr vielen Patenten, die man sich da schon mal geholt hat oder vor allem auch Markennamen. Es gibt eine südkoreanische Metaverse Allianz mit 450 Unternehmen. Südkorea kennen wir ja als sowohl kultureller wie technischer Vorreiter. Also wenn da was ist, weiß das immer schon in so eine Richtung. ByteDance hat sich viele Metaverse Marken schon mal gesichert. Also TikTok ist da auch auf dem Weg. Und die anderen Player, die er noch nennt und das finde ich schon sehr gut, die chinesische kommunistische Partei. Sie ist nämlich sehr besorgt und hat ja auch da schon groß eingegriffen. Nicht nur technisch, sondern auch wie viele Minuten dürfen die Leute eigentlich zu Hause so spielen. Und er nennt Crystal Schaldemose, die Chefunterhändlerin der EU, die auch, Zitat, viele Pläne des Metaversums zutiefst besorgniserregend findet. Und damit hat er uns schon mal ein eigenes Metaverse des Metaverse aufgebaut, nämlich am Anfang die großen Player einfach alle mal genannt. Wir kennen jetzt so ein bisschen die Landschaft der großen Player, die entweder hyped oder besorgt sind oder beides, je nachdem. Und dann kommt die Frage, was ist das Metaverse? Und dann ein sehr kultureller Einstieg. Das fand ich ja richtig gut. Ich kannte natürlich viele Sachen, die er da nennt, nicht. Snowcrasher und so mal gehört.
Geht auf das Buch von Snowcrasher ein. Wir haben das mal in Wohlstand für alle besprochen. Aber es ist ein vollkommen uninteressanter Roman, in dem aber das Wort Metaverse vorkommt. Und es wird da so ein bisschen eine digitale Welt gezeichnet, die sehr dystopisch ist. Und der Autor Neil Stevenson gilt von da an als der große Prophet, was er aber selbst immer wieder von sich weiß. Das ist eine Welt, die also im Digitalen stattfindet, die auch da eine Infrastruktur hat, die aber im höchsten Maße eine privatisierte ist, beziehungsweise es gibt nur kommerzielle Räume dort. Jetzt kann man sagen, in unserem Internet gibt es auch überwiegend kommerzielle Räume, in denen wir uns befinden. Wir kennen das mit all diesen Plattformen. Aber das ist dann auch noch gleichzeitig mafiös durchdrungen. Es wird so ein Krimiplot erzählt. Es ist wirklich kein interessantes Werk. Man muss sich halt nur merken, dass der Begriff Metaverse dadurch sehr geprägt wurde von Neil Stevenson und seinem Roman. Was für mich entscheidender eigentlich ist, ist, dass er dann noch mal so einen kurzen Abriss macht darüber, dass Science Fiction sehr stark damit immer gespielt hat, dass es eine Sehnsucht im Menschen gibt, irgendetwas anderes zu sehen. Wir gehen ja auch ins Kino, um irgendwas anderes zu sehen. Aber dass wir tatsächlich eine Sehnsucht wohl haben nach so welch so so einer Immersion, das bringt er dann zum Beispiel, dass er sagt. 1935 schrieb Stendige Weinbaum eine Kurzgeschichte mit dem Titel Pygmalions Brille, in der es um die Erfindung einer magischen VR-ähnlichen Brille geht, die einen Film produziert, der einem Sicht und Ton gibt. Du bist in der Geschichte. Du sprichst zu den Schatten und die Schatten antworten. Und anstatt auf einen Bildschirm zu sein, dreht sich die Geschichte nur um dich. Und du bist in ihr. Also das haben wir so eine Proto-Metaverse-Geschichte. Dann geht er ein auf eine Kurzgeschichte von Ray Bradbury. Da wird das Kinderzimmer zu einem virtuellen Ort. Und die Eltern erreichen ihre Kinder nicht mehr. Sie sind dort eingeschlossen. Dann geht er natürlich auf Philip K. Dick kurz ein. Auch da gibt es dann Welten, die geformt werden. Worldcraft ist dann das entscheidende Stichwort hier. Auf Asimov kommt er auch noch zu sprechen. Das heißt, dieser kulturelle Einstieg ist für ihn ganz wichtig, um zu zeigen, die Literatur kann natürlich durch ihr fantastisches Denken etwas vorwegnehmen, weil sie erst einmal nicht an physikalische Grenzen gebunden ist. Jetzt aber, so ist dann eine These des Buches, kommen wir langsam dorthin. Im Übrigen nicht so schnell wie Mark Zuckerberg und manche denken, sondern er sagt schon tatsächlich ziemlich langsam dorthin, dass wir solche Fantasien in die Tat umsetzen können. Denn was wir ja auch erleben ist, das Metaverse wird hier nicht einfach so als ein Luftschloss verkauft, sondern es wird immer ganz stark auch an seine Materialität rückgebunden. Also welche Computerships braucht man eigentlich, um eine Welt zu schaffen, in der sich 50 Leute begegnen und es sich für sie auch wirklich so anfühlt, als seien sie mit 50 Leuten gerade in einem Raum.
Genau, weil was nützt es, später zu erfahren, dass man bei Fortnite einem Konzert mit 20 Millionen Zuschauern beigewohnt hat, wenn es aber auf 250.000 Instanzen aufgeteilt ist, und man gar nicht alle gesehen hat. Ich fand diesen Einverweis auf Philip Dix, 53, The Trouble with Bubbles noch gut, weil die Menschen sind technisch in der Lage, in den Weltraum zu fliegen, machen es auch und finden dort aber nichts. Also nutzen sie die Technik, die ihnen den den Exit erlaubt hat, um den Exit in selbst geschaffene neue Welten dann zu machen. Und das ist ja ein ganz interessantes Gleichnis. Und da dann Worldcraft, also einfach die Welt wird nicht entdeckt, sondern geschaffen. Also dieses Bild, weil das ist ja auch das, woran Facebook gerade so ein bisschen leidet. Dass sie eigentlich diese technische Welt schaffen, aber sie gar nicht wissen, wofür eigentlich. Außer weil sie halt möglich ist. Es ist halt technisch möglich. Und jetzt auch mit Beinen und so. Man kommt da mit solchen Sachen, aber man weiß gar nicht, aber wozu jetzt genau? Es ist ja auch erstaunlich, dass es diesmal diese Spielewelten sind und gar nicht die Pornografie oder so. Also wo Menschen so mit extremer Leidenschaft und Lust so reingehen und dann technisch ihnen ein Angebot gemacht wird. Ja, du kannst jetzt Bilder und Bewegebild und so weiter. Und es wird immer raffinierter. Und das ist ja hier diesmal nicht so. Die Leute spielen eigentlich schon. Und die haben jetzt auch gar nicht den mega Antrieb, sich eine Brille aufzusetzen. Der Bildschirm reicht ihnen eigentlich. Und Facebook muss extreme Anstrengungen machen, um den Leuten überhaupt zu erklären, wo will man denn hin. Also man stößt wieder in so einen Weltraum hervor, wo man dann sieht, ja, aber ist ja gar nichts. Jetzt sind wir doch an unser Raumschiff gefesselt irgendwie.
Bemerkenswert, dass immer wieder auf dieses Business-Meeting dann verwiesen wird von Zuckerberg. Dabei ist ja bei jedem Menschen, wenn er Business-Meeting hört, erst mal so eine Stimmung da, ach ja, bestimmt habe ich morgen wieder eins. Da sagt man ja nicht hurra, endlich in der Metaverse-Welt. Also man würde ja eigentlich gerne ins Metaverse, um keine Business-Meetings mehr zu haben. Das ist ja eigentlich das. Und das Versprechen von Zuckerberg ist einfach, nö, wir machen das hier und hier könnt ihr mit und ohne Beine dann rumlaufen.
Genau. Schweben vor allem, man schwebt dann so um sich herum. Genau, also dieser, wir müssen natürlich noch William Gibson Neuromancer hier nennen. Ja klar, Cyberspace und The Matrix. Aber der Umschlagpunkt ist ja da 1986, der C64 wird erfunden. Und damit bekommt, das ist immer wieder erstaunlich, wie recht Schamara hatte, dass so neue Ideen kommen entweder über eine Technik oder ein Buch. Und jetzt haben wir hier diese Geschichte, wie das ganz viel übers Buch kam und dann über die Technik. Also wie der C64 da eigentlich mitzuspielen, wie Habitat von Lucasfilm. Also es sind auch so Geschichtsschreibungen, die kennt man überhaupt nicht. Ja, das Lucasfilm damals, nachdem sie das ganze Star Wars Zeug gemacht haben und so, dann einfach zehn Jahre später. Ja, jetzt machen wir mal dieses Computerspiel auf eigentlich völlig untauglicher Hardware. So, aber sie haben halt angefangen, Computerspiele zu machen. Und das eskaliert ja dann vor sich hin, bis man hier dann schon auf second Life zu sprechen kommt. Linden Labs, und es ist interessant, wie er das hier betont, für den Lintendollar ein, also es scheint für ihn das interessante zu sein, dass das nicht nur eine Welt ist, in der man so irgendwie halt was spielen kann oder sich begegnen kann, sondern ne, da wird so richtig die Welt verdoppelt, da gibt es plötzlich Geld. Und dieses Geld funktioniert auch direkt zwischen zwei Leuten, die sich da begegnen. Das wird nicht vermittelt über irgendwen oder so. Und da hat er ja dieses starke Urteil, dass der Hersteller Linden Labs hier gar nicht so sehr wie ein Spieleentwickler agierte, sondern schon wie eine Regierung. Und damit ist ja dann auch sozusagen dieser kulturelle Bogen geschlagen. Also wir haben die Ideengeschichte, wir haben jetzt die Technik, die es irgendwie leistet. Und ab den 90ern beginnt dann diese Art der Geschichte. Und dann ist es einfach so eine Perlenkette, die sich da aufdröselt bis hin zu diesem Travis scott Fortnite Konzert 2020. Klar ist ja auch Corona und so. 28 Millionen Spieler treffen sich, um einem Musikereignis beizuwohnen. Wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass Christopher Nolan Inception in Fortnite zeigt und solche Sachen.
Travis scott hat da dann ein Konzert aufgeführt.
Genau, riesengroß. Aber naja, und getoppt wird diese Fortnite-Geschichte immer noch mal von Roblox die ganze Zeit. Roblox immer noch mal eine Nummer größer, eine Nummer extremer. 15 Jahre Geschichte, 13 Jahre fast nichts und dann zwei Jahre lang exponentielles Wachstum. Klar, Corona und so. Aber trotzdem Roblox. Also wer bis heute noch nichts von Roblox gehört hat, der muss es jetzt langsam aufholen, sonst ist man irgendwann abgemeldet. Selbst wenn man es nicht selber spielen möchte.
Nach Angaben der Roblox Corporation nutzten im zweiten Quartal 2020 75 Prozent der Kinder zwischen neun und zwölf Jahren in den Vereinigten Staaten regelmäßig die Plattform. Zusammengenommen erreichten die beiden Anwendungen jeweils mehr als sechs Milliarden Stunden monatlicher Nutzung. Also da wird jetzt noch Minecraft hinzugenommen, die sich auf mehr als 100 Millionen verschiedene Spielwelten erstreckten und von über 15 Millionen Nutzern gestaltet werden. Und dann gibt es da ein, also es ist ja so, ich hatte es damals erklärt, dass man dort Spiele kreieren kann und dann auch Leute zu seinen Spielen einladen kann, beziehungsweise anlocken kann, ihn dann auch wieder was verkaufen kann. Jeder wird ja dann auch so sein Unternehmer. Und es ist so, dass ein Spiel, das von zwei Hobbyspielern entwickelt wurde, 2017, Adopt Me, das erfolgreichste ist, obwohl man da gar nicht so viel Tolles machen kann. Also man kann verschiedene Haustiere ausbrüten, sie aufziehen und mit ihnen dann auch ein bisschen Handel treiben. Aber eigentlich ist das nicht viel mehr als Tamagotchi. Bis Ende 2021 wurde die virtuelle Welt von Adopt Me mehr als 30 Milliarden Mal besucht. Das ist mehr als das 15-fache der durchschnittlichen Zahl der weltweiten Tourismus-Besuche im Jahr 2019.
Es ist erstaunlich. Wir sind schon mittendrin, eigentlich.
Wir sind mittendrin, genau. Und das würde ich auch schon mal gerne an dieser Stelle festhalten wollen. Wir werden ja auf die technischen Schwierigkeiten noch eingehen, aber wir sind schon mitten im Metaverse. Und wir sollten deshalb überhaupt nicht so spöttisch mehr über die Zuckerberg-Pläne nur reden, sondern wir sollten vielmehr die ganze Zeit uns befragen, wo ist eigentlich gerade unser Metaverse? Wo befinden wir uns gerade? Jetzt sind wir ganz stark in der analogen Welt oder inwieweit verschwimmt das denn? Das ist ja die Idee auch beim Metaverse. Ja, das eine ist, wie können wir vor Bildschirmen irgendwas erfahren und wie können Bildschirme gemacht werden in Form von Brillen, dass sie uns mehr reinziehen? Aber es geht auch darum, wie kann eigentlich die Welt sich vom Smart Home bis zur intelligenten Stadt so verwandeln, dass es Metaverse dann plötzlich für uns ist, dass wir uns darin bewegen und diesen Übergang aber gar nicht richtig merken?
Genau, das mag Zuckerberg, du hast es ja in der letzten Folge gesagt, selber so sehr auf dieses Buch oder den Outdoor zu sprechen kommt und auch Leserempfehlung gibt, finde ich interessant. Denn so richtig gut kommt ja Zuckerberg hier nicht bei Weg. Nicht so in der direkten Ansprache, sondern so wenn man sich diese Gesamtgeschichte hier mal anschaut. Denn es ist ja schon ihm ganz wichtig, uns nochmal dieses Gleichnis vorzumachen. Es ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass wir digitale Welten erschaffen oder erobern. Denn das ganze Internet ist ja die letzten 30 Jahre so hinein explodiert in die Gesellschaft. Aber über offene Standards wurden eben verschiedene Welten so zusammengeführt. Das Internet ist das Netz der Netze. Und anders als das Metaverse ist das Internet, also die ganze digitale Sphäre, die wir heute alles Mögliche so nutzen, eben nicht von denen bereits vorher schon großen Unternehmen entwickelt wurden. Google, Facebook und so weiter, das ist halt alles neu. Und das ist beim Metaverse jetzt anders. Da versuchen es immer noch. Ich habe ja eben referiert, also Microsoft, Nvidia, Facebook, Tencent, die größten Unternehmen der Welt versuchen, das Metaverse für uns zu schaffen. Und mit diesem Sachverhalt geht ja hier der Ball sehr abivalent um. Erstellt uns diesen Wunsch in den Raum, dass es auch anders sein könnte. Also dass es von Grund auf nochmal neu geschaffen wird. Allerdings finden wir natürlich auch die Wege nicht. Die rosen Unternehmen finden es auch noch nicht so richtig. Klar, es gibt diese Erfolge, Roblox und so weiter, diese spezifischen Spielerfolge, die so mit ihrer eigenen Ästhetik und so weiter mitbringen. Aber ob man jetzt wirklich ein Business Meeting bei Roblox macht, also ob das dann schon kompatibel ist, weiß man auch nicht so richtig.
Ball ist da ja fast verwundert wohl über sich selbst. Er sagt, er ist eigentlich so ein freier Marktkapitalist. Und plötzlich ruft er wieder die Regierung an und sagt ja, so institutionelle Formen, die ja auch öffentlichen digitalen Raum regeln, wären vielleicht nicht schlecht. Und das ist ja auch vielleicht nochmal das, was wir uns deutlich vor Augen führen sollen. Du hast es jetzt gerade angesprochen. Als das Internet begann, war das eine Einrichtung, die zunächst einmal von staatlichen Initiativen herrührte. Also im Sinne von die USA haben Forschungsausgaben noch unnöcher. Und so entsteht dann auch das Internet. Sehr schnell versuchen natürlich dann auch Konzerne dort Fuß zu fassen. Aber die Konzerne, die da jetzt ganz groß sind, die sind fast alle neu. Die hat es also vor der digitalen Zeit nicht gegeben. Und dann findet diese Vermachtung statt, wie wir sie jetzt erleben. Viel Macht in wenigen Händen, viel Geld in wenigen Händen. Jetzt haben aber diese wenigen Hände dieses viele Geld, um es zu investieren in das Metaverse. Das heißt, die Vermachtung findet zuerst statt, ehe überhaupt was aufgebaut werden kann. Richtig. Und das bedeutet, dass es diese öffentlichen Sphären oder solche Sphären, wie das, was wir machen, wir haben hier einen Podcast, vielleicht dann in der Weise gar nicht mehr geben kann. Und Matthew Ball betont es ja sehr deutlich, das Internet hätte auch viel teurer sein können. Also wir haben jetzt eben darüber gesprochen, wie günstig das ist mit Spotify oder wir können auch den ganzen Tag YouTube gucken. Vielleicht müssen wir Werbung über uns ergeben haben, alles gratis. Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man es schafft, das Metaverse so zu codieren, dass man für jeden Genuss bezahlen muss, wie ich auch in Frankfurt nirgendswo durch die Stadt gehen kann, was trinken, essen gehen kann, mir Klamotten nehmen kann, ohne dafür zu bezahlen. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man genau diese Stadtstruktur auf das Metaverse überträgt?
Wir erinnern uns alle noch, als die SMS bezogen auf Preis-Leistungs-mäßig teurer war, als Sachen in den Weltraum zu schießen, weil 140 Zeichen irgendwie 40 Cent gekostet haben und so was. Und diese Gefahr lauert hier immer wieder. Ich habe mir am Anfang so eine Notiz gemacht, der Tenor ist, das Metaverse muss erst mal aus den Fängen seiner technischen Gründer befreit werden. So habe ich es ein bisschen rausgelesen. Und das ist super interessant, weil er die ganze Zeit immer schreibt, wir wissen ja eigentlich noch gar nicht, was ist das Metaverse. Es ist noch, Zitat, eine nicht greifbare Idee. Und trotzdem wird schon so krass zugelangt, dass man, dass echtige Gefahr droht, dass demnächst jede Frisur, die man sich digital auf seinen Avatar setzt, einfach 10 Dollar kostet, anstatt dass man einfach sagt, nee, macht erst mal alle eure Webseite auf. Das ist jetzt gar nichts. Installiert euch ein Forum, dann könnt ihr miteinander kommunizieren. Das kam ja jetzt erst wieder, dass dann discord und wie sie alle heißen und Facebook selbst eben, da so diesen ganzen ökonomischen Kram hinterhergebaut haben. Diesmal soll er vorneweg gebaut werden. Und da fand ich es hier super interessant. Wir haben ja auch so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, diesen großen Streit, Epic, also die Leute hinter Fortnite und so, gegen Google, gegen Apple, weil Google und Apple eben diejenigen sind, die die Endgeräte betreiben und damit immer noch so ein bisschen Wegzoll haben wollen. Wie groß und tiefschürfend diese Streitereien sind und wie sehr Apple da drin verstrickt ist, obwohl wir immer denken, naja gut, Apple, was haben die schon? Gerade Kopfhörer, okay, und ein Telefon, aber keine Brille, sonst nichts und auch keine Bemühungen. Man sieht so gar nichts und man denkt so, ja gut, die sitzen es irgendwie aus oder so. Und dann Tim Cook auf der Bühne. Wir verwenden das Wort Metaverse gar nicht, weil keiner weiß, was das bedeuten soll. Also noch so schnippische Kommentare gegen Zuckerberg. Auf der anderen Seite juristisch schon hier im Hanen kämpfen verwickelt überall. Wollen sie noch ihre 30 Prozent rausholen und die Plattform absichern und eigentlich diese ökonomischen Schranken so hoch wie es geht ziehen. Eben auch aus dieser Angst, dass man noch mal ein Geschäft verliert, so wie man Musikstreaming verloren hat.
Wo man sich erst dachte, gewonnen zu haben.
Genau, aber es ist wirklich immer wieder real. Selbst die größten Unternehmen überhaupt können tatsächlich an ihrem eigenen Metier scheitern.
Das bleibt uns ja noch total offen, ob es richtig war, Apple geschlossen zu halten oder es offen zu halten, wie das dann mit anderen Plattformen oder Anbietern der Fall ist. Also diese Frage könnte man jetzt gerade so beantworten. Für Apple hat es sich doch sehr ausgezahlt, ob das im Metaverse funktionieren kann, diese Offenheit. Das ist wieder eine ganz andere Frage, weil das Metaverse, wir haben es eben schon gehört in der Definition, interoperabel sein soll, also offen sein soll für die Vermischung.
Genau, diese Definitionsfragen, das ist ja wirklich super interessant. Also wir haben virtuelle Welten. Vor allem erstmal Spiele. Das heißt, also bei Spiele gilt noch viel mehr als jetzt bei Filmen oder Podcasts oder so. Man kann es nicht gegen das Publikum entwickeln, sondern nur mit dem Publikum. Sobald die da auch nur kurz Zeit keine Lust haben und so weiter, ist einfach aussortiert. Dann wird was anderes gespielt. Der Markt ist ja riesig. Und interessanterweise kennen wir alle Super Mario und Zelda und so. Aber die noch erfolgreicheren Spiele sind die, die man kooperativ spielt. Also Animal Crossing zum Beispiel. Dieses wenig-kompetitive, aber eben gesellige, sich einer gemeinsam Aufgabe stellen. So und ich finde das super interessant, wie er von diesem, ja der Nutzer hat so einen gewissen Anspruch, er möchte es erstmal so und so. Dass er dann gleich auf diese Frage der Persistenz kommt. Wenn wir uns treffen online und zwar nicht im Sinne von wir machen nur kurz einen Kampf, sondern wir wollen ja eigentlich was aufbauen, langfristig und so weiter, braucht man eine gemeinsame Geschichtsschreibung. Und auf die sind wir technisch noch überhaupt nicht vorbereitet. Jeder hat immer die Angst, man macht das Spiel aus, man macht den Computer aus, man kennt das von früher. Man hat nicht zwischengespeichert, zagt es in alle Fortschritte, die man sich erspielt hat, weg. Und dass es da schon beginnt, also dass wir da noch keine guten Wege gefunden haben, überhaupt die Virtual-Realität mal auf ein gemeinsames Gedächtnis aufbauen zu lassen, weil es schon da mangelt, dass wir aufgrund schlechter und auch jeder hat eine andere Technik, eigentlich in unterschiedlichen Welten sind. Jemand ist mit einem iPhone 14 unterwegs und sieht alle möglichen durchgerenderten Special Effects. Und dann kommt jemand aus sozial herausfordernden Verhältnissen, wie die deutschen Politiker sagen, und hat nur ein iPhone 10 und plötzlich sieht er aber eine ganz andere Welt, obwohl er sich die Welt mit anderen teilt, weil da ganz andere Sachen gerendert oder eben nicht gerendert werden und vielleicht auch langsamer. Das heißt, jemand ist in so einer hochklassischen, ich fühl mich hier richtig wohl Welt und der andere hängt immer eine Sekunde hinterher, weil er eine technische Latenz mitbringt und es wird auch noch nicht alles gerendert, also es sieht für ihn noch hässlicher aus. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegen wir da eigentlich eine gemeinsame, nicht nur eine Gesellschaft, dass man sich gerade begegnet, sondern auch so eine gemeinsame Geschichtsschreibung, dass man an gemeinsame Erfahrungen anschließt und so weiter hin. Und dann meint er, das ist derzeit noch eine ganz große Baustelle. Also das sind alles noch so offene Fragen.
Was wir analog sofort herstellen können, also es gibt beispielsweise in Köln ja diese Brücke, wo Liebespaare hingehen und die hängen dann so ein Schloss daran, um ihre ewige Liebe zu besiegeln. Und da können die auch dann immer mal wieder vorbeigehen und gucken, ah ja, da ist das Schloss. Das ist in der digitalen Welt so ohne Weiteres nicht möglich. Und er bringt ein wunderbares Beispiel. Die zunehmende Persistenz innerhalb einzelner virtueller Welten wird jedoch für das Wachstum des Metaverse von wesentlicher Bedeutung sein. Wie ich im weiteren Verlauf dieses Buches erörtern werde, sind viele der Designideen, die in den letzten fünf Jahren populär geworden sind, nicht neu, sondern eher neu möglich. So mag es uns derzeit schwer fallen, herauszufinden, warum World of Warcraft sich für immer an die exakten Fußabdrücke eines Benutzers im frischen Schnee erinnern muss. Aber die Chancen stehen gut, dass irgendein Designer irgendwann die Antwort herausfindet und es nicht lange dauert, bis es zu einem Kernmerkmal vieler Spiele wird. Also das kennen wir aus dem gerade Beschriebenen. Oder wenn wir am Strand entlang gehen, die Spuren im Sand, wie lange bleiben sie, welche Spuren hinterlassen wir im Leben? Was ist, wenn wir bislang spurlos durch die Spiele gehen, es aber bald nicht mehr spurlos tun? Wenn sich also da eine Historizität, eine eigene Geschichte entwickelt, ist erst da auch ein menschliches Leben möglich. Denn ein Mensch ohne Geschichte ist natürlich eine Katastrophe. Also das ist dann Murmeltier, und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier, wo alles wieder von Neuem beginnt.
Genau, und er macht einen sehr guten historischen Vergleich. Er nennt ja als Einfallstor fürs Metaverse Dating. Also Spiele groß, weil es Spiele schon gibt. Aber er meint ja, das Zugpferd könnte zum Beispiel das Dating sein. Und man weiß ja, wenn man ein Selfie verschickt, dann weiß man, was der andere sieht. Weil das Bild wird, egal wer der Hersteller des eigenen Telefons ist, das Bild wird angezeigt, wie das Bild halt aussieht. Da hat man sich auf technische Standards geeinigt. Das JPG, man kann es dann größer, kleiner, wie auch immer. Aber man weiß, wie es aussieht. Mit dem Nachteil, es ist kein Livebild, sondern der andere kriegt es später. Und wenn man diesen Nachteil aufholen möchte, Dating im Metaverse mit Avataren, dann weiß man nicht genau, wie das Avatar beim anderen aussieht. Weil wir haben einen JPG-Standard oder einen PNG-Standard, und dann schicken wir uns Bilder hin und her. Den gibt es da einfach gar nicht. Jeder baut nach eigenen Kriterien irgendwie Avatare. Und die sind aber auch noch nicht kompatibel zwischen den verschiedenen Herstellern. Also es kommt noch sehr drauf an, in welcher Welt man sich eigentlich begegnet, wie man dann aufeinander wirkt und welches Wissen man selber darüber hat, wie man bei dem anderen gerade wirkt. Er kommt dann auch auf die Synchronität zu sprechen. Denn es ist immer noch das größte Hindernis, diese latenzarmen Synchronisationen hinzukriegen, weil man, und das ist dann fast eine existenzielle Frage, einfach derzeit noch nicht sagen kann, was ist hier eigentlich gerade wahr. Wer sieht hier eigentlich Wahrheit? Sehen eigentlich alle dasselbe? Oder wird so unterschiedlich gerendert, was man sieht, aufgrund von Latenzsachen, welche Geschwindigkeit bietet das Internet eigentlich gerade und so weiter, dass man weder weiß, was erleben eigentlich gerade alle, erleben alle dasselbe wie ich, bringt auch jeder seine eigene Perspektive mit, anders bei einem Bild. Jeder steht woanders im virtuellen Raum. Und dann dazu diese ganzen Rechtsfragen. Was ist, wenn ich meinen Avatar ganz toll in Cyberpunk aufgebaut habe und ich will ihn jetzt aber mitnehmen zu Fortnite? Geht das überhaupt? Nein, es geht natürlich bisher noch nicht. Aber das ist ja Grundvoraussetzung, sagt er, für dass das Metaverse dann wirklich mal so funktioniert, wie man sich das vorstellt, dass es funktionieren sollte.
Denn sonst hätte man nur einzelne abgetrennte Spielewälde, beziehungsweise dann ist es so, wie es jetzt gerade ist. Dann bleibt es so. Nur ein bisschen besser ausgefeilt technisch.
Genau, das ist so, als würde man die Arbeitsstelle wechseln und dann müsste man nochmal ganz neu neu studieren, statt einfach zu sagen, ich nehme meinen Bildungserfolg von früher natürlich mit, wie ich meinen Avatar dann auch mitnehme. Und es geht aber alles gar nicht. Da stellen sich Rechtsfragen, da stellen sich technische Fragen. Die müssen dann wirklich miteinander kompatibel sein.
Darf man in eine Welt, die Adidas kreiert hat, mit Neigschuhen hinein? In der analogen Welt genau diese Fragen sich nicht stellt. Also man kann mit den Neigschuhen in den Adidas Shop und es passiert nichts. Man muss auch nicht eine Gebühr zahlen oder bekommt Ersatzschuhe gereicht.
Genau. Und da hat das Buch so eine ganz wunderbare Ambivalenz, weil es uns auf der einen Seite am Anfang so einlädt, die ganze Kulturgeschichte der letzten 100 Jahre irgendwie als den Hinweg ins Metaverse zu beschreiben. Und dann bei den technischen Sachen merkt man, ne, das dauert noch. Also das ist noch ein paar Jahrzehnte irgendwie, bis hier solche Hollywood-Ideen aufgehen.
Man kann sagen, fünf bis zehn Jahre. Und Matthew Ball ist da dann doch meistens etwas skeptischer, was die Zeit anbelangt. Also gerade, du hast es schon angesprochen, diese Live-Nest wirklich herzustellen, muss immens schwierig sein. Also man hat einfach nicht genügend Rechenkapazitäten. Die Frage ist, wie schafft man das? Wir haben ja unglaublich viele Computer, die wir alle mit uns herumtragen, zum Beispiel in Form von Smartphones. Könnte man es schaffen, dass diese ganzen kleinen Computer, die wir mit uns herumtragen und die auch Rechenleistung haben, immer aktiv sind, damit sie quasi, wenn sie gerade nicht genutzt werden, trotzdem dafür sorgen, dass das Metaverse stabil gehalten wird, dass da genügend Rechenleistung zur Verfügung steht. Er vergleicht das mit Solarpanels. Man hat Solarpanels auf dem Dach und man braucht Strom. Aber man hat in der Regel die Situation, dass mehr Strom aufgenommen werden kann, als dann in dem entsprechenden Haushalt verbraucht wird. Und so wird das überflüssige dann eingegeben, beziehungsweise es wird eingespeist in den Strom für alle. Das heißt also, man bekommt ja dann, glaube ich, auch eine kleine Gebühr, wenn man dann Strom abgeben kann. Aber es ist nicht so, dass die Panels dann einfach sagen, ach so, es wird kein Strom mehr gebraucht. Jetzt werden wir uns abschalten und machen morgen weiter, sondern es wird weiterhin Strom erzeugt und der wird aber dann woanders eingespeist. Und das ist auch die Frage, wenn jetzt jemand drei Stunden sein Smartphone gar nicht nutzt oder vielleicht nur so nutzt, dass es nicht besonders rechenintensiv ist, kann man dann das Smartphone in irgendeiner Weise so einbinden, dass die trotzdem jetzt zur Verfügung stehende Rechenleistung genutzt werden kann, weil gerade viele Leute in der Umgebung sind, die sich im Metaverse vergnügen. Und das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen die Vision dann, dass man sagt, ja klar, man braucht diese supercomputer und vielleicht auch quantencomputer, all das, aber man wird wahrscheinlich auch so eine konstante Rechenleistung überall anzapfen müssen, damit eine Infrastruktur in dieser Weise überhaupt aufgebaut werden kann.
Genau, und selbst das wäre nur super raffinierte Brückentechnologie. Es liegt ja irgendwie nahe, hat man ja auch immer mal wieder versucht. Beim Smartphone ist es besonders schwierig, denn das verbraucht ja auch Akku in der Zeit. Also das sind einige Trade-offs, aber es steht sehr viel Rechenkraft ungenutzt drum, die man da einbinden könnte. Und seine Idee ist ja zu sagen, ja gut, am Ende wird es darauf hinauslaufen, dass zentral gerendert wird und dann nur noch Videobilder ausgespielt werden, die allerdings die Nutzerinteraktion wieder so zügig zurückspielen, dass man gar nicht merkt, dass auf einem zentralen Rechner gerendert wird. Google Stadia war ja genau diese Idee, dass man sagt, Plattform unabhängig. Also man kann auf jedem Bildschirm, egal was es ist, auch ein 3 Jahre altes Android-Telefon oder so, kann man drauf spielen, weil das Bild einfach woanders hergestellt wird. Und dann kommt es auf die Latenzen an. Und das ist interessant, wie weit die Forschung da ist. Also er nennt ja hier diese Zahl. Wenn man 15 Millisekunden statt 25 Millisekunden Ping hat, steigert das die Lust am Spaß, den Spaß am Spiel um 6 Prozent. Und wenn man es auf die Spitze treibt und sagt, die längste Entfernung, die weltweit zu überbrücken wäre, wären 12.000 Kilometer, dann sind das 45 Millisekunden. Wir befinden uns also, Zitat, in einem ständigen Kampf mit der Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Man müsste dann also Serverfarmen, wie das Netflix schon macht, irgendwo so nahe am Kunden, also da ist so eine Metropole und im Bergen, im Bergen oben steht halt schon mal so ein Server, der vorab schon mal Daten liefert, damit die nicht gar nicht erst aus Amerika angeliefert werden müssen und so, sondern kommen einfach aus dem Umfeld Stuttgarts. Und dann geht das Video schneller los und wird auch gleichortlich in eine D gerendert und man hat nicht so eine Startschwierigkeit. Bei Netflix kann man es noch irgendwie lösen, weil die können natürlich zwischenpuffern. Also das läuft ja kontinuierlich, da kann man vorladen. Das alles wird im Metaverse nicht funktionieren. Es muss live.
Alles vorhersehbar.
Es muss, genau, man kennt ja die nächsten 100 Bilder. Also die nächsten vier Sekunden sind irgendwie gesetzt, aber das ist ja hier alles ganz anders. Und das ganze Internet ist darauf nicht vorbereitet. Die Kabel liegen kreuz und quer. Es gibt diese Protokolle noch nicht, die dann wirklich mal den kürzesten Weg nehmen. Wir haben es mit einem Faktor 10 zu tun, den wir auf die technische Möglichkeit legen. Also es kann durchaus sein, dass wir einfach mit einer halben oder sogar mit einer ganzen Sekunde derzeit immer noch im Internet fällt nicht groß auf bei nicht-metaverse-Geschichten, wo man sich nicht live begegnet und ein echtes Gespräch führen will. Aber schon bei Videokonferenzen spielt das ja eine echte Rolle, wenn da zwischendurch jemand plötzlich ganz viel schneller redet, weil das irgendwie nachgeladen wird oder jemand, der so eine Sekunde zu lange schweigt und alles schon durcheinanderbringt. Also extrem hoher Anspruch, den da hier auch nochmal...
Ganz kurz zu sagen, warum das bei den bei diesen Begegnungen so wichtig ist.
Wir sind es gewohnt, er macht diesen biologischen Hinweis, das Auge reagiert mit einer Latenz von 0,00001 Millisekunden. Also unser Gehirn kriegt nicht mit, das Zeit verläuft, wir sind immer im Moment. Und er hat irgendein Gleichnis, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, irgendein Telefonat mit der Oma oder so. Und man stelle sich vor, es wäre immer eine Sekunde dazwischen. Wir kennen das aus Live-Schalten im Fernsehen. Wenn die einfach sich da nicht drüber reden und nicht genau wissen, wann hört die Antwort auf und so weiter. Und das ist hier, also schon wenn er nennt 15 Millisekunden statt 25 Millisekunden, denke ich mir, das ist ganz schön krass. Wir haben doch eigentlich damals gelernt, das Auge sieht mit 25 Bildern pro Sekunde. Und trotzdem hat es mega Sinn, so ein Smartphonebildschirm mit 100 Hertz durchlaufen zu lassen. Und so ein Fernseher vielleicht mit 144 Hertz. Auch wenn gar nicht so viele Bilder geliefert werden. Aber nur damit der Aufbau zwischen den Bildern nicht so sichtbar ist und so. Also die Erwartung des Menschen an eine Natürlichkeit sind so hoch, dass man denen technisch eigentlich kaum entsprechen kann. Diese Idee von, wir sind in einem Metaverse, also in so einer Art, wie Mark Zuckerberg sich das vorstellt, alle sitzen im Konferenztisch, sitzen aber eigentlich auf der ganzen Welt verteilt, wird wahrscheinlich nie aufgehen. Sie werden es immer merken. Es wird immer nur ein Abbild sein. Man wird immer andere Rücksicht nehmen müssen, als man das aus dem echten Gespräch in einem Raum. Also es wird auch Lernerfolge erfordern. Lernwege, Lernkurven auf Seiten der Nutzer. Man wird die technischen Ansprüche, die man da hat, nie so richtig erfüllen können. So meine Lehre daraus.
Ich denke auch, diese Unmittelbarkeit, die das Entscheidende für die direkte Begegnung ist, kann nicht hergestellt werden und wird wahrscheinlich zumindest in den nächsten Jahrzehnten nicht erreicht sein, schreibt er dann auch in den Vereinigten Staaten, beträgt die durchschnittliche Zeit für die Übermittlung von Daten von einer zur anderen Stadt und zurück 35 Millisekunden. Und das ist einfach wahnsinnig langsam, kann man sagen. Wenn man vergleicht mit der direkten Begegnung, wir stehen uns gegenüber und ich spreche dich an. Und das ist schon eine unglaublich gute Lektüre deshalb auch, weil man einfach über diese Luftschlossbauten hinausgeht und einfach mal genau erklärt bekommt, naja, die analoge Grundlage ist halt so schwierig. Also als wir diese Debatte um Hochfrequenzhandel hatten, vor über zehn Jahren, da wurde einem ja plötzlich auch dadurch erst mal so bewusst, wie sehr das Digitale ans analoge gebunden ist, dass es dann plötzlich darum ging, wie bekommen wir auf möglichst direktem Weg eine Leitung zur Börse, damit wir überhaupt Hochfrequenzhandel betreiben können. Und das ist jetzt hier bezogen auf das Metaverse auch extrem eindrücklich, wie das hier einfach an Fakten, von Fakten geschildert wird. Die Latenze ist das größte Netzwerk Hindernis auf dem Weg zum Metaverse, schreibt er dann an einer Stelle.
Ja, es gab, muss noch mal auf Schirrmacher zu sprechen kommen, weil damals so ein Gleichnis aus irgendeinem Buch zu diesem Hochfrequenzhandel, wenn man den normalen Börsenhandel mit dem Hochfrequenzhandel vergleicht, also wo es wirklich auf die drei Millisekunden ankommt, die man da Vorsprung hat, weil man daraus dann die kleine Differenz zieht. Wenn man an den normalen Börsenhandel dagegen stellt und sagt, hier haben wir eine Information, dann ist das so, als würde man in einen vor Milliarden Jahren verglühten Stern gucken. Das ist einfach nur noch ganz große, im galaktischen Maße antike Geschichte. Und wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, bei 35 Millisekunden, was ist das schon? Ein Dreißigstel von einer Sekunde. So, aber wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen, man sitzt an der Bar, redet miteinander, vertieft sich so und plötzlich dauert immer alles eine Zehntel Sekunde länger. Also man sieht den kleinen Augenaufschlag, die Wimpern, die Bewegungen und so. Einfach immer zu spät. Dann hindert das, das was man gewohnt ist. Das menschliche Gehirn arbeitet dann doch ein bisschen gehirn, aber dann doch ein bisschen schneller als. Ich finde es ja immer schon wieder erstaunlich, diese Gespräche über wie schnell hört man eigentlich Podcasts? Also wie schnell kann das menschliche Gehirn arbeiten? Und wie langsam ist die Motorik? Und ich bin ja der Meinung, ja, das menschliche Sprechen läuft sehr viel langsamer, als es das Gehirn in der Lage ist, es zu verstehen. Also man kann das künstlich beschleunigen. Wenn man es noch künstlich verlangsamt, umso dramatischer. Und hier haben wir es mit diesem Problem zu tun, dass wir es durch technische Hürden plötzlich verlangsamen. Dann kommt plötzlich hier noch eine 30. Sekunde und dann noch eine zehntel Sekunde. Und irgendwann merkt man das auch. Und dann ist sehr viel nicht mehr möglich, was vorher eben möglich war. Plus, und das ist halt hier, ist das Wahnsinn, wie eng das alles miteinander verknüpft ist. Er sagt nun, aufgrund dieser Synchronitätsprobleme und der Renderingzeit, es ist ja nicht nur Datenübertragung, sondern Bilder müssen ja auch erst mal hergestellt werden. Also gerendert und so weiter. Das kostet alles Zeit. Es ist also, Zitat, wesentlich, dass die Kreation des Metaverse ins Rechenzentrum wandert. Weg vom Endgerät. Was aber auch wieder bedeutet, dass damit noch mehr Kontrolle den Anbietern gegeben wird. Weil einfach alles nur noch auf deren Server liegt. Diese Idee von, ja ich habe das Spiel ja runtergeladen und kann es offline auf meinem Smartphone spielen und dann nämlich wo und wann ich will, ist hier völlig ausgeschlossen. Also es wird nur noch, klar online sowieso, aber es wird in allen Belangen auf der Hardware der Anbieter. Wir werden nur noch, das Display, das wir in der Hand halten, wird wirklich nur noch, oder auf den Augen haben, wird nur noch Anzeige sein, nur noch Wiedergabe. Aber alles weitere findet in der Hand des Anbieters statt.
Noch viel weiter, als es jetzt bei den Streaming-Services geht.
Genau.
Da haben wir ja auch schon, dass uns die Lieder nicht gehören bei Spotify, sondern wir haben auch nur eigentlich so eine Benutzeroberfläche. Da finden wir alles, aber da kann man nicht sagen, das ist jetzt mein Album hier, das habe ich mir gekauft oder was. Auch wenn ich es streame, dann ist es woanders. Und das wird noch viel stärker werden. Auch einfach deshalb, weil diese Rechenkapazitäten so immens sind, dass sie überhaupt nicht auf Endgeräten... Also was sollen das für Endgeräte sein? Also es müssten ja solche technische Fortschritte dann gemacht werden, dass man sagt, ja, und das passt jetzt alles auch auf das iPhone rauf. Das ist nicht möglich, um das mal mit einer Zahl deutlich zu machen. Da geht auf diesen Pixar-Film ein, Monsters University. Und da sagt er, zu Beginn meines Buches habe ich über den supercomputer geschrieben. Und er sagt jetzt bei Pixar, etwa 2000 zusammengeschaltete industriecomputer mit insgesamt 24.000 Rechenkernen hat man gebaut. Für diesen Computer, für diesen Film, um diesen Film zu rendern. Die Kosten für dieses Rechenzentrum lagen im zweistelligen Millionenbereich. Natürlich weit mehr als für eine Playstation 3, war aber auch in der Lage, viel größere, detailliertere, schönere Bilder zu erzeugen. Insgesamt benötigte jedes der 120.000 Einzelbilder des Films 30 Core-Stunden zum Rendern. In den folgenden Jahren ersetzte Pixar viele dieser Computer und Kerne durch neuere, leistungsfährige Prozessoren, die dieselben Bilder schneller rendern konnten. Wenn man das nicht gemacht hätte, dann hätte man fünf Jahre rendern müssen oder so, bis überhaupt dieser Film mal ausgespielt wäre.
19 Stunden pro Bild, einfach nur, weil die Monster so kleine Härchen haben und so. Ja, also eine unglaubliche Material-Schlacht, die da immer noch drinsteckt. Und die Ansprüche wachsen ja mit der Zeit. Das ist ja nicht so, dass man heute sagt, cool, jetzt können wir Monster AG schneller rendern. Nee, wir haben ja natürlich ganz andere Ansprüche an die Filme und Spiele. Da plötzlich fällt das Licht ganz anders und so. Und man hat viel mehr Bewegung in solchen Dingern. Da sieht man so ein bisschen, es wird nicht einfacher, auch weil die Endgeräte natürlich leichter werden müssen, wenn sie auf dem Kopf sitzen sollen. Kannst ja da ja nicht ein Mega Akku, ein Mega Prozessor, selbst wenn du ihn hast, einbauen, sondern dann willst du es ja reduzieren auf nur noch Anzeigefläche, die ein bisschen Akku mitbringt, also so leicht wie möglich. Das heißt, von dieser Entwicklung, dass wir die ganze technische Hoheit noch mehr in die Anbieter reinstecken und die noch mehr Macht darüber gewinnen, da gibt es gar keinen, also da kann man natürlich dann politisch, muss man da eingreifen, aber da wird es keine technische oder sonstige Parallelentwicklung geben. Da werden wir den ausgeliefert, was auch bedeutet, beim Thema Interoperabilität wird er ja ganz deutlich Tencent hat sich ja mal da wirklich in, ich kannte die Geschichte gar nicht, aber Tencent hat irgendwann angefangen den Leuten zu sagen, also juristisch, nachdem da Handelsplattformen verklagt wurden, wo Spiele Gegenstände, also virtuelle Güter verkauft wurden, und Tencent meinte, nee, das gehört alles uns, also diese digitalen Güter, die Assets, haben gar keinen real-weltlichen Entsprechung. Das heißt, niemand darf mit denen profitieren, also einfach Handel treiben, sondern die gehören alle uns. Und das war ein ganz großer Fehler, weil man den Leuten da gezeigt hat, ach so, ich bin euch ja ausgeliefert. Na dann hat man gleich mal ein paar Jahre Vertrauensentwicklung verspielt, dass man nämlich wirklich eigene Eigentumstitel sich erarbeiten kann durch und das ist es am Ende eben auch Arbeit. Das spielt jetzt gar nicht so eine große Rolle, immer nur so im Klein-Klein, dass man natürlich, wenn man einmal seinen Cyberpunk-Avatar geschaffen hat, den sehr gerne mitnehmen möchte in andere Welten und dann nicht wieder von vorne anfangen möchte mit der Arbeit, sondern das wollen wir eigentlich juristisch absichern.
Das wollen auch die Gamer.
Genau, das wollen vor allem die Gamer. Und da hat Tencent der ganzen Branche sozusagen einen Wärendienst erwiesen, indem sie das in Frage gestellt haben. Aber so sind die Chinesen.
Da geht ja auch das Beispiel discord ein, dass es ja Gamer gibt, die auf verschiedenen Plattformen spielen beziehungsweise mit verschiedenen Equipments oder so, und aber gerne Gamer sich austauschen würden, jenseits dieser technischen und Software-Barrieren, die es gibt. Und dann entsteht so etwas wie discord. Dort können sich wieder alle treffen, egal mit welchem Computer sie sonst ausgestattet sind, egal mit welcher Plattform. Und da können sie ein bisschen über das Spielen sprechen. Da finden sie also plötzlich einen Ort der Gemeinschaft, der was zulässt Interoperabilität natürlich. Und das ist auch ganz interessant, dass er da nochmal zeigt, was eigentlich auch das Begehren der Gamer wäre. Und dem nachzukommen, bedeutend natürlich Eigentumstitel in einer Weise zu erlauben, transformieren und zu erlauben, dass man sich fragt, ob das überhaupt in einem so vermachteten System funktionieren kann. Denn es bedeutet ja letztendlich auch, dass man Eigentumsrechte auf ewig einem geben soll. Also, wenn ich ein Buch kaufe, dann gehört mir das und dann kann ich damit machen, was ich will. Ich kann es hintragen, wohin ich will, jemanden daraus vorlesen. Das kann ich mit einem E-Book nicht, sondern das ist gebunden an das Endgerät und ich kann auch da den Zugang zu verlieren. Wenn man aber tatsächlich sagt, ich verkaufe jetzt einen Nike Sneaker digital, ist es dann wirklich möglich, dass man diesen Schuh für immer besitzt oder ergibt es doch wieder für den Konzern die Möglichkeit zu sagen, jetzt aber nicht mehr oder verlängere dein Abo, was auch immer. Und wenn die Konzerne dazu natürlich nicht bereit sind, dann kann diese Metaverse Idee nie wirklich in die Tat umgesetzt werden, beziehungsweise man kann es dann umsetzen. Aber dann ist es wirklich eine Welt, in der das Handeln so sehr beschränkt ist, dass man nicht das Metaverse als eine Alternative zur Realität ansieht.
Genau. Und neben dieser juristischen Diskussion gibt es ja auch eine soziale, nenne ich sie mal, Facebook hat diesen Facebook Login. Egal bei welchem Dienst, solange der das im Angebot hat, kann man sich mit Facebook dort authentifizieren und bringt also auch seine ganze Geschichte mit, was ja für sehr viele Unternehmen total lukrativ ist, weil die dann sehen, ah, da hat sich gerade der Wolfgang angemeldet. Den können wir jetzt mal richtig Geld aus der Tasche ziehen. Wir lernen ihn sofort kennen. Wir haben nämlich Zugriff auf sein Facebook-Profil. Und auf diese Art und Weise hat man ja sehr viel sozialen Sinn, wenn man seinen Avatar einfach mitbringt, der schon entsprechend historisch aufgeladen ist, der vielleicht sogar mit einer Kreditempfehlung und so einem scoring und so weiter alles dranhängt. Und da macht es natürlich extrem wenig Sinn, wenn jede Plattform so ihren eigenen Avatar sich da aufbauen lässt, sondern nee, eigentlich wollen die ja auch diese Interoperabilität. Die Frage ist nur, wessen Avatar? Bei Facebook und dem Login war es halt easy, weil Facebook hatte die ganze Welt schon bei sich und war da totale Monopolist. Also lag es nahe zu sagen, ja dann loggt euch mit eurem Facebookprofil hier ein, weil welches andere solltet ihr nehmen? Und dieser Kampf läuft eben gerade. Also es ist technisch und sozial so klug zu sagen, ja wir haben eben diese eine discord-instanz. Also wir kommen mit unserem discord-login dahin, damit uns die ganzen anderen Gamer schonen, achja das ist ja hierdings von discord und so. Und dieser Kampf läuft aber gerade. Und alle wollen die Pioniere sein. Jeder will hier der Vorreiter sein. Und das wird glaube ich noch ein ganz großer Kampf um diese Avatare. Wer kann hier wie? Da bräuchte man eigentlich sofort eine technische Standardisierung. Da bräuchte man eine richtig gute Politik, die das von Anfang an einfach löst, das Problem. Und sagt, Avatare sind so und so zu spezifizieren. Es darf keine plattformabhängigen Spezifitäten geben, die irgendwelche Mehrwerte schaffen oder so, sondern das ist der Avatar. Aber so eine Politik haben wir natürlich nicht.
Die haben wir nirgends. Es deutet sich ja nur ganz selten in diesem Buch mal an. Aber eigentlich könnte man dieses ganze Buch politisch lesen. Insofern, als man sagen könnte, das Metaverse ist sicherlich nicht das Paradies, was jetzt geschaffen werden muss. Aber das Metaverse wäre eigentlich auch eine Chance jetzt für das, was auf staatlicher Ebene verpasst wurde beim Web 2.0, jetzt in die Tat umzusetzen und genau solche Infrastrukturen zu schaffen und da auch eine nicht so stark ausgeprägte Kartellbildung herzustellen. Also dort etwas, beziehungsweise Kartelle zu vermeiden. Man könnte dort jetzt tatsächlich versuchen, eine öffentliche Infrastruktur aufzubauen. Denn ich würde auch tatsächlich in Zweifel ziehen, ob die Unternehmen es wirklich schaffen können. Also wenn wir jetzt doch, du hast es schon angesprochen, an diese Kämpfe zwischen Epic Games und Apple denken, an all diese Auseinandersetzung, wo es ja nur um Kleinigkeiten geht, also der Compatibilität oder auch der Honorierung. Was muss denn alles erst geregelt sein zwischen den Plattformen, damit etwas so kompatibel und interoperabel ist, wie das Metaverse sein müsste? Also er bringt ja dann auch so ein Beispiel von second Life, dass da zum Beispiel so Pferde entwickelt wurden und aber irgendwo ein Fehler gemacht wurde, dass diese Pferde nicht zum Futtertrog kamen. Und das bedeutete dann auch in der digitalen Welt, dass die Pferde alle gestorben sind, weil sie halt nichts zu fressen bekommen haben. Und an so einem Beispiel sieht man natürlich schon, was bedeutet das dann, wenn noch irgendeine rechtliche Frage und auch eine technische Gleichmachung zwischen den Konzernen nicht stattgefunden hat, dann bedeutet das plötzlich, man geht mit den Neigschuhen irgendwo rein und kommt am Ende ohne Beine wo raus, weil irgendein System das nicht erkannt hat. Das scheint mir dann doch auch noch sehr, sehr laut klingende Zukunftsmusik zu sein. Und dann müssen wir das auch noch mal rückspiegeln auf unseren letzten Neuen Zwanziger Podcast. Wie ist es denn eigentlich, wenn Zuckerberg da jetzt 10 Milliarden jährlich investiert? Ja, wir haben jetzt schon gesagt, eben geht es jetzt nicht um kurzfristige Gewinne, offensichtlich. Aber was soll das für ein langes Projekt werden? Also das muss ja dann wirklich so China-Dimensionen annehmen, wie in 25 Jahren werden wir ein kleines bisschen Wohlstand für alle haben und dann 25, 50 Jahre später wird es so und so sein. Aber das Zuckerberg-Geld auch nicht ausreichen.
Ja, ich habe ja im Podcast oder im Salon, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, diese kurze Kulturgeschichte der analogen und digitalen Identität, wie man sich so langsam und die Person und ihre Papiere, dann wurden sie so Passagiere, man hat seine Adresse irgendwann gehabt, dann hat man sie so mitgenommen mit dem Smartphone und plötzlich war man immer so doppelt unterwegs. Und das ist natürlich genau der Weg, den jetzt alle gehen und weshalb es sich auch mega lohnt, jetzt einfach neun Milliarden im Jahr daraus zu hauen. Mark Zuckerberg hat sich selber breiterklärt mit Marques Brownlee, zum Beispiel diesem einen YouTuber, der so ganz viel Technik vorstellt und auch so Technikfragen klärt, Right to Repair und alles solche Sachen mit großem Millionenpublikum. Und er hat jetzt so ein Video die Woche gemacht, wo er auch die neue Facebook-Brille aufhat. Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht zu sehen, denn das Ausmaß kannte ich auch nicht, wie sehr die Brille zurück schaut ins Gesicht, um jede Mimik aufzugreifen und dann im Avatar auch darzustellen. Also jemand, der zwingt, die Augenbrauen hochzieht und so weiter, lächelt, das wird dann im Avatar direkt wiedergegeben. Und da läuft ja dieser Wettlauf. Wer schafft es am nähesten ran an die Person technisch, um dann zu behaupten, also die Repräsentation des Avatars, das ist unsere Aufgabe. So wir haben Face ID im iPhone, also das Gesicht wird mit 30.000 Punkten gescannt, ob es wirklich diese 3D Form hat, die das Telefon kennt, um dann zu authentifizieren, ja du bist es. Und daran angeknüpft alle möglichen, und es sind ja dann schon solche Avatar Sachen, ich gehe einkaufen, authentifiziere den Zugriff auf meinem Konto über mein Gesicht. Oder, und das fand ich dann überraschend zu lesen, das wusste ich auch nicht, dass einzelne Bundesstaaten in Amerika schon Apple erlauben, den Führerschein digital abzubilden. Über die Authentifizierung des Gesichtes. So wie wir sehen, dass auch Facebook das Gesicht schon komplett abscannt, um zu sagen, wir haben die Hoheit über die Person. Wir digitalisieren die Person in die neuen Papiere, die digitalen Papiere, das Ausweisdokument. Und da lohnt sich gerade, glaube ich, jeder Dollar zu investieren. Dieses Ganze, und das ist wirklich erstaunlich, es gibt von Google, wo man sich so gegenüber sitzt, man schaut auf eine Glasplatte, aber auf ein Hologramm eines Gesprächspartners. Und Google hat ganz aufwendig das Problem gelöst, dass man nicht vorbei in eine Kamera schaut, sondern sich wirklich in die Augen. Das heißt, die Kamera weiß also, wo die Augen des Avatars, des jeweils anderen sind, und positioniert sich genau dahinter, so dass sich beide gegenseitig komplett in die Augen schauen. Google Glass, schon vor zehn Jahren damals, wo auch dieses Gesicht so richtig in Angriff genommen wurde. Und dann sagt er ja hier, die Plan auch groß ist für 2024. Das ist natürlich so ein, wer weiß, ob er da irgendwie was weiß, was er noch nicht sagen durfte und so. Microsoft, die Hololens und den ganzen Kram. Also alle versuchen, so ganz nah an die Person ranzurücken. Touch ID, Face ID, der ganze Kram, den Oculus da macht und so. In der Hinsicht, da der Wettlauf eben noch läuft und Elon Musk dann sogar noch mit Neuralink direkt unter in die Person reinkriechen will, ist das, glaube ich, ein Wettlauf, wo sich alle gerade nicht auch nur ein Dollar weniger zugestehen und dieses Research and Development da auf die Spitze getrieben wird.
Und das ist sicherlich eine ganz wichtige Erkenntnis aus diesem Buch. Es ist nicht Zuckerbergs Idee vom Metaverse, sondern alle großen Tech-Konzerne glauben in gewisser Weise schon an das Metaverse. Er bringt das Beispiel Apple und schreibt, Apple hat sich wie üblich bedeckt gehalten, was seine Pläne für Augmented Reality und Virtual Reality angeht oder ob es überhaupt daran glaubt. Dennoch sind seine Übernahmen und Patentanmeldungen aufschlussreich. In den letzten drei Jahren hat Apple Startups wie Frana, das ein AR-Headset namens Totem herstellte, aconia, das Linsen für AR-Produkte produzierte, Emotions, dessen Software für maschinelles Lernen, Gesichtsausdrücke verfolgt und Emotionen erkennt, Realface, ein Unternehmen für Gesichtserkennung und FaceShift, das die Gesichtsbewegung eines Nutzers einem 3D-Avatar zuordnete, gekauft. Apple kaufte auch noch NextVR, ein Hersteller von VR-Inhalten sowie Spaces, das ortsbezogene VR-Unterhaltung und VR-basierte Erfahrungen für Videokonferenzsoftware entwickelt. Im Durchschnitt werden Apple über 2000 Patente pro Jahr erteilt. Hunderte davon beziehen sich auf VR, AR oder Körperverfolgung.
Ja, und Facebook macht Elektromyografie. Also, Sie haben ein Unternehmen gekauft, das elektrische Aktivitäten der Skelettmuskulatur aufzeichnet. Also, umso näher, umso mehr man behaupten kann, man verstünde die Person und könnte sie verstehen, abbilden, repräsentieren, wie auch immer. Umso näher dran ist man an diesem Zukunftsmarkt, die zentrale Avatar-Instanz zu sein.
Das ist jetzt der Raum, das ist jetzt der Körper. Aber wenn wir mal zum Raum springen, er bringt ja auch Amazon mit diesen eigenen Amazon-Shops. Da hat man sich ja immer gefragt, was will denn jetzt Amazon wollen, die wirklich den Supermarkt erobern? Ist das so interessant für Amazon, wenn man Online-Helden ist? Na ja, vielleicht kann man es eher als ein Versuchslabor dafür sehen, wie man so ein Metaverse tatsächlich gestalten kann. Er geht da ein auf die Kameras, die dort in einer Vielzahl natürlich zu finden sind in diesen Shops. Und dass man eigentlich dort so etwas vorfindet, wie eine Echtzeitverfolgung des Kunden, was schon so einen Schritt zum Metaverse führt. Und er glaubt, dass auch diese hyperdetaillierten Projektionskameras, die da eingesetzt werden, mit denen man die einzelnen Objekte erkennt, mit denen gescannt werden kann, sodass der Kunde gar kein Geld mehr bezahlen muss an der Kasse, sondern dass es einfach so automatisiert abgezogen werden kann, dass das eigentlich der Schlüssel ist zum Metaverse, dass man also hier mit Sensoren, Projektionen, Kameras schon arbeitet und man da eigentlich so ein kleines Versuchslabor schon vorfindet. Also so ein Metaverse, wie es dann sehr eng auch geknüpft ist, an den noch physischen Raum.
Genau, geh in einen Supermarkt, nimm dir was du willst und geh einfach wieder raus, weil alle Kameras gesehen haben, was du dir genommen hast, dann kriegst du eine Rechnung. Also du wirst gar nicht mehr weiter belästigt und im Grunde wirst du als Person schon zum Avatar da drin. Ohne, dass du es merkst. Er hat ja ein sehr großes Kapitel zum Thema Geld. Das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, wie sich da alle gegenseitig auf den Füßen stehen. Er nennt es ja im Grunde Zahlungsmaschinen, die da hergestellt werden. Finde ich einen sehr guten Begriff, eine sehr gute Problematisierung auf diesen Begriff. Und heute macht Bargeld noch 20 Prozent des amerikanischen Zahlungsverkehrs aus. Das heißt, da ist schon sehr viel digitalisiert. Kreditkarte Erfindung 1950 mit sehr hohen Gebühren. Und das mit diesen sehr hohen Gebühren ist ja wirklich, das ist so, da wird es ja auch zum Kindergarten, wenn man sich dann anschaut, wie Epic als Hersteller von GTA und Fortnite und so weiter da reingeht und sagt, wir wollen erst mal, wie man das so kennt, Märkte erobern. Uns ist erst mal nur Umsatz wichtig oder eben, dass die Leute viel mit uns spielen. Also verschenkt Epic im Ausmaß, im Rahmen von 18 Milliarden Dollar Spiele, 89 verschiedene Titel, um die Leute auf der Plattform zu halten und damit nicht alles nur für Fortnite drauf geht. Um da einfach so zu sagen, wir müssen uns mal diversifizieren. Wir stellen jetzt ganz viele Spiele her und dann verschenken wir die einfach, auch wenn der Ladenpreis so und so ist, dass es rechnerisch dann 18 Milliarden Dollar Geschenke sind. Aber allein 2021 haben sie in diesem Rahmen einfach Spiele verschenkt, nur um die Leute bei der Stange zu halten und von ihrem eigenen Monopol Fortnite, weil sie genau wissen, sobald das nächste Spiel kommt, sind die alle weg und so. Da haben wir als Plattform gar nichts davon. Und Steam und so macht ja auch andere Angebote. Das ist crazy. Und wenn man dann sieht, wie Epic da strampelt, obwohl sie solche weltweiten Erfolgsdinger hingelegt haben, und dann trotzdem nicht vorwärts kommen, beispielsweise weil einfach Apple sagt, die Leute spielen bei uns auf dem Bildschirm, koste dich 30 Prozent. Und Ball hier nur fragt, wer muss bitte 30 Prozent seines Unternehmerumsatzes für Miete bezahlen in der realen Welt? Niemand. Aber Apple hält einfach die Hände auf und sagt, ja, hier 30 Prozent, weil die Leute für ein paar Minuten oder Stunden am Tag unser Gerät nutzen. Also unser Gerät im Sinne von, es ist ja unser Gerät. Es ist nicht das Gerät des Nutzers, es ist unser Gerät.
Oder wer würde noch mit Kreditkarte zahlen, wenn man plötzlich 30 Prozent Gebühr zu tragen hätte?
Ja, genau.
Auch das ist ja nicht. Also er schreibt ja schon, es gibt da hohe Gebühren und das kann auch schnell in die Höhe schießen, wenn Zinsen anfallen. Aber in der Regel ist es natürlich sehr viel günstiger. Aber die haben es tatsächlich durch diese proprietäre Marktstruktur geschafft, das so zu etablieren, dass wir das als gegeben hinnehmen, dass diese 30 Prozent gezahlt werden müssen. Einfach nur dafür, dass das zur Verfügung gestellt wird oder dass eine Zahlung ermöglicht wird. Und diese Zahlungsdienstleistungen, die sind auf der einen Seite ganz günstig. Also wir haben auch so was wie PayPal, was sehr günstig ist. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir diese proprietären Märkte. Und die Frage ist jetzt, was sich durchsetzen wird im Metaverse. Er ist ja interessanterweise skeptisch, was so diese ganzen Kryptowährungen und all das anbelangt. Also er sieht da schon mitunter Potenzial. Aber es ist jetzt niemand, der sagt, und bald werden wir das alles mit Ether oder bitcoin bezahlen. Und dann ist da alles gelöst. Denn da sagt er auch ganz klar, das ist auch teuer. Das kostet Zeit und Energie und ist auch nicht besonders transparent. Und wollen wir eigentlich diese Form des Vertrauens da durch die Community. Er sagt, es war doch nie das Problem, dass man eigentlich ein schlechtes Gefühl hatte, wenn man Geld auf der Bank liegen hatte. Oh, wird die Bank das am Ende ausgeben? Und ich kriege das am Morgen nicht mehr wieder. Das war ja nie die Frage. Insofern sieht er das eher skeptisch. Bei der Blockchain ist das wieder was anderes. Aber die sieht er viel holistischer als jetzt nur über das Bezahlen. Aber diese Frage, wie bezahlt man vor allem diese ganzen Mikrotransaktionen? Das wird ja doch wichtig. Und dann nimmt er ja auch als positives Beispiel dann WeChat. Die haben ja dann gezeigt, dass es sehr viel günstiger geht. Er hat da auch die Zahlen sich angesehen. Und das finde ich schon erstaunlich, dass man da bei WeChat diesen anderen Weg gegangen ist. WeChat ermöglichte es den Nutzern beispielsweise, sich direkt mit ihrem Bankkonto zu verbinden, anstatt eine Kreditkarte oder ein digitales Zahlungsnetzwerk zwischenzuschalten, was bei den großen Spielkonsolen und Smartphone-Appstores verboten ist. Ohne Zwischenhändler und weil Tencent sein soziales Messaging-Netzwerk ausbauen wollte, bot WeChat winzige Transaktionsgebühren an, 0% bis 0,1% für Peer-to-Peer-Überweisungen und weniger als 1% für Zahlungen von Händlern ohne Gebühren für die Lieferungen, Echtzeit- und Zahlungsbestätigung. Und da diese Zahlungsmöglichkeiten auf gemeinsamen Standards, QR-Codes beruhte und in eine Messaging-App integriert war, konnte sie von jedem, der ein Smartphone besaß, leicht angenommen und genutzt werden. Der Erfolg von WeChat half ten sind auch beim Aufbau der heimischen Videospielindustrie und ansonsten durch das Fehlen von Kreditkarten im ganzen Land eingeschränkt worden wäre. Also da hat man natürlich auch dann genutzt, dass das noch nicht in dieser Weise beherrscht war. Im Jahr 2021 entwickelte WeChat schätzungsweise 500 Milliarden Dollar an Zahlungen ab, deren durchschnittlicher Wert bei nur wenigen Dollar pro Transaktion lag.
Und damit, weil sie eben so eine All-in-App sind, sind sie auch eine der wenigen, ich glaube, er hat geschrieben, die einzigen, die bei Apple um die 30 Prozent mal drum rum kamen. Ja, weil Apple dann auch gesehen hat, das kriegen wir jetzt nicht gerechtfertigt, wenn wir hier sagen, dann geht immer noch 30 Prozent an uns, während jeder andere In-App kauft und so weiter da abgerechnet wird. Was ja auch bedeutet, man kann ja bis heute bei Amazon in der App auf dem iPhone keine Kindlebücher kaufen, weil Amazon diese 30 Prozent nicht abdrücken will. Also kann man das nur mit dem Browser machen, wo es wiederum geht. Er beschreibt ja noch mal diese kurze Geschichte wie Netflix auch mal sagte, ihr könnt euch auf dem iPhone einloggen, aber nicht hier registrieren, denn das müsst ihr dann irgendwo auf dem Browser machen. Wir wollen die 30 Prozent nicht an Apple abgeben. Und so wie Apple da den Daumen immer noch drauf hat, gilt das eben auch für die NFC-Chips, die sie eingebaut haben. Also auch das Bezahlen in der Welt ist noch nicht, sind alles diese Amy-Klobuchar-Themen, Top 1 bis 5, wo sie an sich arbeitet. Genau das bei Apple aufzubrechen, aber bislang hält da Apple einfach den Daumen drauf. Ja, dieses Blockchain-Kapitel, also ein richtiger Ausweg, Ausweg steckt da nicht drin, sagt er auch. Interessanterweise, oder sagen wir mal so, die Diskussion, die immer wieder nahe lag, lag auch hier wieder nahe, aber er wird auch wieder nicht geführt, dass wir ja die Blockchain-Diskussion immer nicht nur wegen Geld haben, dass man damit Zahlung machen kann, sondern auch wegen Rechtssicherheit. Wenn man sein Avatar in der Blockchain authentifiziert, hat man ihn. Und dann kann auch keine Organisation dagegen was haben, weil es ist ja technisch abgesichert. Und während wir jetzt diese Metaverse-Diskussionen so diskutieren, dass wir sagen, ja, die Politik kommt da irgendwie nicht so richtig hinterher, also wird das erst mal sehr viel über AGBs gelöst. Wir wechseln also die Referenz-Ebene von Gesellschaftsrecht, allgemeines Recht für alle, auf einzelne Unternehmensgeschäftsbedingungen sozusagen. Dass auch da eigentlich Blockchain das wieder revidiert, also von der organisationalen Ebene wieder zurück in die Gesellschaft holt, wenn auch nicht in die juristisch institutionelle, aber so doch zumindest in die mathematisch technische irgendwie. Da fand ich, jetzt war das mal so ein Buch, wo man noch mal so einen Einflug schneise für diesen. Ja, da macht eigentlich Blockchain noch mal so ein bisschen Sinn, noch mal ein bisschen mehr Sinn als jetzt so bei anderen Themen irgendwie, wo man einfach nur versucht, ja, habt doch einen Zahlungsverkehr. Warum muss der jetzt in Blockchain sein? Ja, wissen wir auch nicht, weil es halt cooler ist oder so. Sondern hier wäre noch mal ein echtes Problem, dass man lösen kann, also gar nicht so sehr die Geldfrage, sondern diese rechte Frage, dass man einzelnen Organisationen die Rechtstitel entzieht über Assets, die die Nutzer haben, Avatare oder digitale Gegenstände, aber gleichzeitig noch nicht ein fertig ausgetüfteltes Rechtssystem haben muss, sondern man hat halt einfach ein technisches Angebot, mit dem man das dann lösen kann. Aber gut.
Lass mich gerade mal noch einen Punkt bringen, den ich für ganz existenziell wichtig halte, denn wir haben ja oft diese Erzählung vom genialen Unternehmer. Und die wird hier auch ein bisschen zumindest in Frage gestellt. Matthew Ball sagt Steve Jobs, ja, der war schon genial, aber jetzt haben wir dieses iPhone 12 als erstes Smartphone, das von Apple herausgegeben wurde, dass ein 5G-Gerät war. Konnte denn, fragte er sich, wenn Steve Jobs genügend Geld ausgegeben hätte, hätte man auch dieses iPhone 12 schon 2008 haben können? Das ist ja eigentlich eine interessante Frage. Woran lag es, dass es dann doch noch zwölf Jahre gedauert hat? Hätte es auch zwölf Jahre früher funktioniert? Und dann sagte er ganz klar, die Entwicklung des iPhone 12 erforderte Innovationen und Investitionen in das gesamte Ökosystem, die größtenteils außerhalb des Zuständigkeitsbereichs von Apple lagen, auch wenn die lukrative iOS-Plattform der Hauptantrieb für diese Fortschritte war. Die Geschäfte mit 4G-Netzen von Verizon und dem Ausbau der Funktürme der American Tower Corporation hingen von der Nachfrage von Verbrauchern und Unternehmen nach schnellerem und besserem Mobilfunk für Apps wie Spotify, Netflix und Snapchat ab. Ohne sie wäre die Killer-Applikation von 4G eine etwas schnellere E-Mail gewesen. Bessere Grafikprozessoren wurden in der Zwischenzeit von besseren Spielen genutzt und bessere Kameras wurden durch Fotosharing-Dienste wie Instagram relevant. Leistungsfähige Hardware ermöglichte ein größeres Engagement, was zu mehr Wachstum und Gewinn für diese Unternehmen führte, was wiederum bessere Produkte, Apps und Services zur Folge hatte. Das heißt, die gesamtgesellschaftliche technische Entwicklung und auch die Nachfragen bei den Konsumenten sorgen dafür, dass am Ende so etwas wie das iPhone 12 überhaupt entstehen kann. Es ist keineswegs der genialische Einfall eines Einzelnen oder eines Teams, dass das iPhone 12 entstehen lässt. Sondern es braucht ganz viele zusammenhängende, aber dann doch nicht so ganz fest verbundene Konstellationen, die so etwas wie das iPhone 12 auf den Weg bringen. Das bedeutet dann Übertragen auf das Metaverse. Das kann jetzt einer noch so sehr wollen und geniale Erfindungen machen, die das Metaverse vorantreiben. Am Ende muss es darum gehen, also muss es auch in dem Mark Zuckerberg darum gehen, dass alle in irgendeiner Weise ein Interesse an diesem Metaverse haben und sich dann entsprechende Spiele dahin entwickeln, Zahlungsdienste dorthin entwickeln, Hardware sich da und dorthin entwickelt, dass Investitionen stattfinden, auf die Mark Zuckerberg überhaupt keinen Zugriff hat, von denen er dann aber schlussendlich profitieren kann. Das ist, glaube ich, auch noch mal sehr wichtig zu sehen, dass das Metaverse nicht die Frage ist von drei, vier tollen Milliardären, die sich irgendwas einfallen lassen und wenn die nicht wollen, gibt es das auch nicht.
Genau, es ist eine kritische Masse miteinander verbundener Innovationen, wie er schreibt, plus Nutzer und deren Aktivitäten. Und er macht ja dieses schöne generationale Argument, also die Leute, die das Metaverse zum Erfolg machen, müssen mit dem Internet aufgewachsen sein. Die Rentner, die wir jetzt haben oder die die nächsten zehn Jahre noch in Rente gehen, die werden weiterhin 7,5 Stunden am Tag Fernsehen schauen.
Das habe ich auch zweimal lesen müssen, dass es wirklich 7,5 Stunden Fernsehen sind, die Rentner in den USA vor den Fernsehgeräten sitzen.
Also deren Sicht allein die Basistechnologien, Rechenpower, Standardisierung, Interoperabilität wird nicht reichen. Es ist ein kollektiver Mindset erforderlich.
Nun frage ich mich jetzt gerade, wenn wir von diesen 7,5 Stunden sprechen und wir wissen, die Smartphone-Nutzung liegt bei knapp fünf Stunden beim durchschnittlichen Smartphone-User. Inwieweit stimmt denn das, was wir bislang auch so im Podcast gesagt haben, wenn wir über das Metaverse gesprochen haben? Wir waren ja doch sehr skeptisch. Du sagst dann Oxytocin. Ich sage direkte Begegnung, Oper in Präsenz erfahren. Inwieweit stimmt denn das überhaupt? Also das ist wirklich die Frage, die mich auch die 300 Seiten umgetrieben hat. Was ist denn wirklich das, was die Menschen wollen? Wenn sie 7,5 Stunden vor dem Fernseh sitzen, dann sagen wir ja, die lassen sich betäuben. Die sind passiv. Mein Gott, was ein trauriges Dasein. Wird das von denen auch so empfunden? Und die Alternative der Gesellschaft, des geselligen Lebens, wie du es beschreiben würdest, ist nicht gegeben. Und was bedeutet das denn eigentlich, wenn es tatsächlich gesellschaftlich eine solch große Sehnsucht gibt nach Metaverse-Welten? Denn sonst würde ja Roblox nicht so arg frequentiert werden.
Das ist natürlich eine Frage, die genauso kompliziert ist, wie alle Fragen zum Metaverse selbst. Denn die Armutsdefinition, die für uns entscheidend sind, heißt ja nicht, man hat wenig, sondern man hat weniger, als man sich wünscht. Und dann ist die Frage, von was eigentlich ganz einfach zu beantworten ist, Geld. Wir wünschen uns alle mehr Geld, als wir haben, weil wir dann wissen, welche Gelegenheiten wir wahrnehmen oder welche Augenblicke wir uns erschaffen können, einfach durch Geldzahlung. Beim Thema Geselligkeit ist das ein bisschen anders gelagert, denn wir kennen alle die Jugendlichen, vor allem männlichen Jugendlichen, die im Rahmen ihrer Familie am Abendessen Tisch sitzen und sich nichts sehnlicher wünschen, als zu ihren Freunden ins Metaverse zu gehen, ins GTA-Spiel, zu Fortnite oder wie auch immer. Also die sehr viel mehr sozialen Sinn daraus schöpfen, physisch alleine, aber in Gemeinschaft mit ihren Avatar-Kumpeln in so einer virtuellen Welt zu sein. Dann gehen aber 50 Jahre ins Land. Und dann macht man den gleichen Menschen wieder das Angebot. Willst du jetzt am Abendessen-Tisch sitzen oder zurück zu deinem Bildschirm? Für was die sich dann entscheiden, das können wir noch gar nicht sagen. Wir kennen die romantische Antwort von heute. Diese Menschen, die siebeneinhalb Stunden am Tag Fernsehen schauen, hätten lieber was Soziales zu tun. Umso näher man seinem eigenen Lebensalter oder Lebensende rückt, umso mehr ist das so.
Und gleichzeitig ist das wirklich so. Also ich wünschte, es wäre so. Das kann ich hier unterstreichen. Mir erzählte ein Bekannter von seinen schon sehr alten Eltern, dass sie dann auf einer Familienfeier waren und um 16 Uhr plötzlich in Panik ausbrachen. Wir müssen jetzt dringend nach Hause, weil sie immer im dritten Programm so eine Sendung gucken, sowas wie Kunst und Krempel. Und sie brechen von der Familienfeier auf, begeben sich zurück in die Einsamkeit, also die Lebenssitz, zurückgezogen, um dann diese Fernsehsendung zu gucken.
Ja, da kann man nur, wie Katharina Saalfrank immer als Erstes sagte, hier hat sich ein Muster entwickelt. Sobald man das mit den Leuten reflektiert oder ihnen auch die technischen Möglichkeiten nennt, du kannst es aufnehmen und später schauen. Es geht nichts verloren, du verpasst nichts. Das ist ja die Botschaft.
Gut, das kann man im Fernsehen. Das ist natürlich jetzt zum Beispiel beim Sporterleben schon schwieriger. Es gibt ja Leute, die sich Fußballspiele aufnehmen, aber da gibt es ja schon diese Live-Nes. Aber was ich nochmal deutlich herausstellen will, wir haben den Eindruck, dass es eine große Sehnsucht eigentlich nach diesen zwischenmenschlichen Begegnungen gibt. Und ich glaube auch, dass das eigentlich zur Bedingung des Menschseins gehört. Aber ich habe tatsächlich den Eindruck, dass sich dies, was eigentlich wichtig wäre, immer mehr zurückentwickelt. Das mag jetzt ein bisschen kulturpessimistisch klingen, aber ich glaube, dass man es auch ganz deutlich so sagen kann, dass tatsächlich diese andere Welt nicht mehr erlebt wird oder die Gegenwelt, also die nicht digitale Welt nicht mehr erlebt wird oder auch da es nicht besonders schön zugeht und dass es ganz logisch ist, dass man dann dorthin geht, wo es vielleicht angenehmer ist. Oder muss man es ganz runterbrechen, wie das jetzt vielleicht ein Medienwissenschaftler tun würde, der sehr relativistisch argumentieren würde und sagt, nun Herr Schmitt, sie lesen ja gerne acht Stunden am Tag einen Roman. Warum soll nicht jemand acht Stunden am Tag in einer Spielewelt sein?
Ja, also umso weiter man es runterbricht, umso besser, umso pragmatischer. Ich würde auch sagen, dieser ganze Kulturpessimismus im Sinne von, oh krass, siebeneinhalb Stunden, das ist ja, das Fernsehen ist ja nicht das Problem, sondern dass sie da so abgeschottet sind. Und ich glaube, es liegt schon ein großer Gewinn da drin, dass sich Jugendliche, also dass sie heute die Möglichkeit haben, in ihrer Komfortzone zu bleiben und trotzdem unter Menschen zu sein. Zwar nicht physisch unberührbar, aber zumindest im Gespräch. Da kommt schon ganz viel sozialer Sinn mit, der einen auch herausfordert, der das Gehirn eben anders beschäftigt, als würde man jetzt einfach nur so ein vorgefertigtes Produkt, das im Ablaufplan einer Programmierung im Fernsehen hingelegt wird. In der Ansicht, aber es sind die großen Fragen.
Ich will das noch zuspitzen. Ich will dich jetzt ein bisschen herausfordern. Pass auf Thema Dating. Ja, in den letzten Jahren haben Dating Anwendungen neue Funktionen für zusammen passende Paare hinzugefügt, zum Beispiel Gelegenheitsspiele und Quizze, Sprachnotizen und die Möglichkeit, Ihre Lieblings-Playliste auf Spotify und Apple Music zu teilen. In Zukunft werden Dating-Anwendungen Paaren wahrscheinlich eine Vielzahl von virtuellen Welten bieten, die ihnen helfen, sich gegenseitig kennenzulernen. Diese könnten die simulierte Realität, Abendessen in Paris oder das fantastische Abendessen in Paris auf dem Mond umfassen. Viele Live-Auftritte von bewegungserfassten Avantaren beinhalten. Stellen sie sich die Mariachis oder einen digitalen Zwilling des Londoner Royal Ballet vor, aber von Atlanta aus und möglicherweise zu einer Neuerfindung klassischer Spielshow-Formate wie The Dating Game. Es ist auch wahrscheinlich, dass diese Apps in virtuelle Welten von Drittanbietern integriert werden können, so dass beispielsweise ein zusammengeführtes Paar einfach in ein virtuelles Peloton oder Headspace einsteigen kann. Ich halte das für hochproblematisch, aber auch zugleich für absoluten Nonsens. Also will man also ist ja vielleicht doch ich gehe immer zu sehr von mir aus, aber ist man auf einer Dating Plattform, um im Digitalen zu verweilen miteinander, ist nicht der eigentliche Sinn und Zweck einer Dating Plattform, wieder reale Begegnungen zu haben, gerne erotische dann. Ist das nicht das eigentliche? Aber klar, es gibt natürlich dieses Phänomen, ist ja auch schon 100 Artikel beschrieben wurde, von Leuten, die bei Dating Plattformen nur schätten wollen. Und zwar am liebsten fünf Jahre lang und immer dann die passende Ausrede finden, warum doch nächste Woche das leider nicht klappt mit dem Restaurantbesuch, aber lass uns ruhig noch weiterschreiben.
Genau. Also aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich dir sagen, Dating Plattformen und so weiter sind für mich zum Beispiel nur dafür da, um Menschen kennenzulernen, denen man ansonsten nicht so einfach über den Weg läuft. Und das Ziel ist, Menschen zu treffen, mit denen man wirklich gerne seine Zeit verbringt. Analog. Egal in welchem Rahmen. Aber dieser Moment, wo man dann auch in seinem Freundeskreis so Bescheid sagt und sagt, ja, ich habe viel über die und jene Person gesprochen, war dann doch nicht so. Dieses war dann doch nicht so oder krass, voll überraschend jetzt hat sich doch als so und so herausgestellt. Diese kleine Zäsur in jemanden kennenlernen und dann überrascht sein, weil man doch super Spaß hatte oder eben nicht. Der ist überhaupt nur durch eine echte Begegnung zu ermitteln. Niemand sagt, oh, wir haben so krass gechattet, aber dann beim Telefonieren hat es plötzlich gefunkt oder, nee, dann war ich aber echt mega gelangweilt. Sondern selbst dieses Telefonat wäre dann nur auch wieder so der letzte Weg der Rampe bis zur Begegnung. Erst dann stellt sich wirklich heraus, ist es jetzt eine Person, mit der man gerne seine Zeit verbringt? Ja oder nein. Deswegen finde ich, dieses Dating ist…
Stimmt dir absolut zu.
Ja, also dieses Dating ist…
Und führt uns das nicht auch noch mal zu so einem Kernproblem mit dem Metaverse. Dating ist sicherlich eine Extremsituation, aber bedeutet das nicht auch generell ist es die unmittelbare Begegnung, dann wenn wir jetzt von unserer direkten Lebenswelt, nicht von unserem Medienkonsum ausgehen. Also wir wollen nicht den Tagesschaussprecher im Wohnzimmer stehen haben. Es reicht uns, wenn wir ihn da sehen und wenn wir da in ein vertrautes Gesicht gehen.
Genau, das meine ich nämlich. Es gibt sehr viele Bereiche, wo es auf diesen Moment der echten Begegnung und dann zu prüfen trifft, dass jetzt die Erwartungen oder werden sogar übertroffen, wo das gar keine Rolle spielt. Will ich Sport machen? Nee, da gehe ich einfach hin. Da sind Leute, die machen auch Sport. Die muss ich nicht so im Sinne von, oh krass, ich wünsche mir noch eine Minute länger mit dir hier irgendwie und so. Darauf kommst du ja gar nicht an. Das ist genau das gleiche im Bildungsbereich oder auch beim ganzen Gaming. Man spielt halt so mit Leuten, klar, cool, wenn so Debattis sind und so, weil man dann auch ein paar Gesprächsthemen hat und so eine Wellenlänge findet, wie auch immer.
Da überraschst du mich jetzt beim Bildungsbereich. Also wir haben jetzt eben noch mal gerantet gegen Kita-Schließungen und Schulschließungen. Das wird ja noch mal ein Thema wahrscheinlich werden, wenn die nächste Studie raus ist. Hier gibt es ja schon diese Vision, dass er sagt, man kann, es wäre doch toll. Also der sagt schon, es gibt immer Präsenzunterricht. Also er sagt nicht, das muss alles abgeschafft werden, immerhin. Aber er fängt auch dann mit solchen Überlegungen an, wie ja und man kann sich doch einfach mal vorstellen, wie dann so ein Klassenraum im Metaverse aussehen könnte, wenn beispielsweise dann eine Jane Goodall dort auch tatsächlich als Hologramm erscheint und noch mal erzählt, wie ist das eigentlich mit den Schimpansen entscheidend ist, sagt er, dass dieser virtuelle Unterricht durch einen engagierten, realen Lehrer ergänzt werden kann. Stellen Sie sich vor, dass die echte Jane Goodall in einer virtuellen Umgebung reproduziert wird und die Schüler durch den GOMS-Team Nationalpark in Tansania führt, wobei der Lehrer, den die Schüler zu Hause haben, hinzukommt und die Erfahrung noch persönlicher gestaltet. Ich muss einfach sagen, ja, das ist so wie diese ganzen interaktiven Museen, wo ich immer denke, am besten wäre doch gewesen, man hätte einfach mal ein Ölgemälde an die Wand gehangen und den Kindern das erklärt.
Also Bildungsbereich, es ist ja nicht immer nur die frühkindliche Heransozialisierung, wo es wirklich all in Präsenz sein muss. Es gibt ja auch Erwachsenenbildung, Weiterbildung, wo es super synergetische Effekte gibt, wenn man dann sagt, ne, das kannst du nach Feierabend zu Hause machen, es ist keine Reise erforderlich und so weiter, sondern einfach, man sitzt eh schon auf dem Sofa und dann kann man die Stunde auch noch mit Inhalten verbringen, statt jetzt nur noch Konsum von Unterhaltung und sowas.
Nur brauche ich dafür das Metaverse. Also das ist ja so, dass wir uns die ganze Zeit bilden über YouTube. Also wir haben sicherlich unglaublich viele Vorlesungen, uns schon angehört, auch in Fachbereichen, die wir sonst nie hineingekommen wären an der Universität.
Also ich will es, genau, lass uns nicht zu lang drüber reden, ich spitze es jetzt richtig zu. Okay, Dating finde ich da so interessant, weil bei dem ganzen anderen Kram auch die Frage, was ist das Metaverse? Ja, es ist so mehr oder weniger irgendwas mit Bildschirm und Internet und so weiter, das mal ganz schwammig jetzt formuliert. Beim Thema Dating geht es ja darum, will ich mit jemanden für so einen kurzen Moment Zeit verbringen, nur weil es diese Person ist. Ich brauche darum kein Gaming, ich brauche kein persönliches, ich will mich da noch zertifizieren Ziel in Sachen Bildung oder ich verbinde in dem Moment kein sportliches Ziel damit, sondern wo es nur darum geht, mit dieser Person möchte ich jetzt Zeit verbringen. Auch weil die aus allen anderen Zusammenhängen, die auch wieder ganz viel mit Metaverse zu tun haben können, nämlich Sport, Bildung, was auch immer, Geschichten mitbringt, die ich in dem Moment gerne hören möchte, aber eben nur, weil es von dieser Person erzählt wird. Da, finde ich, wird das Metaverse immer scheitern. Und Menschen, die glauben, oh nee, jetzt habe ich aber auch da eine tolle Metaverse-Erfahrung gemacht, ich habe wirklich ganz tolle Zeit. Und ansonsten, wir haben gar nichts davon genutzt, wir haben alle Wände schwarz gelassen und so, wir haben uns nicht an irgendeine Küste oder wie auch immer, wir haben uns nicht voneinander ablenken lassen. Das, glaube ich, wird es so nicht geben. In vielen anderen Bereichen, wo Sozialität eine Rolle spielt, hat es aber so ergänzendes Potenzial. Oder vielleicht auch so mal tragendes. Ich glaube nicht, dass man sein Lieblings-Let's-Player, der in der Lieblingswelt, die man so gerne miterlebt, dass der spielt, dass man den jemals in echt kennenlernen muss. Sondern das kann von mir die Horde amerikanischer, gelangweiliger Twitcher sein, die dann irgendwie acht Stunden am Tag spielen. Und dann gucke ich mir das halt auch mal zwei Stunden an. Und habe dann auch gefallen daran. So wie man sich ja auch Filme anschaut, ohne jemals Tom Cruise begegnet zu sein. Man muss einfach nicht, die Echtwelt ist da einfach nicht vonnöten. Aber beim Thema Dating eben schon. Und da finde ich das so interessant, dass das Thema Dating nicht so eine umfangreiche, aber wie er es formuliert, so eine wichtige Horde spielt. Dass er glaubt, beim Dating wird es losgehen. Das ist so das Einfallstor, wie das Metaverse, wo wir alle sagen, weil das glaube ich gar nicht. Also da widerspreche ich einfach der knappen Aussage in diesem Buch, wie sie da drin steckt.
Ich würde mich dem nur anschließen wollen. Noch zwei Fragen aber aufwerfen. Wir sind uns jetzt einig, dass es für manche Bereiche sicherlich sinnvoll ist. Aber man kann sich auch fragen, muss eigentlich diese Immersion, die da versprochen wird, durch die Brille, durch ich gehe durch die Welten überhaupt sein? Du hast das Thema Tom Cruise gerade aufgebracht. Wenn ich im Kino sitze, auf der Leinwand Tom Cruise sehe, reicht das nicht einfach aus? Also was sagt das eigentlich über unser Abstraktionsvermögen, wenn wir immer glauben, wir müssen so eine möglichst real sich anführende Welt nachbasteln, damit wir dann auch wirklich drin sind. Wir gehen ja in die Oper jetzt mal wieder zusammen. Und in der Oper sehen wir vorne ein Orchester sitzen. Da wissen wir, die kommen jetzt alle kurz vorher rein und haben ein bisschen noch geprobt und jetzt legen die los. Dann geht ein Vorhang auf. Dann werden irgendwelche Dinge mechanisch hin und her gefahren auf der Bühne. Das mag vielleicht mal eine Ausstattungsorgie dann sein, aber wir sehen doch in jedem Moment, es ist Kulisse. Und trotzdem sind wir ergriffen davon, sind wir in einer anderen Welt. Und hier kommt jetzt eine Ideologie, die uns sagt, nee, erst wenn das 100 Millionen Pixel hat, wenn man das mit dem bloßen Auge nicht mehr kennt, dann erst können wir das in irgendeiner Weise genießen. Da würde ich sagen, nein, ich kann das im Theater, ich kann es im Kino, ich kann überall meinen Metaverse dort doch erleben und benötige diese Immersion dieses zum Anfassen gar nicht.
Ja, da kann ich dir nur sagen, was mir auch im Buch wichtig war, was mein neues Lebensmotto ist. Am Ende ist es total egal, ob ich in einem Metaverse oder auf der echten Insel sitze, die wunderschön mir die Südsee zeigt. Die entscheidende Frage wird umso mehr sein, mit wem und nicht was. Und da hat das Metaverse nun keine Antwort drauf.
Eine letzte Frage noch an dich. Da gibt es diesen Begriff scoiomorph. Das meint, dass man von 2007 bis 2013 das Apple Betriebssystem so angelegt hat, dass es rückgebunden war an die analoge Welt. Das heißt, man hatte ein digitales Bücherregal, das wie ein Bücherregal aussah. Man hatte die Notizen-App, die ein bisschen wie ein Notizzettel aussah und so weiter. Das nennt man scoiomorph. Jetzt aber ist etwas eingetreten, oder schon vor ein paar Jahren, dass es nicht mehr scoiomorph ist. Das heißt, man hat nicht mehr die Referenz zur realen Welt, sondern sagt einfach, so sehen jetzt bei uns Notizen aus. Oder Bücher, da kann man jetzt auf so Buttons klicken oder so. Es sieht nicht mehr aus wie ein Buch, das im Regal steht. Glaubst du, dass wir diesen Loslösungsprozess noch viel stärker erleben werden? Also dass das scoiomorfe ganz verschwindet und dass wirklich eigene Welten dann entstehen, im Sinne von, die haben gar nichts mehr mit unserer Realität zu tun? Oder passt sich die Realität wiederum anders an und wird die Realität scoiomorph, dass man sagt, ach ja, Bücher, Moment, das sieht ja im Apple Shop so aus, da müssen wir die auch mal wieder so drucken.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt, ich schaue gerade jetzt in diesem Moment auf dieses Speichern Symbol in der Word Datei, in der Word App, die immer noch nach Diskette aussieht. Ja, die Diskette ist schon kein richtig analoges, weil da wurde ja auch digital drauf gespeichert und so. Es ist schon aus dem Internetzeitalter, aber es ist trotzdem so lange her. Und ich glaube, Mark Zuckerberg scheitert und das weiß er auch an sich selber. Denn die Losung ist, die Innovationen sind die ganze Jungen. Ball hat es ja auch beschrieben, bei Roblox spielen Leute, die für Mark Zuckerberg am gefährlichsten sind, weil sie niemals auf den Gedanken kämen, sich bei Facebook einen account zu machen.
So.
Und Mark Zuckerberg weiß, dass die Innovationen sowohl von den Nutzern, als auch die Techniker sind, wenn sie alt sind, sind sie halb so alt wie er. Eigentlich sind sie noch jünger, sind die 14- bis 18-Jährigen.
Naja, die Roblox ja schon Spiele herstellen. Das ist ja der Trick bei Roblox.
Er hat diese ganze Kontrolle über seine Facebook-Welt, die so langsam rausschiftet aus den neuen Generationen, die so von unten nachwachsen. Er wird selber so ein Dino sein, wie wir uns heute das CDF und so weiter anschauen. Was für ein aller Laden, wer braucht denn sowas? Die haben ja nur versucht, das Bestehende zu digitalisieren. Das war ja auch bei Google ganz lange. Google Books, Google Maps, einfach nur das. Und dann hatten wir plötzlich dieses Roblox, wo man stellt fest, ach so, die Leute brauchen eigentlich, die wollen gar nicht, also Google Maps, klar, das verwendet man mal so kurz und dann finden wir noch toll, dass man sich in der Welt zurechtfindet. Aber wenn man sich eine Welt aussuchen kann, nee, dann geht man eigentlich zu Roblox und Mineshaft. Und da werden so alle physischen Gesetze, nur ein bisschen nachgeahmt, aber schon aufgehoben. Bei Fortnite springt man plötzlich so einen dritten Stock hoch und wechselt die Waffen da und so. Und es ist halt, in der Ansicht, nee, das wird alles hinter uns bleiben, glaube ich. Diese analoge Welt in viel krasserem Ausmaß noch, als wir uns heute vorstellen können.
Und das kann man in diesem Buch wirklich sehr gut nachvollziehen und vor allem auch technisch visiert nachvollziehen. Das finde ich einfach sehr, sehr gut an diesem Werk, dass es mal gründlich erklärt, wie funktioniert das eigentlich, dass ein digitales Bild plötzlich begehbar wird, dass wir beide dieses Bild in gleicher Weise sehen können. Und was fehlt noch auf dem Weg dorthin? Es ist also nicht irgendein Investoren-Geschwätz, das wir hier lesen. So jetzt investieren, das ist the next big thing. Sondern es ist einfach mal eine sehr, sehr fundierte Analyse des Status Quo mit einer Perspektive darauf, was in den nächsten Jahren möglich sein könnte. Ob das dann wünschenswert ist, das ist wieder eine andere Frage.
So ist es.
Matthew Ball legt ein sehr fundiertes, sehr gründlich recherchiertes Buch zum Metaverse vor. Es ist kein Buch, das irgendwelche Luftschlösser bauen will, sondern das sehr genau den Status Quo analysiert und perspektivisch aufzeigt, wohin die Reise gehen könnte, was wünschenswert wäre und was wir doch eher fürchten sollten. Ein Buch, das alle interessieren sollte, die vielleicht doch ein bisschen digitaler in Zukunft leben werden. Also uns alle müsste es interessieren.
Richtig. Und du sagst es, es ist noch ein Buch, was uns mal wieder zeigt, nein, wir müssen nicht den YouTubern hinterher ins Metaverse, ihre Twitch-Live-Erfahrung bei Cyberpunk folgen, sondern wir können es noch mal nachlesen. Wir können uns das Buch vorlesen lassen, wir können es uns digital schicken lassen. Wahrscheinlich hat er es diktiert oder mit sonst irgendwelchen Unterstützung, technischer Art geschrieben. Aber es ist noch ein Buch über das Metaverse und deswegen so zu empfehlen.
Wenden wir uns jetzt den Sesselgenerellen zu. Allein das ist doch schon ein wunderschönes Wort. Es stammt von Nathalie Weidenfeld, die hat in der Süddeutschen Zeitung einen längeren Leiterartikel geschrieben und der beginnt so. Neulich saß ich mit einem langjährigen französischen Bekannten ausgewiesenem linken und erfolgreichen Filmproduzenten in einem Café in Paris. Wir unterhielten uns über das Leben und darüber, was uns derzeit am meisten bewegt. Für ihn war es der Einzug zweier junger ukrainischer Frauen in seine Familie. Zutiefst beeindruckt sei er gewesen, als die beiden Frauen sich vor einigen Wochen in Frankreich Munition und Schusswaffen besorgt hätten, um diese ihren Väter in der Ukraine zu bringen. Er sagte, er bewundere dieses Volk für seine Entschlossenheit und seinen Mut, sein Land zu verteidigen. Die Pariser Kaffeehausbewunderung für den Einsatz zweier Frauen für den Krieg von Seiten eines schmächtigen französischen Intellektuellen, behütet in einer schicken großbürgerlichen Wohnung im 16. Jahrhundert aufgewachsen, war faszinierend. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir auch hin und wieder medial gesehen haben. Und sie bringt dann gleich noch ein weiteres Beispiel. Ich musste an einen deutschen Freund denken, einen überaus sensiblen Schriftsteller, der gleich zu Beginn des Krieges verkündet hatte, er verstehe jetzt endlich Hemingways Einsatz im Krieg. Und es sei nun das Gebot der Stunde, an die Front zu gehen. Auch wenn er selbst das natürlich nicht tun werde. Während viele gerade ältere ex-generelle Politiker, Sicherheitsexperten wie Klaus von Dohnany oder Henry Kissinger, die den Zweiten Weltkrieg und den Kalten Krieg noch erinnern, die langjährigen Bemühungen um strategische Stabilität, die permanente Angst vor einer nuklearen Selbstvernichtung jetzt ausdrücklich für eine Option auf den Verhandlungstisch plädieren, erhitzen sich ausgerechnet bei vielen jüngeren Intellektuellen die beläzistischen Gemüter. Und dann fragt sie sich, wie kann das eigentlich sein? Es ist doch eine ganz eigenartige Zeit, in der wir leben. Zum einen haben wir da auf der Buchmesse ein Awareness-Team, das rumläuft und das, wenn man sich in irgendeiner Weise beleidigt, belästigt fühlt, kann man sich daran wenden. Aber zugleich ist man dann dabei, bedingungslos zu heroisieren bzw. dann den Gegner zu demonisieren. Da ist man sich nicht zu fein, für irgendwelche brutalen Mittel zu plädieren oder auch entsprechende Worte zu wählen. Sie schreibt dann auch zunächst einmal die Beobachtung, dass gerade jene, die von der Woken-Gesinnung inspiriert und also stets strategisch auf Phrasen wie die Frauen oder die Indianer reagieren, also stets allergisch auf Phrasen wie die Frauen oder die Indianer reagieren, im Falle des Ukraine-Konflikts deutlich problemloser von den Russen oder auch den Ukrainern sprechen und diese dabei in stereotypisierte Klischees stecken, vor denen sie sonst leidenschaftlich warnen. Also erst einmal Ausdruck von großer Verwunderung. Nun ist sie Kulturwissenschaftlerin und versucht das natürlich ein bisschen größer zu verbinden. Sie verweist darauf, dass der Topost des Wilden Westen ein ganz, ganz wichtiger ist, aber der Wilde Westen ist auch ein mythologischer Ort. Hier im Wilden Westen, so die großen Narrative der Amerikaner, da kann man nicht nur durch Gewalt Besitz erwerben, sondern man kann auch, schreibt sie, dann zu sich selbst durch Gewalt kommen. Also, indem man gewalttätig ist, wird man erst jemand. Und dann bringt sie ein Beispiel, das mir so gar nicht bewusst war, nämlich Theodore Roosevelt. Keiner personifizierte diese Suche besser als Theodore Roosevelt, der von 1901 bis 1909 US-amerikanischer Präsident war. Roosevelt, ein New Yorker mit hoher Stimme und schwacher Konstitution, von Journalisten als Jane Dandy verspottet, zog mit 25 Jahren in den Westen, kaufte sich eine Ranch und begann mit der Erschaffung einer neuen Persona. Zu einer Zeit, in der an der Ostküste ein neuer Typ Mann, der gewaltfreie und ökonomisch erfolgreiche Gentleman seinen Siegeszug vollendet hatte, begann Roosevelt, an dessen maskulinem Gegenentwurf zu arbeiten. Er arbeitete als Cowboy, er nahm immens zu, legte seine Brille ab und härtete seinen Körper mit einer fanatischen Entschlossenheit. Immer wieder posierte er auf Fotografien in einem Wild West Outfit, um damit seine Transformation zum harten Mann zu belegen, die schließlich in seinem Einsatz im spanisch-amerikanischen Krieg kulminierte, indem er mit seinen Rough Riders zu einem Kriegshelden avancierte. Erst dann war klar, dass Roosevelt wirklich der richtige Mann ist. Roosevelt ist dann auch wirklich ein Trendsetter geworden für diese Männlichkeit. Jetzt fragt sich Weidenfeld, sind die westlichen Intellektuellen, so wie der französische Filmproduzent oder der deutsche Schriftsteller, ähnlich wie Theodore Roosevelt in seinen jungen Jahren, es insgeheim leid, in einer Zeit zu leben, in der die Männlichkeit sich in einer Krise befindet? Also es ist ja ganz interessant, dass wir wirklich diese mitunter Kriegslüsternheit erleben, bei Leuten, die sonst jeglichen Männlichkeitskult infrage stellen und vieles ja auch zu Recht infrage stellen, dass die aber offenbar selbst darunter leiden, dass dieses Männlichkeitsbild nicht mehr präsent ist, dass also eigentlich dieser auch damit verbundene Vitalismus ihnen fehlt und all das. Und ob das nicht jetzt quasi projiziert werden kann auf das ukrainische Volk oder den heroischen Krieg oder den Soldaten, die an die Front gehen, es ist ein bisschen vergleichbar vielleicht mit gewissen Salonlinken der 80er, 90er Jahre, für die auch vollkommen klar war im Westen, wir werden uns noch nicht mal mehr an einem Streik auf der Straße beteiligen. Wir haben eigentlich nichts mehr damit zu tun. Wir bleiben im Elfenbeinturm, aber wir bewundern unglaublich, wie toll diese lateinamerikanischen linken Bewegungen agitieren, auf die Straße gehen, demonstrieren. Also man hat dann ein historisches Objekt, das man selbst nicht mehr erfüllen kann, woanders hin projiziert und sehnt sich denn da hinein. Das ist etwas, die so übertragen, die dann auch stattfindet. schreibt dann auch, oder ist es das Inuit eines Beschützten, also Inuit, das ist ein Begriff, der für die Bohem wichtig ist, für die zweite Hälfte des 19. Jahrhunderts in Frankreich. Also man ist so ein bisschen getrieben, ein bisschen ratlos, gibt es überhaupt noch Sinn in meinem Leben? Ist nicht alles auch furchtbar langweilig? Oder irgendwas treibt einen dann zu den Frauen, zur Kunst, zum Rausch, zum Opium, was auch immer? Oder ist es das Ennui eines beschützten intellektuellen Lebens, das die primitivistische Sehnsucht nach einem wahren, rohen und gewaltsamen Leben hervorbringt? Freud schrieb, Krieg lässt den Urmenschen in uns wieder zum Vorschein kommen. Und das, glaube ich, ist sehr gut gesprochen von Freud. Denn wir erleben ja jetzt Dinge, die man nicht für möglich gehalten hat. Ich will nur ein Beispiel herausgreifen, weil es gestern bei Twitter viral ging. Und zwar hat sich das ukrainische Verteidigungsministerium sowohl mit einem Video bei Frankreich, als auch mit einem Video bei Deutschland bedankt für die Waffenlieferung. Man hat bei dem französischen Dankesvideo das berühmte Je T'aime genommen und hat das immer zwischengeschaltet dann mit erotischen, beziehungsweise sehr so Kitschbildern aus Frankreich und Waffen, irgendwelchen Panzern, die losschießen. Und für das deutsche Dankesvideo hat man auf Supergeil zurückgegriffen von Friedrich Lichtenstein, der, so heißt es zumindest bei der Tagesschau, nicht befragt wurde, nicht angefragt wurde, ob das überhaupt genehmigt wird. Und dann hat man immer diese Bilder von ihm zwischengeschnitten mit deutschen Waffen, die abgefeuert werden. Und das ist eine solche Enthumanisierung, die da stattfindet. Man kann ja aus einer realpolitischen Erwägung jetzt lange darüber reden, Waffen ja, nein, wenn ja, welche, wie viele. Das haben wir auch alles viel schon behandelt. Aber dass man eine solche Verkitschung und Kulturindustrialisierung von Waffen vornimmt, die letztlich dazu da sind, Menschen zu töten, ist wirklich eine unglaubliche Geschmacklosigkeit. Und dass das aber nicht skandalisiert wird, sondern dass das sogar dann noch von entsprechenden Leuten, deren Namen wir hier nicht erwähnen, geteilt wird, das ist für mich wirklich unerträglich zu sehen. Und ich glaube, dass gerade hier so Stimmen wie von Weidenfeld sehr wichtig sind, dass man einfach mal fragt, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Seid ihr euch vielleicht eurer Wolfgang-Männlichkeit doch gar nicht so selbstsicher und braucht jetzt doch wieder irgendwo anders den starken Mann? Dann wird es vielleicht doch auch hier der Fitnessstudio Besuch tun. Sie schreibt dann am Ende, wird ausgeblendet, dass es nach dem brutalen Überfall Putins auf die Ukraine im Februar nun nicht um Regeneration durch Gewalt gehen kann, sondern dass junge ukrainische und auch russische Männer, Söhne, Brüder und Ehemänner, dass viele viele zivile Opfer auf ukrainischer Seite, dass Familien, Frauen und Kinder noch ihr Leben werden lassen müssen. Statt imaginäre Krieger zu sein, sollten wir, wo es geht, also auch rhetorisch zur Friedensstiftung beitragen. Also ein sehr guter Einwurf hier und das auch nochmal zurückzubinden an Freud. Mir scheint er auch, dass da einige Kräfte entfesselt wurden, von denen wir glaubten, sie seien unter all den politisch korrekten Diskursen domestiziert. Das war überhaupt das Einzige, was ich dann doch immer diesen Leuten dazu gut halten konnte. Na ja, sie sind zumindest, vielleicht sind sie manchmal ein bisschen hypersensibel, aber sie sind bestimmt, haben so ein ein pazifistisches Element in sich. Aber das scheint ja gerade nicht der Fall zu sein, sondern die eine, er hat es so eine Hyperkompensation gegeben, die sich dann jetzt in so einer Triebabfuhr umschlägt. Es ist ein bisschen gespenstisch.
Das stimmt. Wie wenig das zusammenpasst, ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dieser Wogdiskurs auf der einen und dann diese Kriegsrezeption auf der anderen Seite. Ich vermute da immer noch zu wenig Distanz zwischen Film und Wirklichkeit oder so. Das da einfach so eine grundsätzliche Verwechslung, dass man es nicht glauben kann, dass der Krieg echt ist oder wie auch immer, dass die Geschosse auch irgendwo landen, nachdem sie so ästhetisch abgeschossen wurden. Scheint da irgendwie noch nicht oder wie auch immer noch ist falsch. Scheint da nicht bewusst zu sein.
Einfach noch mal im Westen nichts Neues sich ansehen. Ich habe es ja schon mal im Salon empfohlen.
Ja, ich habe es auf meiner Liste.
Dieser Netflix-Film ist wirklich herausragend.
Und 1917 wollte ich mir auch noch mal anschauen.
Ja.
Genau. Ich bleibe beim Thema. Lässt Putin mit sich verhandeln, fragt Michael Thumann auf Seite 2 der Zeit. Ich hatte mir so ein bisschen vorgenommen, komm, jetzt hast du hier die Zeit liegen, ein Text findest du da raus. Und ich war doch überrascht, dass die ersten Seiten mir alle sehr zugesagt haben. Deswegen nehmen wir gleich die Seite 2. 99 Tage hielt das Gedreide abkommen, das Putin eigentlich auch nur auf 120 Tage angelegt hatte. Also er hatte da selber noch mal ein Zeichen setzen wollen. Nein, dieses Ausfohren des Getreides, kennen wir ja, da auf der Krim gelagert, unter russischer Hoheit auf ukrainischen Gebiet und dann blockiert, dass gebraucht wird in Nordafrika und so weiter. Jetzt wird es gerade wieder nicht geliefert. Und stellt sich die Frage, kann man mit so einem Vertragsbrecher über einen Waffenstillstand verhandeln? Zitat, es wurde viel ausprobiert seit dem russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine im Februar. Das fand ich interessant, denn es wurde viel ausprobiert, heißt ja, ich habe nicht viel mitbekommen. Ja, mit irgendwelchen Gesprächen. Naja, es gab jedenfalls an der belarussischen Grenze gleich zu Beginn Gespräche und dann in Istanbul. Da hat man zumindest die Rahmenbedingungen so ein bisschen mehr gehört, nachdem sich da Erdogan und so auch positionieren wollte. Themen sind dann sowohl die Demilitarisierung von Teilgebieten der Ukraine als auch, ständiges Gesprächsthema, De-Nazifizierung. Also die Russen nutzen dann auch die Gelegenheit, wenn es schon zu Gesprächen kommt, dann immer noch ihren Punkt dazu machen. Zwischenzeitlich kam sogar aus Kiew der Vorschlag, die Krim aus Verhandlungen auszuklammern. Beispielsweise, das fand ich sehr überraschend, ich habe das vorher nicht gehört. Aber es lag wohl eine Idee auf dem Tisch, Russland die Krim zuzusprechen im Rahmen eines Leasing-Vertrags über 100 Jahre.
Ah ja.
Damit alle jetzt mit gutem Gesicht da irgendwie rauskommen, aber es trotzdem keinen permanenten Annektionsanspruch gibt. Na ja, Putin hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt allerdings alle Treffen mit Zelensky abgelehnt. Dadurch kam es nicht auf höherer Ebene. Es blieb also Arbeitsebene. Friedensverträge und ähnliches müssen, wenn sie sein, über die westlichen Staaten abgewickelt werden. Das ist super interessant. Ich habe da auch gar nicht vorher drüber nachgedacht. Es wünschen sich ja alle irgendwie so Friedensgespräche, Friedensverträge, die dann vielleicht im Raum stehen. Das bedeutet aber, sie müssen ja abgesichert werden. Wer sagt denn der Ukraine, dass Russland dann nicht sagt, okay, dann haben wir jetzt so einen symbolischen Frieden hergestellt, lassen die Gemüte beruhigen und dann in zwei Monaten fallen wir halt wieder das Land ein. Nicht so mit so einem großen Trara, sondern dann halt dieser kleine Partisan-Krieg oder wie auch immer, dass man so ein Schwälen, das hat wie die letzten Jahre. Und da wäre es natürlich super wichtig für so ein Vertrag, dass er abgesichert ist. Was bedeutet, jetzt gerade strampelt die Ukraine auf eigene Faust und wird natürlich nirgendwo aufgenommen. Weder in der NATO noch in der EU. Das sind alles langfristige Projekte. So ein Friedensvertrag zwischen der Ukraine und Russland würde allerdings de facto einen Artikel 5-artigen Paragrafen beinhalten. Wo es heißt, das ist jetzt der Frieden. Wenn der gebrochen wird, dann kommt Rest Europa auch zur Hilfe. Und zwar nicht nur mit Waffenlieferung, sondern dann als echte Unterstützung. Und das wäre natürlich auch eine echte Zäsur in dieser ganzen juristischen Gemengelage, die da so dahinter steckt. Also es ist schon recht heikel, derzeit lehnen sowohl Amerika als auch alle europäischen Länder diese Art von involviert sein ab. Auch, würde ich jetzt wieder vermuten, weil sie ja gerade schon so krass involviert sind. Und das eben bewusst auf einer informalen Ebene. Dass man es auf dieser formalen Ebene hier nicht braucht. Na ja, darüber hinaus gibt es jedenfalls derzeit keine weiteren Beistandsklauseln, da auch alle UN-Texte immer am Veto Russlands scheitern würden. Also es gibt gar keinen völkerrechtlich gerechtfertigten Eingriff der Ukraine unterstützenden Staaten auf ukrainischem Grund und Boden. Weil das dann ein Kriegseintritt wäre, der entweder irgendwie eine vertragliche Klausel braucht, auch in künftigen Verträgen, die dann entsprechend zu schreiben werden. Oder eben bei der UN, aber das steht ja aus. Es wird also aktuell so gar nicht über den Krieg verhandelt. Es gibt keine sichtbaren Verhandlungen zum Thema Ende des Krieges. Aber Gefangenenaustausche. Bislang 28 Austauschvereinbarungen mit 978 befreiten Ukrainern und Briten, Amerikanern, Schweden, Kroaten und Marokkanern. Was bedeutet, jeweils sind die diplomatischen Vertretungen dieser Länder da auch richtig involviert. Putin bekam auf diese Weise beispielsweise Viktor Medvedchuk zurück. Das gilt so als sein Sprachrohr in Kiew und hätte die Invasion Kiews funktioniert, wäre er auch der wohl erste Kandidat gewesen, um diese Stadtteil der Position da irgendwie zu übernehmen. Also man hat nicht nur aus dem Militär, sondern auch aus dieser paramilitärischen Zivilgesellschaft, die Putin da unterhält, in der Ukraine recht wichtige Leute da irgendwie so gefangen genommen, dass sie dann auch im Rahmen diplomatischer Anstrengung da eine große, große Rolle spielten. Diese Art der Gespräche allerdings, sagt Andrei Kutronov, ein unabhängiger Politikwissenschaftler und Leiter des russischen Rats für internationale Angelegenheiten. Diese Arten der Gespräche seien allerdings nur im Abseits zu finden, Zitat, keine Twitterei, keine Erklärung, keine öffentlichen Erwartungen. Also da hält man sich dann aus dieser Sphäre, die ansonsten so eifrig bespielt wird, raus. Und in Sachen Frieden sieht derzeit niemand eine Möglichkeit und es gibt keine Versuche. Im Finale heißt es hier, Andrei Kutronov glaubt, zur ernsthaften Verhandlung werde es erst kommen, Zitat, wenn beide Seiten die Hoffnung verloren haben, die Hoffnung, diesen Krieg noch zu gewinnen. Da sind wir wieder bei Alexander Kluge. Genau, erst wenn die Materialschlacht so richtig einmal durch ist und man dann so nach jeweils 100.000 abgeschossenen Drohnen und tausenden Panzern und zehntausenden Leben feststellt, ne, so richtig weiter kommen wir hier nicht und die öffentliche Meinung trägt es auch nicht mehr. Erst dann sind überhaupt Friedensverhandlungen möglich. Was bedeutet, umso mehr auf Twitter eingepiept wird, entweder weil die Ukrainer solche Angebote machen, solche Retweets zu machen oder weil man von sich aus irgendwie nochmal die Heldenhaftigkeit der Ukrainer lobt und so weiter sind Verhandlungssituationen in die Ferne gerückt. Das ist ein bisschen paradox, aber ja, man kann nur noch hoffen, auf so eine gewisse Geheimdiplomatie.
Ich denke da an Angela Merkel, kann die nicht mal sich ein bisschen erkenntlich zeigen. Also es gibt ja doch noch oder so ein paar andere aus dieser Riege der großen Staatsmänner und Frauen, die jetzt auf dem alten Teil sind. Ich meine da nicht Gerhard Schröder, sondern andere, die Kontakte haben nach Moskau in die Ukraine. Also dass da auf diesem Wege, was dann wirklich noch weiter weg von der Öffentlichkeit ist, als das, was du uns jetzt hier geschildert hast, dass auf diesem Wege versucht wird zu verhandeln. Denn ohne das wird es nicht gehen. Und das sind so Sätze wie in die Ukraine Musiken oder so, die man sagen kann aus Fernsehsesseln heraus, die aber überhaupt nichts bedeuten. Also da ist jede Aussage zum Metaverse am Ende sinnvoller als sowas einfach mal loszulassen. Und deswegen, glaube ich, kann man nur hoffen, dass das so auf dieser Ebene noch ist. Denn die Eskalation ist ja nach wie vor eine reale Gefahr. Wir schlittern auf einen Atomkrieg zu. So ist der Text überschrieben von Jeremy Shapiro. Er ist Forschungsdirektor beim European Council on Foreign Relations. Dieser Artikel ist bei Internationale Politik und Gesellschaft erschienen, also von der Friedrich Ebert Stiftung. Und dieser Text beginnt mit Im Krieg ist nichts unvermeidlich und wenig vorhersehbar. Doch wie sich der Krieg in der Ukraine entwickelt, können wir von außen erkennen und beschreiben. Aus dem rechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine ist ein Stellvertreterkrieg zwischen Washington und Moskau geworden. Sofern sich die derzeitige Entwicklung fortsetzt, wird die Eskalationsspirale, in der sich die beiden Seiten befinden, eine direkte Konfrontation herbeiführen und in einen Atomkrieg münden, der Millionen von Menschen das Leben, Kosten und weite Teile der Welt zerstören wird. Das ist der Manneinstieg. Er geht dann dazu über, dass er darauf hinweist, Joe Biden hat vor dieser Gefahr gewarnt. Und bei ihm scheint es wohl so zu sein, dass er mit so einer Offenheit, in dem er das anspricht, versucht, einen solchen Ausgang des Krieges zu vermeiden, dass es zu einer Nuklearkatastrophe kommt. Im Moment scheint keine Partei willens- und politisch in der Lage zu sein, eine solche Konfrontation zu verhindern, schreibt Shapiro. In den Vereinigten Staaten werden Stimmen, die diese Gefahr auch nur andeutend scharf verurteilt, weil man fürchtet, die Entschlossenheit des Westens könnte dadurch geschwächt werden. Man hat ja auch diesen Spott hier erlebt in den deutschen Medien, dass wenn vor der nuklearen Gefahr vor dem Atomkrieg gewarnt wird, man sagte, ja, da ist sie wieder, die German Angst oder was auch immer. Und hier schreibt Shapiro, wird dann gleich auf das Jahr 1938 verwiesen auf die Appeasement-Politik und will man sich dann etwa wieder daran orientieren. Ungeachtet dieser Schmähungen lässt sich die Gefahr aber nicht mindern, indem man sie verschweigt, sagt Shapiro. Und ich will auch noch mal darauf hinweisen, im Zweiten Weltkrieg hatten wir noch keine, beziehungsweise Hitler hatte keine Atombombe. Das ist schon mal ein ganz entscheidender Unterschied. Weiter heißt es dann über ein mögliches Szenario. Kein vernünftiger oder auch nur zurechnungsfähiger Staatschef bricht geplant einen Atomkrieg vom Zaun. Also das ist auch deswegen eine vollkommen unnütze Überlegung, dieses wie wir das mal hatten bei so einem ukrainischen, literarischen Künstler, der sagte, ja der Putin hat nicht die Eier dafür, das zu machen. Darum geht es überhaupt nicht. Shapiro sagt, bei aller Risikofreude ist im russischen Regime auch keine Selbstmordneigung auszumachen. Wir haben es nicht mit bloßem Irrsinn zu tun, sondern mit einem im Kern unberechenbaren Problem kommt eine Eskalationsspirale erst in Gang. Können mehrere einzelne an sich vernünftige Schritte die Welt in eine aberwitzige Lage stürzen? Im Fall des Ukraine Krieges haben beide Parteien öffentlicher Glättenkrieg keinesfalls verlieren zu dürfen. Und das ist eine schöne Sache, die hier zusammenkommt in der Argumentation. Also einzelne vernünftige Schritte führen zu einer aberwitzigen Lage. Also, wenn das, dann das. Das ist wiederum alles in den Protokollen so vorgesehen. Wir müssen darauf reagieren. Es kann nicht angehen, das und in dieser Logik heraus, aus dieser Logik heraus, kann es dann zu dieser Eskalation kommen. Die roten Linien der Russen, schreibt Shapiro, die stellen sich immer wieder als rosa heraus, wo raus dann wiederum westliche Medien ableiten. Naja, dann ist das doch auch mit dieser nuklearen Bedrohung alles nur ein Getöse. Dessen kann man sich aber nicht sicher sein. Wann wird man dann als unmittelbare Konfliktpartei von den Russen gewertet? Also es sind ja jetzt auch amerikanische Soldaten in der Ukraine. Das hat ja dieser Brigadegeneral Pat Ryder von der Luftwaffe bestätigt, bei einer Pressekonferenz, das war diese Woche. Da sagte er ja, ja, da ist US-Personal und die nehmen Inspektionen vor Ort vor, um die Waffenbestände da zu kontrollieren und so was. Das wird jetzt offenbar von den Russen noch nicht gewertet, als ein Einsatz von US-Soldaten auf ukrainischem Gebiet oder in diesem Krieg. Aber wir sehen, wie heikel da diese Situation ist. Die Signale der Russen sind, schreibt Shapiro so problematisch, weil eine gezielte Eskalation nicht von irgendwelchen Einzelhandlungen des Westens abhängt. Sondern mutmaßlich von den Fortschritten der Ukraine vor Ort. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Eskalation steigt nicht mit dem Überschreiten einer willkürlich gesetzten roten Linie, sondern mit russischen Rückschlägen auf dem Gefechtsfeld. Aber niemand weiß es genau. Wahrscheinlich wissen es nicht einmal die Russen, was denn eigentlich die rote Linie ist. Klar ist, dass beide Seiten in der Ukraine immer dann eskaliert haben, wenn sie eine Niederlage fürchten mussten. Also die Niederlage ist die ganz große Gefahr. So soll zum Beispiel die russische Annexion besetzter ukrainischer Territorien das Signal an das Inn und Ausland aussenden, dass die betroffenen Provinzen nunmehr wie russisches Staatsgebiet verteidigt werden. Im Gegenzug muss dann natürlich auch der Westen wieder darauf reagieren. Und so kann dann sehr schnell auch wieder eine Eskalationsspirale entstehen. Und diese entfaltet dann immer eine eigene Logik. Natürlich sind, schreibt Shapiro auch vorher, schon Kriege eskaliert. Doch seit 45 hat kein Krieg mehr mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen geendet. Die Vereinigten Staaten, glaubt er auch, müssten, um diese Eskalationsspirale wirklich in Gang zu setzen, wahrscheinlich noch mehr Waffensysteme liefern. Und Russland müsste, um weiter zu eskalieren, noch mehr Männer einberufen. Er schreibt mir, brutalere Gräueltaten begehen und schrecklichere, nicht-nukleare Waffen einsetzen. Sollte sich ein reiner Abnutzungskrieg entwickeln, würde es vermutlich nicht zum Atomwaffeneinsatz kommen. Das bedeutet natürlich auch unglaublich viele Tote auf beiden Seiten. Also so ein Abnutzungskrieg ist ja nicht nur einer, der das Material betrifft. Dann zitiert er Michael Kaufmann und Anja Lukianow-Fink. Sie haben sich angeschaut, was russische Militäranalysten so wollen. Und da gibt es wohl einige, die wollen eine demonstrative Gewaltausübung, die auch den Einsatz von Atomwaffen zu Demonstrationszwecken einschließen könnte. Die Argumentation dieser russischen Militäranalysten wiederum ist, dass der Westen sich eigentlich gar nicht um die Ukraine scheren würde. Und wenn jetzt Russland zu einem solchen Schritt greifen würde, dann würde bestimmt schon nichts passieren, weil so sehr wäre der Westen dann auch nicht an der Ukraine interessiert. Also das könnte von russischer Seite eine Überlegung sein für einen taktischen Atomenangriff. Aber man weiß es eben nicht, wie der Westen darauf reagiert, denn er müsste eigentlich darauf reagieren. Shapiro zeichnet es nach. Die US-Regierung zieht diesen Fall in Betracht und hat deshalb erst kürzlich den nationalen Sicherheitsberater Jake Sullivan und Außenminister Antony Blinken auf Reisen geschickt. Damit sie die Russen vor den schrecklichen und katastrophalen Konsequenzen warnen, sollten sie in der Ukraine Atomwaffen einsetzen. Falls es dazu kommt, wird sich die US-Regierung jedoch schwer tun, eine Antwort zu finden, die der Schwere des russischen Atomwaffen-Einsatzes gerecht wird, ohne eine weitere Eskalation hin zur direkten Konfrontation und einen ausgemachten Atomkrieg auszulösen. Dann geht er wirklich durch, was der Westen tun würde. Er schreibt dann etwas flapsig, auch in den USA wird ein genialer Kopf erklären, mit einer unmittelbaren und verhältnismäßigen Reaktion auf den Angriff werde man der russischen Führung klar machen, dass die USA den verbrecherischen Einsatz von Atomwaffen ahnten, ohne aber den Krieg zu eskalieren oder den Sturz des russischen Regimes zu betreiben. Die Warnung der Russen, strategische Atomwaffen einzusetzen, wird man als Bluff einstufen, weil in solcher Einsatz auf russischer Seite glatter Selbstmord wäre. In Ermangelung besserer Alternativen wird die US-Führung die Idee einer fein abgestimmten Reaktion aufgreifen und einen konventionellen Angriff durch die NATO in die Wege leiten, entweder auf russische Truppenverbände in der Ukraine oder auf den russischen Militärsturzpunkt, von dem der Atomschlag ausgegangen ist. Als Vorsichtsmaßnahme versetzen die USA auch ihre Atomstreitkräfte in Alarmbereitschaft. Leider aber dürfte auch eine solch subtile Botschaft im paranoiden Kreml nicht ankommen. Durch den direkten NATO-Angriff verfrustern oder russische Streitkräfte wird man dort die eigene Auffassung bestätigt sehen, dass der Festen vorhat, die russische Regierung zu zerstören und das Spitzenpersonal zu töten. Und das würde wiederum bedeuten, dass Putin sagt, gut, da müssen wir jetzt richtig eskalieren. Offenbar ist es so, dass Putin, so schreibt er hier, sich berichten zufolge wie ein Besessener immer wieder das Video vom Tod des libyschen Staatschefs Muammar al-Gaddafi ansieht, nachdem dieser von NATO-Truppen gestürzt worden war. Also Putin guckt da, ob er da seine Zukunft erblicken kann und was wäre zu tun, um diese zu vermeiden. Ja, dann geht das noch weiter. Also dann würde Artikel 5 natürlich wichtig werden und er schreibt dann aus Angst, dass durch diese NATO-Angriffe die strategischen Nuklearkapazitäten Russland zerstört werden und das Land den konventionellen Streitkräften der NATO wehrlos ausgeliefert sein könnte, werden die Russen mit einem strategischen Erstschlag versuchen, die Entschlossenheit oder die Fähigkeit des Westens zu reagieren, um das eigene System zu retten, zu brechen. In diesem Fall bleiben mir noch ein paar Minuten den Kolleginnen und Kollegen per E-Mail mitzuteilen. Ich habe es euch doch gesagt.
Ja, düster.
Ja, sehr düster, aber ich finde das schon wichtig, dass solche Artikel erscheinen und eigentlich müsste es darüber die großen Debatten geben, denn alles andere ist dann Makulatur und alles muss dahin geführt werden, dass genau eine solche Eskalation vermieden wird, auch weil sie am Ende niemandem nutzen würde. Wirklich niemandem.
So ist es wohl. Es ist auf jeden Fall super interessant, wie kompliziert dieser spieltheoretische Überbau in so einem Krieg ist, den man dann immer wieder dadurch leben muss. Ich habe zwei Texte gefunden, die so ein bisschen zusammengehören, aber nicht aus dem Oktober sind, sondern August und September. Aber trotzdem interessant, denn Jason Allen hat beim Colorado State Fair, irgendwas Kunstwettbewerb teilgenommen, eine Institution mit 150 Jahre Kunstgeschichte, bei der eben Kunst ausgestellt und auch prämiert wird. Und er hat sein Werk Theater, Dopera, Spatial mitgebracht und hat gesiegt. Und dann stellte er sich raus, ah ja, das kam gar nicht alles aus seiner Feder, sondern da hat sehr viel Computerkunst mitgewirkt. Weshalb er im Tenor bei Drew Harwell in der Washington Post klang es dann so, die Leute müssen ihre Furcht vor Technologien überwinden, die die Menschheit nach vorne bringen kann. Und das ist ja auf jeden Fall gegeben bei Kunst. Die macht ja nichts kaputt, sondern wenn die Aufklärung da ist, kann man ja sagen, ja, ein cooles Werk, auch wenn vielleicht ein bisschen der Computer mitkuratiert hat. Und dieser Alan, der Künstler, leitet selbst ein Unternehmen, das Computerspiele herstellt. Und er hat den Kunstgenerator mit Journey verwendet, der innerhalb von 60 Sekunden Bilder synthetisiert. Ganz interessant, an discord angegliedert. discord kennen wir ja, die große Schnittstelle zwischen den Welten. Und da läuft also so ein Generator, dem man einfach so ein paar Worte zuwirft. Und dann fällt Kunst heraus. Und er hat sich Teile generieren lassen und dann zusammengebaut und ergänzt. Und ist damit dann prämiert worden. Und die Washington Post hat das ziemlich groß gefahren. He used AI to win a fine arts competition. Was it cheating? Fragezeichen und ob es jetzt Betrug war, denn ja, nein, wird gar nicht so richtig geklärt in dem Text. Es steht einfach die Frage im Raum. Ist es jetzt Betrug oder nicht? Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, es gibt auch diesen Text von Kevin Roos. We need to talk about how good AI is getting. Also wir müssen darüber reden, wie gut die künstliche Intelligenz so langsam wird. Er hat also im September so ein Überblicksartikel geschrieben. Wahrscheinlich wäre es fast ein Buch geworden, bei ihm ist ja unklar, wie viel Zeit und Lust hat man denn. Und dann kommt entweder ein schlechtes Buch oder ein sehr guter Text raus. Und es geht um das Golden Age des Fortschritts. Denn er selbst hat, wie der Jason Allen, einfach mit diesen Bildgeneratoren rumgespielt. In dem Falle DOL-E2 haben wir ja schon kennengelernt. Von der Open-Eye-AI in Amerika, die ja so ein bisschen mit Google da konkurrieren. Und er wurde eingeladen, diesen Generator mal zu benutzen. Er hat sich also ein paar kleine Texte ausgedacht und dann Bilder generieren lassen. Und seinem eigenen Text in der New York Times hat er ein Coverbild vorangestellt, das er mit den Worten Infinite Joy hat generieren lassen. Also ganz minimal, einfach nur Infinite Joy. Und es hat ihm so gut gefallen, dass er es sich ausdrucken lässt, um es gerahmt in seine Wohnung zu hängen. Und das muss natürlich was heißen. Also wenn man weiß, es ist künstliche Intelligenz, die es geschaffen hat. Aber es gefällt mir so gut, dass ich gar keine Demühen des Künstlers Geschichte brauche, sondern einfach nur so ein Zu-Uf. Und dann ist er dem nachgegangen. Das technische Prinzip ist also die Diffusion, ausgehend von ganz wenigen Zufallspixeln wird dann aufgrund der Inhalte einfach ein Bild ausgrund der bestehenden Bilddatenbanken und zwar nur aus den Abbildungen. Also nicht, dass da was verwendet wird, konkret, sondern dann von Null aufgestaltet, ausgehend aus diesen Zufallspixeln werden diese Bilder kreiert. Und es sind, wie er hier sagt, mega Fortschritte, die man da sieht, nicht nur in der Kunst, sondern wir haben es mit einer noch laufenden Golden Decade zu tun. Vor fünf Jahren war es Alpha Go. Wir waren alle beeindruckt, weil wir das Spiel Go schon gar nicht kannten. Und plötzlich hieß es, das Spiel, das du nicht kennst, aber von denen alle sagen, das ist ganz schön krass, hat dann plötzlich ein Computer. Also wir haben eigentlich den Alpha Go noch früher kennengelernt als Go, wir Europäer zumindest. Und jetzt ist aber dieser Fortschritt auch von Alpha, also von DeepMind, Google steckt ja da dahinter, so gewaltig, dass es auch Fortschritte auf Gebieten gibt, die für uns alle interessant sind und nicht nur für Go-Spieler. Zum Beispiel in der Medizin dieses Proteineverhalten von DeepMind, Alpha Fold habe ich auch letzte Woche wieder mit einer Ärztin drüber gesprochen, die sind alle tief beeindruckt von diesen Sachen, die man da jetzt machen kann, weil es eben jetzt nicht nur Patienten studieren im Sinne von wir gucken mal, was passiert ist, sondern man kann halt so Vorabhypothesen überprüfen, weil man mittlerweile alle 200 Millionen Proteine kennt und weiß, wie sie sich falten werden. Man kann sich das einfach generieren lassen. Also, die Wilden.
Wie wird das gemacht?
Na, du hast diesen Strang aus Proteinen. Das sind ja die vier Basisaminosäuren. Und die liegen ja nicht in Länge, sondern der Körper findet ja dann, wie bei der DNA auch, so verschiedene Formen das Platz sparend unterzukriegen. Und das Problem mit den Proteinen ist, man kann anhand der Aminosäurenfolge nicht genau wissen, was es im Körper bewirkt, weil man auch die Faltung der ganzen Proteinkette an sich kennen muss. Die nimmt auch Einfluss auf die Wirkungsweise. Und das konnte man eben bisher nicht vorausahnen, wie die sich verhalten. Es sind zu viele, das sind zu viele miteinander. Und dadurch waren eben, gerade bei Medizin und so...
Lockchain ist zu lang.
Genau, es ist einfach zu kompliziert. Und man kann das nur experimentell machen. Man hat einen Versuch gewagt und dann hat man geguckt, was hier Folgen sind. Und das kann man jetzt so ein bisschen vorhersehen, indem man einfach diese Proteinfaltungen aufgrund der Aminosäurenfolgen nachvollzieht, im Sinne von schon mal vom Computer ausrechnen lässt. Und da gibt es auch ganz tolle Visualisierung, wo sich dann eben nicht einfach nur Doppelhelix und so, das wäre super easy, sondern total komplizierte hier da Knoten von diesen Proteinen einfach finden. Und man eben da der Wirklichkeit auf die Pelle rückt und nicht einfach nur schöne Kunst macht. So wie ja auch, das ist ja auch bei Interstellar gewesen, dass man die ganzen Animationen von schwarzen Löchern und so weiter nicht einfach nur nach Ästhetik, sondern dann hat man mit den Physikern da gesprochen, wie sieht das wirklich aus und es dann versucht im Film zu repräsentieren. Nur dass man bei einem schwarzen Loch wenig, ja es ist halt was anderes, wenn man die Sachen im Körper selbst so plötzlich so durchschaut und da so Fortschritte hat. Nach der Medizin nennt er die Textgeneratoren. Open AI GPT-3 schreibt schon Drehbücher oder attestiert zumindest. Und das fand ich dann auch interessant, wie salopp er einfach sagt, in diesem kurzen Textabschnitt geht es um Text, aber dann eben nicht nur um Drehbuchtext und was wir unter Literatur verstehen, sondern auch um den GitHub Copilot. Man lädt also seine eigenen Skripte bei GitHub hoch und dann vervollständigt GitHub schon mal so ein bisschen den eigenen Code, den man schreibt, je nachdem wie weit die durchschauen können, an was man da arbeitet. Aber so ein paar Ergänzungen, die auf der Hand liegen oder auch gerade programmieren, ist ja häufig auch nur so Tippereihe von Text, der so muss halt gemacht werden. Da kann man sich doch dann Hilfe holen. Relativ viel. Das bietet dann mittlerweile jetzt auch GitHub an. Jack Clark ist Co-Chair in der Stanford AI Index Report. Der lässt sich hier zitieren. Wir kommen jetzt vom Frühling in den Sommer. Man merkt gar nicht mehr, dass Texte, die man liest, generiert wurden. Sondern man findet auch noch echten Gefallen daran. Also in deren Sicht, wir wissen ja nicht mehr genau, wo es uns alles begegnet. Aber wenn uns ein Text richtig gut gefällt, müssen wir immer häufiger zweifeln, ob ihr nicht doch einfach eine raffinierte künstliche Intelligenz so ein bisschen mit die Buchstaben ausgesucht hat. Viele Forscher glauben jedenfalls, dass neue Anwendungen, die uns dann wirklich begegnen, unmittelbar bevorstehen. Es betrifft natürlich wieder die White-Color-Knowledge-Jobs. Also alle, die in Büros am Computer rumtippeln, sind jetzt mal wieder besonders bedroht. Ruth schreibt hier, es geht nicht darum, sich in diesem, was auch immer man jetzt vor sich sieht, zu positionieren. Hinsichtlich der Frage, ist es jetzt schlecht oder gut oder wie auch immer, sondern man muss sich jetzt einfach ganz neutral damit befassen, dass es passiert. Und die Frage nur noch ist, ob es jetzt direkt heute schon oder gleich dann morgen ist. Wer jetzt jedenfalls hier nicht auf Augenhöhe ist, droht auch ein bisschen abgemeldet zu werden. Und es gibt ja ein paar Professionen, die besser nicht abgemeldet werden, wie zum Beispiel Lehrer, Politiker und so weiter. Also so ein paar sind in verantwortlichen Rollen. Wir müssen uns jetzt darüber informieren, wie die Welt aussieht, wenn die künstliche Intelligenz aus den Laboren herauskommt. Und auch, wo wir sie in der Gesellschaft begrüßen und wo nicht. Und ganz konkret nennt er hier schon beispielsweise die Propaganda und Werbung. Also gerade die direkte politische Ansprache wird ja sehr häufiger jetzt über so Bilder gemacht, wo die Individualisierung auch auf ästhetischer Ebene so auf künstliche Intelligenz Rücksicht nimmt, also deren Potenziale einfach nimmt, um das noch zielgenauer zu machen. Und wir brauchen hier neue Debatten, nicht nur Davos, Diskussionen und Ted Talks. Sagt er so ein bisschen dyspektierlich. Er meint vor allem drei Schritte, die ihm wichtig sind. Zuerst einmal brauchen Politiker jetzt Infos. Es gibt das Stanford Institute for Human Centered Artificial Intelligence. Die machen zum Beispiel schon so drei Tagesseminare, wo man als Kongressabgeordneter, Mitarbeiter oder so Regulator auf Länderebene einfach mal hingeht und sich das drei Tage Zankt zeigen lässt. Er empfiehlt so Bücher. Brian Christian, The Alignment Problem. Oder sagt man kann sich auch durchaus mal einen Wikipedia Artikel über die Grundzüge des GPT-3 Textgenerators durchlesen, um einfach grob zu wissen, so wie so ein Metaverse Buch einfach mal lesen, dass man so einen groben Überblick hat. Google Meta Open AI empfiehlt ja eine sehr viel bessere Unternehmenskommunikation. Es kann zwar schön sein, dass sie sich jetzt durchmogeln, aber am Ende sind noch die Überraschungspotenziale so groß, dass auch die Unternehmen vielleicht in so Kommunikationsprobleme reinrennen, dass auch Politiker überschnappen, weil sie ihn auf eine öffentliche Meinung treffen, die dann sagt, das geht jetzt zu weit oder so. Und außerdem ganz selbstreflexiv, die Journalisten müssen sich jetzt auf den Stand der Dinge bringen. Man darf nie wieder Texte schreiben, mit denen irgendwie auch noch mal Skynet oder Hell 9000 genannt wird. Das finde ich natürlich sehr gut. Diese Illustration braucht niemand. Und dann schreibt er so einen schönen letzten Satz. We all need to start adjusting our mental models to make space for the new and credible machines in our midst. Also die Maschinen sind schon da. Und wir sollten uns jetzt mal mit unseren eigenen mentalen Modellen befassen, um uns auch da so ein bisschen friedfertig in die Arme der Maschinen in unserer Mitte zu werfen. Bisschen übertrieben ausgedrückt.
Aber eine gute Idee, dass Politiker sich anders informieren sollten. Ich meine, wir haben Leute wie Frank Thelen, die dann von Politikern konsultiert werden. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Oder dann Richard-David Brecht, der erzählt, alle werden arbeitslos werden. So sieht es aus. Nur das BGE kann uns retten. Das stimmt ja alles nicht. Also man müsste eher das wirklich so detailliert mal durchsprechen. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Und dann ist tatsächlich so ein Metaverse Buch die bessere Lektüre. Das war ja ohnehin mein Vorschlag, nachdem du da ganz schöne Häppchen präsentiert hattest, aus dem Bundestag zu dem neuen Buch über Olaf Scholz und Comics, dass es doch eigentlich schön wäre, wenn man sowas ins Leben setzt wie eine Stadt liest ein Buch. Sowas gibt es ja, dass man auch sagt, so jeden Monat liest der Bundestagsabgeordnete ein Buch. Wir beide wählen das aus, würde ich vorschlagen, damit nichts schiefgeht. Und dann wird darüber immer diskutiert. Und zwar alle müssen anwesend sein. Und da wird dann vier Stunden lang über dieses Buch, die Thesen diskutiert, dass mal alle auf diesem Stand sind. Da kann man sich dann unterschiedlich, je nach Partei, Linie, Ideologie oder persönlicher Fragen zu äußern und positionieren. Aber eigentlich wäre das so eine gute Grundlage. Denn wir haben ja zum Teil noch abstruse Diskussionen von bewaffneten Drohnen und so was im Ohr. Einfach auch, weil so wenig Information da ist und es immer dann nur heißt, ja wollen sie denn unsere Soldaten etwa nicht schützen und mehr kommt dann nicht. Nee, man müsste erstmal so eine argumentative Grundlage ebenen.
Genau. Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich bin ja neuerdings Mitglied im Literaturhaus hier. Ich war aber noch nie bei diesen nur internen Veranstaltungen da, aber bei einigen, wo es so ein bisschen und auf Ticketbasis einfach hingeht, schon. Und es gab jetzt die Tage auch im Literaturhaus Frankfurt wieder der Veranstaltung, bei der ich dann beijenigen, die da waren, nachfragt, habe ich was verpasst. Und dann lautet die Antwort nur, nichts verpasst. Nur alte Menschen, Ausrufezeichen. Und da dachte ich mir wieder, ja, auch das Literaturhaus Frankfurt am Main, der coolsten und wahrscheinlich auch urbansten, jüngsten, poppigsten Stadt Deutschlands, fehlt, dass das Literaturhaus mal aufgemischt wird. Und jetzt, wo du das so sagst, müsste man ja eigentlich sagen, es gibt ja mehrere Literaturhäuser in Deutschland. Alle Bundestagsabgeordneten müssen erstens wissen, welches ist das Literaturhaus in nächster Nähe zu meinem Wahlkreis. Dann müssen sie einmal im Monat verpflichtet werden, da aufzukreuzen und über ein Buch zu diskutieren. Mit spezifischen Moderatoren auf der Bühne, aber auch mit dem Publikum, das ansonsten auch noch da ist. Und dann muss man denen einfach so eine inhaltliche Agenda hinlegen und sagen, dieses Buch, nimm dir diesen Tag. Es reicht, wenn du morgens um 10 anfängst zu lesen, soweit du schaffst, bis 18 Uhr die Veranstaltung beginnt. Aber dann haben wir zumindest mal eine Textgrundlage. Und dann beredet man mal so ein paar Sachen. Diese Verpflichtung aufs Buch wäre tatsächlich nicht schlecht, gerade in diesen Zeiten, wo es immer so weiter in den Hintergrund rückt, weil auch niemand mehr rezensiert. Es wäre ja schön, wenn mal die eine oder andere Rezension gelesen würde. Aber es gibt ja auch keine mehr. In der Hinsicht einige Not am Mann.
Deswegen greife ich zu einem Buch. Und zwar von Helwig Schmidt-Glitzer, der Ädle und der Ochse Chinas Eliten und ihr moralischer Kompass. Dies ist ein Essay eines Mannes, der sich auskennt. Er ist Jahrgang 1948. Er ist Synologe, war Professor für Ostasiatische Kultur und Sprachwissenschaft an der Uni München. Er ist heute Direktor des Chinazentrums in Tübingen. Er schreibt immer wieder zu China und hier in diesem Essay versucht er, ein bisschen zu erklären, wie eigentlich China funktioniert, wie diese chinesischen Eliten aufgebaut sind, wie die Bürokratie aufgebaut ist. Aber es ist kein Essay, der jetzt versucht, einfach nur zu erläutern, wie funktioniert die kommunistische Partei, sondern das wird tatsächlich mit Kulturgeschichte, mit Historie verwoben. Ich würde sagen, dass der Essay an sich etwas zu unkritisch ist mit vielen Dingen, aber ich brauche es auch nicht immer bei der Lektüre gleich. Also das nervt mich dann auch bei vielen Texten über China. Ich muss das nicht in jeder zweiten Zeile noch mal lesen, was da auch Schlimmes passiert mit Überwachung und dergleichen, sondern mich würde manchmal auch einfach mal einen Zugang dazu interessieren, was zeichnet das Land aus, was macht es so anders, als wir das aus Europa kennen. Und was erstmal erstaunlich ist, es gibt sehr viele Verbindungen. Nämlich, wir hatten es schon angesprochen, du hattest da Clips mitgebracht von chinesischen Studenten, die hier observiert werden. Und dann meinte ich, na ja, man hat auch immer Angst vor Ideen importen, die damit einhergehen könnten, wenn die Studenten dann doch mal zurückkommen. Wie wichtig ist eigentlich das Ausland für das Inland China? Und hier liest man dann ziemlich am Anfang gleich, die Suche nach einer neuen staatlichen Ordnung hatte die politisch interessierten intellektuellen Chinas nach Europa und auf dessen Flügelmächte blicken lassen. Seit 1917 nach Russland und lange zuvor schon in Richtung Vereinigte Staaten von Amerika. Die Einheitsstaatsbildung, der Bürgerkrieg unter Abraham lincoln und die Durchsetzung der Union wurden in China zum Vorbild. In der zweiten Hälfte des letzten Jahrhunderts wurden bei der Suche nach einem eigenen Weg in die Moderne und nach der Distanzierung von Moskau die USA dann für China zum wichtigsten Gegenüber. Das heißt, China ist gar nicht so abgeschlossen immer gewesen, sondern man hat auch gesehen, naja, die versuchen auch eine Einigung in den USA und eigentlich haben die doch auch ein ähnliches Problem wie wir. Denn was deutlich sein muss, ist natürlich, dass China auch ein Vielvölkerstaat ist, dass die ganz unterschiedlich funktionierende Regionen haben, mit eigenen Mentalitäten und Ideologien. Also 1,3, 1,5 Milliarden Menschen denken da keineswegs gleich. Und wie man dies miteinander vereinen will, ist die Frage. Es heißt dann im Essay, auch wenn sich weltweit die Überzeugung durchgesetzt hat, dass alle Menschen gleich, im Verständnis mancher sogar Brüder und Schwestern sind, so bleibt dennoch die Frage auf der Tagesordnung, ob dies auf eine Homogenisierung hinausläuft oder ob nicht doch kulturelle Unterschiede weiterhin bestehen bleiben. Das ist also auf der weltpolitischen Ebene natürlich die interessante Frage. Vieles spricht für Letzteres, zumal selbst in der überschaubaren chinesischen Welt alles auf eine zunehmende, sich auf die angesprochenen kulturellen Subtexte stürzende Differenzierung zuläuft, die auch dem Begriff vom Vielvölkerstaat gerecht wird. Das heißt, auch wenn wir jetzt eine Homogenität erlebt haben, beim kommunistischen Parteitag, dass uns fast die Augen aus dem Kopf fallen, wenn wir selbst in Gleichschritt und in einer merkwürdigen Choreografie sehen, wie sich das Einschenken von T vollzieht auf dieser Partei veranstaltet. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Bilder gesehen hast. Das war ja gleich ein kleines Ballett, war das ja fast. Dann dürfen wir nicht daraus schließen, ach ja, genau, China, das ist so, wo alle dunkelgraue Anzüge tragen und alle fast so ähnlich agieren, wie Xi sich das vorstellt. Also diese Einheit, die da nach außen transportiert wird, überdeckt natürlich den Vielvölkerstaat und verdeckt auch die konfligierenden Interessen innerhalb dieses Staates. Und das ist doch ganz gut, wenn in so einem Essay einmal darauf Wert gelegt wird. Die Religion haben wir, wenn wir über Xi reden, Sprachen hin und wieder einmal angekratzt, spielt irgendwie eine Rolle. Es gibt den Bezug zum alten China, zu Konfuzius. Man versucht, so einen neuen Nationalismus auch mit Religion zu verquicken. Und dann erklärt uns hier Schmitt-Glinzer mal, warum das eigentlich so ist. Er sagt, bei all diesen Sinn-Stiftungsprozessen spielen Kulte und religiöse Deutungstraditionen eine zentrale Rolle. Denn wenn wir so einen Vielvölkerstaat haben, wenn wir konfligierende Interessen haben, muss natürlich irgendwie so eine Gemeinsamkeit hervorgehoben werden. Daher kann keine Herrschaftsvorstellung von dem Umgang und diesen Systemen absehen. Hier sind zwei Feststellungen hilfreich. Erstens, der Säkularisationsprozess in China und in Europa ist grundverschieden. Zweitens, dieser Prozess ist auf keiner der beiden Seiten abgeschlossen. Was wir ja auch hier immer mal wieder merken. Im April 2016 hat Xi Jinping auf einem innenpolitischen Gipfel zum Thema Religion betont, dass die Religionsarbeit von Partei und Staat Einfluss auf die Entwicklung des Sozialismus chinesischer Prägung habe. Sie habe Einfluss auf das konkrete Verhältnis zwischen der Partei und den Volksmassen. Sie hat Einfluss auf die gesellschaftliche Harmonie, die ethnische Einheit, die nationale Sicherheit und die Einheit unseres Vaterlandes. Was passiert hier also? Die Religionen, schreibt Schmitt-Klinzer, werden also hier durch den Staat in den Dienst genommen. Dies steht scheinbar im Gegensatz zur Rolle des Verhältnisses von Staat und Religion in Europa. Auch weil dort, anders als in China, wo sich der Staat seit der Handzeit im Prinzip über alle Kulte stellt, ein andersartiger und ebenso wenig abgeschlossener Säkularisationsprozess stattfindet. Während in China heute der Staat alles tut, um desintegrierende Kräfte in den religiösen Gemeinschaftsbildungen entgegenzuwirken, stellt sich der Staat in Europa prinzipiell jenseits der Religion dar. Also das ist etwas vollkommen anderes. Säkularisation meint hier, wir versuchen das zu trennen. Das gelingt uns dann nicht genügend für manche und manche sagen, ein bisschen müssen wir aber schonen. Auch wir brauchen noch ein Kreuz in der Schule oder diese Debatten kennen wir. Während wir es in China eher so haben, dass man diese Religionen sieht, man natürlich immer auch fürchtet, dass die die Einheit gefährden können, wenn zu stark diese Interessen sich durchsetzen. Also versucht man von Startseite hineinzugehen in die Religionsgemeinschaften und dort für eine Harmonisierung zu sorgen, damit es da nicht zu Extremismus oder irgendetwas kommt. Also es ist ein komplett anderes Konzept. China sucht die Religionen, schreibt Schmittlinzer, in ihrer Vielfalt auf den chinesischen Traum, einschließlich der Jahrhundertziele erreichen, einer Gesellschaft bescheidenen Wohlstands bis 2021 und vollständige Transformation Chinas in einen sozialistischen modernisierten Staat bis 2050 zu verpflichten. Das heißt, die werden ganz klar mit in den Dienst genommen, um diese ökonomischen und politischen Ziele zu erfüllen. Damit einher geht dann auch dieses konfuzianische Harmoniegebot. Auch das wird recht gut in diesem Essay herausgearbeitet, was das eigentlich meint. Und da kommt auch dann dieser Titel her. Da geht es ja um den Edlen und den Ochsen. Der Edle damit ist gemeint in der chinesischen Literatur oder auch älteren Geschichtsschreibungen, dass der Edle einer ist, der sich anzupassen weiß, der sich aber nicht gemein macht. Und das bedeutet auch, dass man bei diesem Prinzip der Harmonie versucht, dass man stets das Gesicht wahren kann. Und alle versuchen, eine Gesichtswahrung dem anderen zu ermöglichen. Auch selbst Figuren wie dem Zensor muss es ermöglicht sein, dass er sein Gesicht nicht verliert, dadurch dass er diese Tätigkeit ausübt. Und das ist dann rückgekoppelt an dieses Harmoniegebot, das eigentlich weitreichender ist als Koexistenz, sondern wirklich sowas meint, dass man einander eine Wertschätzung entgegenbringt. Jetzt würde ich aber da natürlich fragen, wie kann es denn sein, dass wir zu gleichem System haben, das sehr stark auf Denuziation aus ist, gerade auch durch diese digitalen Möglichkeiten. Das lässt dann der Essay mir leider unbeantwortet.
Da gibt es aber eine Erklärung. Ja, dieses, wir waren noch zusammen bei Strittmacher damals in diesem Vortrag im Architekturmuseum. Und da hat es ja ein bisschen erklärt, dass die Chinesen dieses scoring-system sehr begrüßen, weil das ihnen selbst die Möglichkeit gibt, ohne jemanden persönlich denuzieren zu müssen oder denuziert zu werden, sich als edle Menschen darzustellen. Und dann auch allen anderen die Möglichkeit gibt, sich ihnen gegenüber als edle Menschen darzustellen, indem sie nämlich ein gutes scoring haben. Und man von der direkten Konfrontation dadurch absehen kann, weil sich beide am großen dritten, sozusagen dieser scoring-tabelle und ihren Regeln daran orientieren können. Also indirekt sozusagen sich des eigenen Edelseins da versichern können. Und das fand ich eine sehr gute Erklärung.
Noch ganz kurz zum zweiten Begriff, zum Ochsen. Auch das ist ein Bild, das immer wieder auftaucht. Hunderte Jahre alt ist. Wer ist mit diesem Ochsen gemeint? Der Ochse, heißt es hier, steht für den sich abmöhenden Staatsdiener, der keine Anerkennung erfährt. Eine Erfahrung, die in China bis heute wohl bekannt ist. Wer wollte ausschließen, dass nicht auch Mitglieder und insbesondere Kader der kommunistischen Partei sich im Bild des Ochsen wiedererkennen? Wenn wir hier den Darstellungen des Ochsen weiterfolgten, kämen wir bald zum Umgang mit einem erlammten Tier. Während der Konfuzianer ihm das Gnadenbrot in Form einer Rente geben will, möchte der ulitaristische Landbesitzer ihn zu Geld machen. Dem einen nämlich ist die Arbeit Ware, dem anderen geht es um den Arbeiter selbst. Diese Figur des Ochsen, die finden wir durchgehend immer wieder als Metapher. In verschiedenen politischen Reden, also dass auch diese Last zu tragen ist und man ist bereit, diese Last zu tragen. Also diese Identifikation mit diesem Tier findet dann eigentlich über die Jahrhunderte hinweg statt in der Gesellschaft. Wir wissen, es ist eine sehr geschichtsträchtige Gesellschaft. Du hast es ja mal gesagt, wenn irgendwelche Daten gesucht werden, die 900 Jahre zurückklingen, dann schauen die mal schnell nach. Das ist hier nicht möglich bei uns, aber da ist es so. Und das bedeutet natürlich, wenn man in einem solchen zeitlichen Horizont denkt, auch eine ganz andere Perspektive auf Politik und auch auf die einzelne Aufgabe des Subjekts. Ich glaube, man muss damit jetzt nicht den Universalismus über Bord werfen. Oder ich will es stärker formulieren, man sollte es auf keinen Fall tun. Aber ich glaube, dass man doch, wenn wir vor diesen rätselhaften Bildern stehen, wenn wir begreifen, wie viele Menschen eigentlich in China leben, dann ist es hilfreich, sich solche Erklärungen hin und wieder zu Gemüte zu führen, um nicht in so einer absoluten Überheblichkeit nur darauf zu blicken, sondern auch tatsächlich da mal diesen nichtwestlichen Blick, der ja sonst permanent eingefordert wird, einmal tatsächlich anzuwenden.
Das Bild mit dem Ochsen finde ich irgendwie interessant, weil am Ende ist es ja doch wieder so dieser, wie soll man sagen, wenn jemand sich in die Partei unten reinbegibt und dann erst mal nur buckelt für den Start, schwingt ja immer die Hoffnung mit, wenn ich genug gebuckelt habe, höre ich zu den Auserwählten, die dann für die Karriere vorgesehen sind. Also so ganz selbstlos ist es dann doch nicht. Auch wenn es immer eine Wette ist, die dann häufig nicht aufgeht. Sehr gut, dann kommen wir mal zu einem Thema, das wenn ein Land auf der Welt es bräuchte, sind es die Chinesen, aber wir auch. Joe Cohane schreibt in der BBC über Why Talking to Strangers Can Make Us Smarter? Also warum macht uns das echte Gespräch mit Fremden klüger? Ist natürlich eine bisschen übertriebene Überschrift, aber der Tenor hier lautet Fremde. Wir sollten uns mehr mit ihnen umgeben und mit ihnen reden. Also nicht nur dran vorbeilaufen. Vielleicht der erste Einwurf ist dann ganz gut. Wenn uns wirklich Gefahr droht, wie wir immer glauben, dass der Fremde uns Gefahr bedeutet und wir ihn deswegen möglichst im großen Bogen und so, dann müssen wir noch sagen, ne, die Kriminalstatistik sagt, Gefahren drohen uns aus unserem eigenen sozialen Umfeld, insbesondere wo es Kinder betrifft und beispielsweise sexuellen Missbrauch, wo nämlich die ganze Idee herkommt, stranger danger, rede nicht mit Fremden. Es gibt also, wir blicken ja auf eine jahrzehntelange mediale Kampagne, angeleitet von Politikern und so weiter Lehrern, Helfern aller Arten, die es natürlich alle gut meinten, mit diesem nicht mit Fremden reden. Nicht bei Fremden ins Auto einsteigen ist ja wieder was anderes, aber nicht mit Fremden reden ist ja eigentlich übertrieben, wie man heute weiß und es gibt jetzt Forschung, ja wir haben uns hier zu lange auf einem falschen Pfad bewegt. Kindern zu sagen, jeder den sie nicht kennen, sei eine Gefahr, war ziemlich schädlich für unsere Gesellschaft, ist der aktuelle Forschungsstand. Und man lässt nicht nur viele tolle Gelegenheiten links liegen, durch diese Angst vor Fremden, sondern man übergeht auch so neue Begegnungen mit sich selbst. Der Autor ist Autor eines Buches, The Power of Strangers, The Benefits of Connecting in a Suspicious World. Und da im Titel steckt schon dieser Doppelschlag drin. Umso mehr man sich den Fremden zuwendet und mit ihnen auch sich traut, ein Wort zu wechseln, umso anders wird auch das eigene Verhältnis zur Welt, in der man lebt. Und die ist ja seit mindestens 6000 Jahren, ich hätte das ein bisschen knapper, so auf die dreizehnte Jahrhundert, diese Verstetterung in Europa. Aber hier geht es um 6000 Jahre Leben unter Fremden, also mit einer Bevölkerungsdichte, bei der man sich begegnet, aber eben unter Fremden bleibt, obwohl man sich sieht. Und heute begegnet man sich ja sowieso. Wir leben ja alle in urbanen Zentren. Das ist der letzte große Megatrend, den wir haben. Aber wir reden immer weniger im Verhältnis dazu miteinander. Also die Bevölkerungsdichte wächst viel schneller als der Kontaktreichtum, der sich da ergibt. Obwohl es doch immer heißt, wir seien so soziale Wesen. Aber das stimmt gar nicht. Wir haben einfach zu viel Angst vor Zurückweisung. Wenn man sich dagegen traut, jemanden anzusprechen, redet man erstens länger als gedacht mit demjenigen und zweitens fühlt man sich auch besser als erwartet. Also von Angst und so, da bleibt doch wenig übrig. Und dieser Forschungsstand ist mittlerweile auch kulturübergreifend gültig. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit Menschheitsforschung zu tun, nicht mit irgendwelcher europäischen, chinesischen oder sonstigen Forschung.
Aber da haben wir doch eine gute Antwort auch nochmal für unsere Metaverse Frage. Also dass es vielleicht auch die Angst ist vor diesen realen Begegnungen, dass man sagt, ach ja, ich bleib lieber in der sicheren Metaverse-Welt. Da ist auch eine Zurückweisung oder so nicht so entscheidend. Das ist ja auch das, was bei Dating so eine Sache ist, die Zurückweisung direkt zu erleben oder einfach keine Antwort mehr zu bekommen im Messenger. Da sind ja schon doch deutlich Unterschiede. Und ich muss auch sagen, jetzt wo ich ja viel allein auf Reisen war, also ich hatte ja zwölf Termine in zwölf Städten im letzten Monat, dann ist man ja doch in den Hotels meistens allein und ist aber vielleicht noch abends an der Bar. Und ich bin jetzt aber auch so, dass ich doch meistens nochmal mit irgendjemanden ins Gespräch komme und wenn es nur dann die Barkeeperin ist, die mir nicht ausweichen kann. Und es ist eigentlich immer angenehm. Es war eine wunderbare Begegnung in einem Hotel in Erfurt. Die Barkeeperin kam aus Budapest, war so Mitte 50. Und dann zeigte sie mir auf ihrem Smartphone, wie schön Budapest ist. Und dann fragte ich sie, ob sie denn Marika Röck kenne. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, ja, natürlich. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ah, und dann gibt es noch diese andere wunderbare Schauspielerin. Wie heißt die? Und wir waren überlegen. Und dann kam plötzlich Jaja Gabor. Und dann haben wir darüber geredet. Also es war ganz herrlich.
Sehr gut. Ich bin ja Montag auch in Erfurt. Mal sehen, ob ich das reproduziert kriege.
Die Bar empfehlen.
Im Tiefen Osten. Umso mehr wir miteinander reden, desto besser geht es den Einzelnen und der Gesellschaft, weil man dann mit anderen Erwartungen aufeinander trifft. Und jetzt das, was du angesprochen hast. Die Jillian Sandstorm von der University of Sussex hat Forschung gemacht. 30 Probanden in der einen Gruppe und 30 Probanden in der anderen Gruppe. Sie sollten Kaffee trinken gehen. Die einen sollten mit dem oder der Barista so intensiv Kontakt aufnehmen, wie sie es anbot. Die anderen sollten möglichst sachlich und effizient einfach ihren Kaffee bestellen und fertig. Und naja, es kommt eben raus, was sich vorher auch erahnen lässt. Das Zufriedenheitslevel ist doch enorm höher, wenn man den Kaffee und die sozialen Gelegenheiten drum herum wahrnimmt. Statt einfach sich auf den Kaffee zu reduzieren. Plus, und das ist hier dann auch der Tipp für alle, dass Dienstleistungspersonal darf man ruhig ansprechen. Und es redet dann auch zurück. Und dann kann man ja gucken, wie weit es trägt. Klar, die bleiben in ihrer Beschäftigung. Du bist ja nicht der einzige an der Bar und so weiter. Aber diese Idee von, man beginnt erstmal mit einer Frage, was auch bedeutet, entweder du wirst von der Bar gefragt, was möchtest du trinken, oder du fragst zurück, was ist denn im Angebot. Eine Frage ist immer ein ganz hervorragender Einstieg in jedes Gespräch. Denn dann kommt der andere erstmal dazu, erzählen zu können. Das ist also eine Einladung. Sehr viele wissen bestimmt auch von sich selber, ja ich hätte nichts dagegen, wenn mich jemand was fragt, weil dann kann ich erstmal erzählen. Und dann weiß man ja, ich gehe erstmal auf die Frage ein. Und der andere kann dann sich aus der Antwort irgendwas raussuchen und daran anschließen. Und zack ist das Gespräch begonnen. Also man muss nicht mit Sprüchen oder sowas anfangen, sondern einfach fragen. Einfach irgendwas fragen. Kennt man ja, wo geht's hier lang, was habt ihr im Angebot, wie auch immer. Und das ist ein sehr guter Einstieg, weil dann kann man aus Gesprächen auch wieder aussteigen, weil man dann einfach sagt, achja, okay, danke. Also man beginnt mit einer Frage und endet mit einem Dank. Und damit hat niemand sein Gesicht verloren oder sonstiges, sondern das ist ein sehr guter Weg, der auch doch mal zeigt, ja, so wie du eben meintest, dieses ganze Metaverse Ding. Ja, umso weniger Körper man mit reinbringt, umso weniger ist man investiert. Klar, dann ergibt sich irgendwie Kommunikation. Aus der kommt man auch ganz einfach wieder raus. Man muss sich vielleicht nicht mal verabschieden, sondern klemmt sich einfach vom Server ab. Und dann hat man das schon erledigt. Und mit Fragen und Dankbarkeit kommt man genauso gut auch durch normale Gespräche mit echten Menschen. Ohne, dass man sich da gleich zu sehr aufreibt oder sonstiges, wovor man so viel Angst hat. Jedenfalls, umso mehr man mit Fremden spricht, desto mehr hinterfragt man auch sich selbst und lernt sich entsprechend kennen. Das, was uns am meisten davon abhält, mit anderen Leuten zu reden, ist dieser Shortcut. Ich kann mich auch mit meinem Smartphone beschäftigen, aber genau hier sollte man dann wieder stehen. Übrigens, ich habe vorhin bei Unbox Therapy ein Video gesehen, wie Lou, der diese Videos macht, diese neue Super Apple Watch trägt und meint, vielleicht kann ich mit der Uhr auf mein Handy verzichten. Sein Urteil war ziemlich gut. Er ist ein Typ, der jeden Tag ein neues Handy hat, weil er die ganze Zeit diese Unbox-Videos macht. Er hat dann solange der Akku hielt, auf sein Handy verzichtet und nur die Uhr benutzt. Es waren also zwei Tage, er konnte sich durch die Stadt navigieren, er konnte mit seinen Liebsten in Kontakt bleiben. Alles, was er notwendigerweise brauchte, konnte er erledigen. Aber er hat auch den Vorteil genossen, nicht immer gleich bei jedem Quatsch zum Handy zu greifen, nur weil man noch drei Minuten zu killen ist. In deren Sicht könnte jetzt auch dieser technische Fortschritt uns wieder ein bisschen wegführen vom Handy. Na wie auch immer. Letzter Tipp da nur, Männer müssen ein bisschen aufpassen, wenn sie dann zugewandt und selbstsicher in der Übung mit Fremden zu reden, dann können sie auch manchmal Frauen gegenüber etwas und so. Da muss man dann drauf achten. Aber ansonsten feuerfrei, was die Begegnungen und Gespräche mit Fremden angeht.
Wenn man denn die entsprechenden Codes beherrscht, was uns zu einem Buch der Soziologin Hannelore Bublez führt, die verborgenen Codes der Erben über die soziale Magie und das Spiel der Eliten. Ich hatte mir unter dem Buch eigentlich was ganz anderes vorgestellt. Ich dachte, es sei wirklich eine Studie in dem Sinne, dass sich angesehen wird, wie die Eliten ihre Codes pflegen, welche sie haben, wie sie vererbt werden. Aber es ist eher so eine theoretische Abhandlung, so dass ich, auch wenn unser Influencer Buch sehr, sehr ausführlich und positiv rezipiert wird, gewisse Abstriche machen muss. Insofern, als wir es hier mit einer Bourdieu-Ré-Lektüre zu tun haben, wir wissen Pierre Bourdieu, wichtiger französischer Soziologe, der sich nicht so sehr mit dem ökonomischen Kapital, sondern mit dem sozialen Kapital beschäftigte und dem damit einhergehenden kulturellen Kapital. Dieser Kapitalbegriff wurde dann von der Soziologie auch noch stärker erweitert und ausdifferenziert. Jedenfalls geht es darum, dass es neben dem ökonomischen Kapital auch etwas gibt, womit wir ausgestattet werden, aufgrund unserer Herkunft, der Erziehung, die wir durchmachen, dem Umfeld, in dem wir uns bewegen, das für uns ein ganzes Leben lang wichtig ist, beziehungsweise dass man vieles auch nur schwerlich abstreifen kann. Also von Bourdieu, der aus einfachen Verhältnissen stammt, war es auch zum Beispiel immer so ein Anliegen, nicht mehr zurückgeführt zu werden, wenn er spricht auf seine eigentliche Herkunft. Also er lebte in Paris und wollte auch nur als ein solcher Nachworter, wollte nur als ein solcher dann auch wahrgenommen werden. Nun, wir haben ja schon einen Begriff, der doch ganz hilfreich ist. Soziale Magie, von der Bublitz hier schreibt. Also was ist es eigentlich, dass uns zu erkennen gibt, mit wem wir es da eigentlich zu tun haben? Bublitz schreibt, was zählt, ist soziale Ähnlichkeit. Ausschlaggebend für den sozialen Erfolg sind frühe Weichenstellungen und unterschwellige Mechanismen, die signifikant von der sozialen Herkunft abhängen. Das Beherrschen eines ganz bestimmten Zeichensystems, Dinge, Haltungen und Fertigkeiten sichern den gesellschaftlichen Eliten Macht. Exklusives Kulturellungsbildungskapital sichert die Reproduktion von kulturellen Privilegien. Es spielt denjenigen in die Hände, die die Magie der Rekrutierung von Eliten und deren Codes beherrschen. Wer die falschen Codes besitzt und die der Privilegierten nicht dekodieren kann, ist automatisch draußen. Was beschreibt sie hier? Nun, an jeder wird es kennen, man betritt irgendwelche Räume, in denen man üblicherweise nicht zu Hause ist. Ganz klassisch wäre das natürlich so etwas wie ein Empfang in einer Bank oder so etwas. Und wenn man selbst nicht Banker ist und sich in der Finanzwelt herumtreibt, dann wird man vielleicht Schwierigkeiten haben, sich dort selbstsicher auf dem Parkett zu verhalten. Vor allem wird man auch merken, dass man irgendwie nicht dazugehört. Und die anderen werden es auch merken. Vielleicht haben manche noch die Szenen aus Ice White Shut vor Augen mit Tom Cruise, der in dieser Geheimgesellschaft ist, wo gewisse erotische Rituale gepflegt werden. Und obwohl er maskiert ist, obwohl man ihn eigentlich nicht erkennen kann, erkennt man ihn doch als denjenigen, der hier nicht reingehört. Und das ist ein Gefühl, das sicherlich viele Leute oder alle Leute kennen, auf die eine oder andere Weise. Aber was jetzt hier im Buch die verborgenen Codes der Erben deutlich gemacht wird, ist, dass natürlich solche Codes vererbt werden, dass es gewisse editäre Codes gibt, die mitunter sich zwar verändern können, die aber doch dafür sorgen, dass man nicht nur aufgrund des Bankkontos sich von den anderen unterscheiden kann, sondern auch aufgrund der Art, wie man spricht, wie man isst, was man trägt. Ein weiteres Beispiel, das kennst du vielleicht, du bist ja auch Jim Carrey Fan. Jim Carrey hat doch mal in einer Talkshow nachgemacht, wie reiche Leute auf Partys lachen. Ich kann es nur jedem empfehlen, sich das anzusehen. Also er schreibt dann erst, wie normale Leute lachen, wenn jemand einen Witz macht und so, ha ha ha, ja. Aber reiche Leute, weil sie es sich erlauben können, lachen wirklich in einer extrovertierten, überschwänglich-weise rastenförmig aus, weil sie so reich sind, können sie sich das leisten. Und das ist quasi ein Code, an dem man die zukünftigen Erben erkennen kann. So etwas wird hier in diesem Buch dann an vielen Beispielen deutlich gemacht, aus der Literatur interessanterweise. Es geht hier nicht um Forschung unter Eliten, sondern die Autorin hat sich zum Beispiel dann auch so einen Roman wie American Psycho angesehen. Buble schreibt, wir alle sind Erben. Also auch wenn wir kein Geld erben, dann ist es trotzdem so, dass wir etwas geerbt haben von unseren Vorfahren, meistens dann von den Eltern oder anderen engen Verwandten. Wie nämlich man sich verhält, welche Minen man zu welchen Situationen zieht, das sind einfach Dinge, die durch Nachahmung entstehen. Sprache ist natürlich etwas ganz Entscheidendes. Und das ist etwas, was natürlich sehr schwer zu überwinden ist. Also womit auch diese meritokratischen Versprechen von der Leistungsgesellschaft sehr schnell an Grenzen stoßen. Schon deshalb, weil man diese Codes erst einmal nicht hat, die die anderen einfach von klein auf eingeübt haben, wie man sich durch ein Museum bewegt, wie man am Abendessen geht, wie man Menschen begrüßt, all diese Dinge, das wird hier dann in verschiedenen Facetten ausgeführt und erläutert. Es geht dann auch um die sozialen Medien, inwieweit da ein Status erworben wird. Und immer wieder kommt es dann darum, wie auch der Konsum von Luxusobjekten natürlich auch einen gewissen Habitus hervorbringt. Also ich will es kurz machen. Dieses Buch ist interessant für Leute, die sich mit Baudieu beschäftigen wollen und Baudieu jetzt ein bisschen weiterverfolgen wollen. Es ist aber jetzt wirklich kein Buch für Leute, die sich informieren wollen, wie funktioniert eigentlich die Elite, welche Codes hat sie. Es sind einzelne Überlegungen, die man von dort mitnehmen kann, wie zum Beispiel nicht das Vertrauen in Diplome und Zeugnisse schiebt Menschen nach oben, wie die offizielle Darstellung es will. Die Dinge halten vielmehr diejenigen, die bereits an der Spitze sind oben. Diejenigen, die von vornherein die falsche Kultur, die falschen Codes und das falsche Dekodierungswissen mitbringen, müssen den ihnen angelegten Nachteil überwinden, dass sie die falschen Hebel in Bewegung setzen, die falschen Dispositionen und die falsche Sprache zur Anwendung bringen. Es ist keine Bildungsbenachteiligung, sondern vor allem eine Benachteiligung, die auf kulturellen Defiziten beruht, und zwar nicht solchen, die die Aneignung von Bildung und Wissen betreffen, sondern solche, die sich auf die verborgenen Codes der Kommunikation und des Austauschs beziehen. Denn die Herstellung des Adels bzw. der Erben erfordert, spezifische, magische Praktiken und Techniken, die gewährleisten, dass aus Erben wirkliche Erben werden, die den Nachlass nicht nur verwalten, sondern ihn vermehren. Erben werden also gemacht, sie werden nicht einfach vorgefunden. Ich glaube, man kann sich mit diesen Überlegungen durch die Gesellschaft bewegen, kann mal diese Codes studieren, kann es natürlich in der Literatur im Film gut nachvollziehen, aber was vielleicht ein gewisses Problem der Soziologie ist, wenn es da so Überväter gibt wie Bourdieu oder wir sehen das ja auch bei den Epigonen von Luhmann, es gibt doch so eine gewisse Tendenz, dass wenn man dann auf diese Gründerväter aufbaut, man sehr stark verleitet ist, sie unaufhörlich zu zitieren, sodass man fast noch mal ein weiteres Bourdieu Buch bekommt. Und eigentlich wäre es doch ganz gut, wenn man bei solchen Abhandlungen so auf den ersten 20 Seiten noch mal ganz kurz gesagt bekommt, hier das sind die Bezugspunkte, Bourdieu oder Luhmann meinte dies und das. Darauf baue ich jetzt auf. Glaubt mir, ich habe Luhmann und Bourdieu gelesen. Ich zitiere das aber jetzt im Weiteren nicht permanent, sondern versuche jetzt auch ein bisschen davon loszukommen und eigenes zu etablieren. Und das ist ein großes Problem doch bei der Soziologie, aber nicht nur dort, dass man sehr häufig dann Bourdieu oder Luhmann oder sonst einen der ganz Großen noch mal paraphrasiert.
Ja, das stimmt. Es treiben einen aber auch die Professoren so ein bisschen aus, indem sie so die Seminararbeiten auf ihre Weise lesen. Und am Ende ist der Schreibstil, den man da lernt, nicht mehr kompatibel mit so einer Außenwelt, die man dann irgendwie finden muss.
Dass es dann ganz gut, dass Bublitz so mutig ist und einfach so ein paar Szenen schildert. Also sie hat immer dann jedem Kapitel vorangestellt. Szenen, bei denen nicht so ganz klar ist, inwieweit sie fiktiv sind, inwieweit sie die auch der Wirklichkeit abgeschaut hat. Dass dann einfach so ein Kapitel beginnt mit drei Zimmer für fünf Personen sozialer Wohnungsbau der 50er Jahre. Sie war im elterlichen Schlafzimmer untergebracht. Die Brüder teilten sich das Kinderzimmer. Mit zwölf oder dreizehn wich sie an den Sonntagen in die Kirche aus. Sie gewährte ihr zwei Stunden Aufenthalt, erst im Erwachsenen-Gottesdienst, dann im Kindergottesdienst, immer in der eiskalten Kirche. Später fuhr sie mit den Rollschuhen unter den Augen des ganzen Wohnblocks die Straße auf und ab, hoch und runter, raus aus der engen Wohnung, in der ein unberechenbarer Vater allen Raum einnahm und man nie wusste, was kam. Also was dadurch ich also das ist dann für mich viel wertvoller als zehn Seiten Redaktüre Baudieu, weil hier einfach eine unglaubliche analytische Stärke schon drin liegt, dass natürlich jemand, der genau in diesen Verhältnissen aufwächst, über diese Codes, die man haben muss, wenn man in irgendeiner Society sich bewegt, nicht so einfach herstellbar sind.
Genau, und ich schließe mal direkt daran an, denn was da für Erfahrungen gemacht werden, sind ja Fremdheitserfahrungen, über die auch Michel Friedman schreibt, allerdings nicht soziologisch aufgeladen, sondern sonst irgendwie, sondern aus ganz eigener, eigentlich impressionistischer Perspektive. Auf eine Art und Weise, wie wir das bisher noch nie gesehen haben, ich jedenfalls nicht. Und selten hat sich jemand, wenn man dann das Buch, das Cover finde ich ein bisschen schräg, da ist so ein blaues Ding drauf, ich weiß gar nicht genau, warum es passt und wie es ausgewählt wurde, aber egal, wenn man es dann in die Hand nimmt und aufschlägt. Und mein Erstkontakt war nicht über, ich mache es auf und lese, sondern Michel Friedman sitzt auf der Bühne und erzählt einfach davon. Und er hat einen Schauspieler mitgebracht, oder es wurde ihm an eine Seite gesetzt, Peter Schröder vom Schauspiel Frankfurt, der dann eben noch Passagen liest und so. Und man denkt sich so, das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig eigen. Also ich will auch mal auf Seite 1 hier reinlesen, nicht weil ich glaube, ich bin ein besonders toller Leser oder so, sondern ich werde mal auf Zeile betonen. Also jede Zeile für sich, wie Friedman die so reingeschrieben hat. Dann erkennt man glaube ich so ein bisschen, wie es gemeint ist. Kapitel 1 von Kapitel 54, sie tragen keine Titel, sie sind einfach durchnummeriert. Und dann schreibt er, ich bin auf einem Friedhof geboren. Schmerz, der keinen Anfang kennt, der kein Ende kennt, manchmal leise, manchmal laut, manchmal versteckt er sich. Launisch ist er, hungrig ist er, hinterhältig. Meine Mutter, mein Vater, meine Großmutter, überlebende, trauernde, traurige, lebens traurige. Ich war ihr Lächeln, lächelnde Traurigkeit. Und dann geht das einfach 150 Seiten in dieser Tonalität. Also man hat ganz enge Zeilen. Auf den ersten Blick würde man sagen, das ist irgendwie Poesie oder so. Aber nein, es ist nicht als Poesie gedacht. Es ist einfach nur so geschrieben, wie er halt meinte, so muss ich es schreiben. Und ich will es auch so schreiben. Und wenn es so nicht angenommen wird, täte mir das in meinem Herzen weh. Aber er hat die Erfahrung gemacht, die Leute nehmen es irgendwie gut an. Es ist also eine Form, die zum einen, wie du vorhin schon mal anmerktest, brauchen wir ein Metaverse? Nee, wir haben doch Film. Und dann kann man sich die Frage stellen, brauchen wir einen Film? Wir haben doch Bücher. Und dann brauchen wir Bücher? Wir haben doch Worte. Und er hat es komplett reduziert auf dieses, ich habe nur meine Worte. Alles andere findet in meinem Kopf statt. Und dann versuche ich mal, wie zu wenig wie möglich Worte, so viel wie möglich bei euch in den Köpfen stattfinden zu lassen. Und wenn das der Anspruch ist, muss ich sagen, es ist wirklich eine Weltmeisterschaftsleistung, so mit Text umzugehen. Insbesondere in dieser aufgeregten Zeit, in der man immer Sorgen hat, sein Buch überhaupt noch verkauft zu kriegen. Und dann Verlage kreuz und quer. Diese Erfahrung haben wir jetzt nicht gemacht. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die so wirklich hauptberuflich Bücher schreiben. Vielleicht nicht mal unter ihrem eigenen Namen, die sich also komplett zum Markt ausliefern. Oder so ein Verlag, der angeblich weiß, wie der Markt funktioniert und wie auch immer. Und am Ende kommt der Autor da gar nicht zur Geltung. Und Friedman hat hier in einer Art und Weise in sein eigenes Buch reinregiert. Das ist unglaublich. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass ich hier der Lektor überhaupt traute, noch irgendwie einen Komma umzusetzen oder einen Zeilenumbruch mal rauszunehmen oder so. Sondern einfach, nee, Friedman hat Text geliefert, okay, bitte drucken. Herr Friedman, sind Sie einverstanden mit diesem Umbruch der Seiten und so? Einfach nur noch entgegennehmen, sozusagen. Und diesen Text aufs, das ist ja immer so ein schöner Spruch, aufs maximale reduziert, was will der Autor uns sagen. Er sagt es uns einfach. Er schreibt es hier rein. Es ist impressionistisch in der Hinsicht formal gesehen. Es kommt inhaltlich auch viel bei rum. Also so ist es nicht. Es werden die richtigen Signalworte geliefert. Und ich fand es dann überraschend. Auf der Bühne, wenn er darüber redet, fällt immer mal wieder das Wort Wirlinge. Was mich total fasziniert. Weil wir ja diesen Megadiskurs haben. Minderheiten da, Minderheiten überall. Minderheiten setzen sich durch. Minderheiten verbünden sich. Minderheiten sind vielleicht sogar zusammengenommen. Mehrheiten. Aber was für Mehrheiten? Sind ja doch wieder in sich Minderheiten. Und was steht dem eigentlich gegenüber? Und die Antwort ist der Wirling. Der Wirling und die Wirlinge. Als diese undefinierbare Gemeinschaft, der man sich so ausgeliefert fühlt. Und man muss sich jedes Mal neu überlegen, bin ich jetzt eigentlich Wirling oder nicht? Und Friedmans ganz wichtige Botschaft ist, du kannst in Deutschland keine Frau sein, keinen Migrationshintergrund haben, kein Jude sein. Und du gehörst trotzdem nicht immer zu den Wirling. Also ist das Problem der Minderheiten immer auch deins. Du musst nur mit einem falschen Gesichtsausdruck mit sieben Jahren auf dem Schulhof aufkreuzen und zack, wirst du der Hobbs genommen und dann wird dir gesagt, du gehörst hier nicht zu den Wirling. Und das kann das einzige Mal in deinem Leben bleiben, dass dir das passiert. Aber irgendwann passiert es jedem. Und da steckt diese große Lehre drin, weshalb man sich mit dieser Idee des Fremdseins der anderen beschäftigen muss, um auch sein eigenes Fremdsein, den Wirling ausgeliefert sein, so ein bisschen zu verstehen und diese Transferleistung zu erbringen. Auch in dem Moment, wo man richtig weiß, ich bin hier ein Wirling, zu sehen, da sind aber nicht alle Wirlinge hier und dann auch Rücksicht zu nehmen. Und das ist ihm wirklich atemberaubend gut gelungen. Also wirklich eine Sensation. Dieses Buch sollte man sich in dem Fall dann wirklich gedruckt kaufen, einfach nur, um es im Regal stehen zu haben, um zu zeigen, ja, ich weiß Bescheid. Wir sind hier alle Fremd. Es ist ja mein eigenes Anliegen im Buch gewesen, dass Menschen so über die Schicksalshaftigkeit der alten Republik lesen, dass sie verstehen, ich bin nicht selber schuld an meiner zu hohen Miete, an meinem zu schlechten Arbeitsvertrag und so weiter. Es sind nicht meine Defizite, sondern sie sind strukturell. Und wenn wir uns begegnen, können wir uns alle darüber verständigen, dass wir hier alle Loser sind. Und nicht gegenseitig das Spiel der angeblichen Gewinner, der sich vorgaugelnden Gewinner weiterspielen. So und genau so eine Einladung ist dieses Fremdbuch von Friedman auch. Wir können alle mal nachlesen, dass jeder Fremd ist. In unterschiedlichem Maße. Nicht jeder wird 18 Jahre lang als Staatenloser in Paris, einer jüdischen Familie, kurz nach dem Krieg aufwachsen, nur so wie er. Und dann nach Deutschland kommen und es ist dann auch so, also es ist wirklich krass, wie er das beschreibt, wie man so ankommt. Und in der Ausländerbehörde als Kind den eigenen Eltern ausgeliefert. Und dann aber auch erleben, wie die Eltern der Ausländerbehörde ausgeliefert sind. Da macht nämlich jemand einfach seinen Alltag. Und kann gar nicht mehr registrieren, dass alle Menschen, die vor ihm sitzen, gerade den wichtigsten Moment ihres Lebens haben. Nämlich die Frage, werde ich jetzt eigentlich Staatsbürger hier? Ja oder nein. Und dann sitzt also so ein Wirling da und ihm gegenüber so eine Masse an Fremden. Und er ist aber alleine, aber ist trotzdem der Wirling. Also ganz grandios geschrieben, grandios konzipiert, einfach grandios dann gemacht, so an seinem Schreibtisch zu Hause. Ich stelle mir das so ganz romantisch vor, wie er einfach sagt, hier ist mein Text. Und auf der Bühne wird dann noch so ein bisschen. Wir wissen ja, dass Friedman auch so ein Überwältiger ist, der Einzige, der jemals schlingsiv Schachmatt gesetzt hat mit einem Schnitzel und so. Das ist ja auch erstaunlich. Aber dass so eine Figur wie Friedman hier nochmal so ganz das Innere nach außen stellt und sagt, Leute, ich stelle mich jetzt auf die Bühne und rede mal über wirklich krasse Geschichten. Also hier stehen auch wirklich krasse Geschichten drin, wo ich denke, muss man sich schon trauen, das zu schreiben, welche Unterdrückungserfahrung man auf Schulhöfen so gemacht hat. Aber in der Ansicht Hut ab. Ein wirklich tolles Ding. Und empfehle ich wirklich zur Lektüre. Und wer es verpasst hat, Friedman da mal auf der Bühne zu sehen. Zu diesem Buch. Also nicht Friedman allgemein auf der Bühne. Das wissen wir alle. Da kann man ihn mögen oder nicht. Aber zu diesem Buch auf der Bühne. Es gibt morgen im Jüdischen Museum in Frankfurt eine Veranstaltung, zu der es keine mehr Karten mehr gibt. Und ich bin auch nicht in der Stadt. Aber das Jüdische Museum überträgt ja live. Also Samira und Michel Friedman.
Ah ja, Samira moderiert das.
Genau, morgen im Jüdischen Museum. Und es gibt live bei YouTube übertragen. Kann man sich also währenddessen oder danach mal anschauen. Es macht einen großen Unterschied. Ich habe Friedman im Literaturhaus gesehen. 90 Minuten. Also wirklich bewegend und spektakulär. Auf der Buchmesse eine halbe Stunde. Also keine Ahnung, was Moderatoren des hessischen Rundfunks glauben, wie schlecht sie in der Veranstaltung organisieren und durchziehen können. So, aber ja, ich glaube morgen im Jüdischen Museum, das ist dann auch noch mal so ein bisschen Heimspiel für ihn, das Buch dann da noch mal so zu besprechen. Mal sehen, ich kann es empfehlen, sich das dann mal anzuschauen, glaube ich.
Wunderbar. Du hast mir jetzt große Lust darauf gemacht und ich bin sehr gespannt. Zum Schluss noch, ich mache schnell ein Text, der mir von einem Freund geschickt wurde und ich war erst verwundert, denn es geht in diesem Text um Sport und dieser Freund weiß, dass ich damit nichts zu tun habe, schon gar nicht Sport gucken. Dieser Text ist überschrieben mit den Worten, Moneyball for everything has done to American culture. You can make a thing so perfect that it's ruined. Dieser Text ist in The Atlantic erschienen von Derek Thompson und diese Autos schildert erst einmal, wie das früher war. Wenn man samstags oder sonntags da saß, hat mit den Eltern Baseball auf dem Sofa geschaut. Alle waren froh und es gab so die Rituale. Und jetzt kann man da sehr nostalgisch werden, aber man weiß inzwischen ist etwas passiert im Profisport, nämlich die Moneyballisierung. Moneyball, den Film kennst du vielleicht auch, mit Jonah Hill, wo es darum geht, dass man versucht, Baseball zu optimieren, indem man strategisch, mathematisch an die Sache angeht. Also wie muss das eigentlich positioniert werden? Ein Film, den ich da noch mal sehr zur nächsten neuen Sichtung empfehle, nachdem man den Text gelesen hat. Nach der, es gab so Stereoid-Skandale, Doping und alles Mögliche. Und irgendwie war das schon alles nicht so toll. Aber was hat wirklich Baseball unterminiert? Und der Autor sagt, das war die Mathematik. Die analytische Revolution, die mit der als Moneyball bekannten Bewegung begann, führte zu einer Reihe von offensiven und defensiven Anpassungen, die sagen wir mal katastrophal erfolgreich waren. Auf der Suche nach Strikeouts erhöhten die Manager die Anzahl der Pitcher pro Spiel und steigerten die durchschnittliche Geschwindigkeit und Spin-Rate pro Pitcher. Die Schlagmänner reagierten darauf, indem sie die Abflugwinkel ihrer Schwünge vergrößerten, was die Chancen auf die auf einen Home Run erhöhte, aber Strikeouts wahrscheinlicher machte. Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung von Baseball. Ich weiß nur, dass der Autor hier wohl kritisiert, dass man also nur noch nach mathematischen Formeln versucht, diese Spielaufstellung vorzunehmen und dadurch eigentlich den spielerischen Charakter diesem Spiel entreißt. Er bringt das dann auch mit Zahlen in Anschlag. In den 1990er Jahren gab es in jedem Spiel in der Regel 50 Prozent mehr Hits als Strikeouts. Heute gibt es durchweg mehr Strikeouts als Hits. Die Zahl ist also auf einen und das führt dann dazu, dass man eigentlich total langweilige Spiele produziert hat, die aber mathematisch betrachtet sehr sinnvoll sind, sie so zu organisieren. Wahrscheinlich werden jetzt alle gerade mit den Augenrollen, die sich mit Baseball auskennen, wie ich darüber spreche. Aber es geht hier nur mal um die These an so Mathematik hat die Spiele so langweilig werden lassen. Sie laufen jetzt perfekt ab. Es ist alles im Sinne von, wie bekommen wir schnell eine hohe Punktzahl, perfekt gelaufen. Aber für diejenigen, die eigentlich gerne diese Spiele schauen, ist es nicht besonders angenehm.
Ich nehme an, es geht darum, dass man auch mal einen Home Run, der erfolgreich ist, sehen will. Ich kenne das ja vom Fußball, wenn die Mannschaftsaufstellung so lautet, dass sieben Leute verteidigen. Man verhindert damit Tore. Das ist ganz schön und gut. Aber man würde nie einen tollen Angriff sehen. Weder der Mannschaft, die gar nicht dazu kommt, gegen sieben Abwehrspieler einen tollen Angriff zu organisieren, noch bei der anderen Mannschaft, die gar nicht so viele Spiele auf dem Feld hat, die einen tollen Angriff machen können, weil alle in der Verteidigung feststecken. Und das scheint hier auch so eine Optimierung zu sein.
Exakt. Wenn universelle Intelligenz zu universellen Strategien führt, kann dies zu einem homogeneren Produkt führen. Nehmen Sie die NBA. Wenn jedes Basketball-Team erkennt, dass drei Punkte 50 Prozent mehr wert sind als zwei Punkte, wird in der gesamten Liga eine Flut von drei Punktewürfen eingeführt, um diese Diskrepanz auszunutzen. Vor der Saison 2011-12 hatte die Liga als Ganzes im Durchschnitt nie mehr als 20 Dreipunkteveruche pro Spiel verzeichnet. In diesem Jahr versucht kein Team weniger als 25 Dreier pro Spiel, vier Teams sogar 40. Interessanterweise ist nun aber, dass das nicht bei der Sportbetrachtung bleibt, sondern er schaut sich dann die Billboard Shards an. Er sagt, früher war das mit den Shards so eine Sache, da hat man so Zahlen rausgegeben, aber so richtig genau wusste niemand. Inzwischen hat man die Methodik dieser Billboard Shards geändert, man hat also objektivere Daten nun und kann jetzt wirklich sagen, was wird dann gehört, was nicht. Die Shards veränderten sich über Nacht und das hat schon in den 90er Jahren begonnen. Rock'n'Roll Bands wurden verdrängt und Hip-Hop und Country erlebten einen Aufsprung. Als die Shards ehrlicher wurden, wurden sie auch statischer. Beliebte Songs halten sich länger als früher. Dieses statische können wir sehen, wenn Taylor Swift auf zehn Plätzen vertreten ist. Eine Analyse der Geschichte der Popmusikstile ergab, dass Rap und Hip-Hop die amerikanische Popmusik länger dominiert haben als jedes andere Musikgenre. Als die analytische Revolution in der Musik zunahm, wurden die Wiedergabelisten im Radio immer repetitiver und die beliebtesten Songs immer ähnlicher. Dann schaute sich das an mit den Filmen. Auch da hat man versucht zu berechnen, was ist am lokrativsten, wo lohnt sich das Investment. Und sagt dann für 2019 hier, zu den größten Filmen nach Einspielergebnissen gehören zwei Marvel-Fortsetzungen, zwei Animationsfilm-Fortsetzungen, ein Reboot eines Blockbusters aus den 90ern und ein Batman-Spinoff. Wie sieht es im Jahr 22 aus? Zu den zehn umsatzstärksten Filmen gehörten zwei Marvel-Fortsetzungen, eine Zeichentrickfilm-Fortsetzung, ein Reboot eines 90er-Jahre-Blockbusters und ein Batman-Spinoff. Also die Studios wollen den vorhersehbaren Zuschauer, sie produzieren entsprechendes und es hat Erfolg. Es hat Erfolg und wird deshalb dann ständig wiederholt. Wir sind also in einer Welt angekommen, wo eigentlich das, was wir an der Kunst oder auch vielleicht am Sport lieben, also der Überschuss, der Überschwang, negiert wird, weil das eigentlich statistisch gesehen nicht besonders sinnvoll ist, diesen Überschwang zu haben. Und so kommt es dann, dass wir einen kulturellen Monibalismus haben und dieser opfert in dem Lichte die Überschwänglichkeit zugunsten einer formelhaften Symmetrie. Er opfert die Vielfalt zugunsten der Vertrautheit. Er löst endliche Spiele auf zu Kosten von unendlichen Spielen. Seine Genialität stumpft die rauen Kanten der Unterhaltung ab. Ich denke, das ist wert, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen. Wir hatten ja ähnliche Überlegungen auch von Martin scorsese bezüglich auf die Filmwelt. Wurde er sehr für kritisiert. Aber ich glaube, wir haben da tatsächlich einen wirklich kulturellen Aspekt, der uns noch gar nicht so in der Dimension bewusst ist. Wir haben zwar eine große Diversity-Debatte, aber wie stark die Kulturindustrie homogenisiert, noch viel stärker als das Adorno und Horkheimer im Kulturindustrie-Kapitel der Dialektik der Aufklärung vorausgesehen haben, das ist noch gar nicht so bewusst, weil das auch wieder so eine Sache ist. Wie spürt man es? Hier hat man dann mal so Zahlen und denkt, da scheint sich ja wirklich was bei den Spielen verändert zu haben oder in den Chats oder sonst was. Aber so richtig spüren wir das noch nicht. Mich liegt es immer so an, wenn ich alleine irgendwo in Bars oder Restaurants sitze und da so auf die Musik achte, die mir so da eingespielt wird. Ich liebe dann ja noch den Traditionsitaliener, der mir noch Albano und Romina Power serviert, aber es ist oft einfach nur noch ein Gestampe, das irgendwie nach moderner Musik klingt, aber ich kann es eigentlich gar nicht mehr orten. Es ist auch für mich nicht mehr unterscheidbar von dem, was überall läuft.
Ja, deswegen, wo kriegt man unseren Kick nachher? Es wird schwieriger.
Wir gehen nicht wie Opa oder wir, ich glaube, oder das ist ja die Tragik. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es das nicht gibt, sondern es wird ja verdeckt und es gibt ja so viele andere tolle Musik und es ist ja nicht nur die Oper, sondern es gibt ja so viele Musiker, die kaum Chancen bekommen oder so. Also es gibt ganz vieles, was man sehen kann. Ich glaube, man muss bewusster danach suchen und das, glaube ich, geht dann doch wieder stärker in der analogen Welt. Und wenn man einfach mal schaut, was kommt gerade in dem Kulturzentrum nebenan, in dem Stadttheater oder so, da muss man ja sagen, hat der Föderalismus in Deutschland wirklich viel, viel Positives hervorgebracht, dass wir eine sehr vielfältige Kultur haben, die vielfältiger ist als das, was uns ein paar Playlists angezeigt wird.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Und Opa heißt deswegen immer, erst mit wem klären und dann wohin. Genau. Wird auch Spaß machen. Sehr gut, dann haben wir alle Lektüren. Weitere gab es nicht.
Weitere gab es nicht.
Oder? Vielleicht haben wir auch ein bisschen. Wir sind ja offen für Empfehlungen. Wir nehmen ja jede Empfehlung entgegen.
Genau.
Für November nehme ich mir auch mal vor, mehr Bücher zu lesen. Jetzt, wo Bonos da ist, das reizt mich ja schon.
Oh Gott, ja, dann müssen wir das, da muss aber noch, das ist ja schon fast eine Triggerwarnung.
Ja, aber da fallen auf jeden Fall viele, viele Biographielgeschichten bei ab.
Aber Bruno selbst ist doch schlimm, oder?
Naja, aber...
Dieser Weltverbesserer mit sieben Steueroasen.
Genau, aber der geübte YouTube-Hörer weiß ja, wie er skip, skip, skip zum nächsten Titel in Live-Aufnahmen skippt und dich das Gequatsche einfach spart.
Okay. Ja, also, liebe Salon-Freunde, es kommen harte Minuten, wenn Stefan auslässt. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall, das können wir schon wahrscheinlich kein Buch, das wir zusammen lesen werden.
Wir werden uns was anderes suchen. Sehr gut.
Alles klar. Schönen Monat.
Yes, haut rein.